Ich habe es verpasst. Wo war ich an dem Abend? Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Wasted Love heißt der Titel.
Hast du alles gesehen?
Nein, um Gottes Willen. War es zu Recht der Siegertitel? Keine Ahnung,
ich gucke ESC nie. Ich dachte, damit korrektiert man damit.
Dass man es sieht.
Ja, das ist wohl so. Aber für mich ist das einfach zum größten Teil Musik, die ich nicht aushalte.
Ich glaube, dieser Titel ist recht gut, wenngleich mich mehr interessieren würde,
JJ in einer klassischen Rolle zu sehen. Denn er hat ja auch Auftritte in der
Staatsoper in Wien und er hat eine sehr berühmte Gesangslehrerin, nämlich Linda Wurzen.
Das ist eine große Wagner-Interpretin und sie legt auch Wert darauf,
dass er kein Countertenor ist.
Also Countertenöre singen ja in so einer Altstimme eigentlich,
klingen auch so eine Mischung aus Knabe und Frau. und er aber tatsächlich kommt in Sopranhöhen.
Und das ist sehr beeindruckend, wie hoch er mühelos gelangt.
Also du bist auch beeindruckend. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine beeindruckende Leistung.
Wenn gleich ich sagen würde, für ihn wird jetzt das Lied zu singen gar nicht das Schwerste sein.
Er hat, wenn er klassische Partien singt, sicherlich stimmlich größere Herausforderungen.
Da geht es ja noch um Performance und alles Mögliche. Aber es ist natürlich wieder so ein Phänomen,
dass das ja von einem Publikum geschieht, das zum größten Teil nicht vertraut
ist mit klassischer Musik und jetzt auch nicht mit Counterteneuren oder mit
Barockopern und die hören das und finden das so unglaublich,
dass es das gibt und da kann man natürlich sagen,
ja Moment mal, das gibt es ganz ganz oft.
Da geht mal ins Theater, seht euch Barockopern an.
Oft werden die auch mit Counterteneuren oder auch mit Männer-Sopran-Stimmen besetzt.
Man kann auch abseits vom ESC hohe Stimmen, schöne Stimmen gesungen von Männern hören.
Ja, das habe ich jedenfalls mitbekommen davon. Sonst geht der ESC an mir vorüber.
Sehr gut. Wir sind ja auch immer nur drei Minuten. Das Publikum wird ja nicht wirklich...
Beschäftigt damit, nur kurz befasst und dann findet man es gut.
Kennt man ja von Paul Potts, damals X-Factor, der ja auch plötzlich diesen klassischen
Gesang auf diese Bühne brachte und schon nach dem zweiten Ton rastete das Publikum
aus, weil man es gar nicht ausgehalten hat, mal zuzuhören.
Wir gehen ja heute wieder in die Oper, drei Stunden. Ja, aus Ihnen ist das Programm heute.
Wir sind gespannt. Es wird ja noch immer über die Wehrpflicht debattiert.
Du hast vielleicht mitbekommen, dass der Frankfurter Allgemeinen am Sonntag
Pistorius ein Interview gegeben hat und meinte, ja,
vorerst gibt es keine Wehrpflicht, aber wenn das dann nicht so klappt mit der
Freiwilligkeit, müssen wir darüber nachdenken und Eva Högl hat das auch nochmal
so betont. Wir werden sehen.
Ist Eva Högl noch wer?
Nein, nein, sie ist nicht mehr, aber sie hat das auch nochmal so nachgeschoben,
dass das wahrscheinlich nicht nur freiwillig geht.
Kommt direkt mit der Impfpflicht, glaube ich.
Jedenfalls wird darüber auch im Feuilleton debattiert und wir werden uns jetzt
eine Feuilleton-Debatte im Radio anhören.
Zwei Feuilletonistinnen, Nele Polacek und Myrna Funk sprechen darüber,
dass die Wehrpflicht doch auch für Frauen eingeführt werden könnte und haben
da unterschiedliche Positionen.
Ich kenne ja deine Clips noch nicht, würde aber behaupten, dass das jetzt die
blödesten Clips sind, die wir heute zu hören bekommen.
Ich habe nachher Merz Clips.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also auch irgendwo.
Aber ich finde es schon von der Anlage her blöd, denn die Bundespolitiker in
Verantwortung sagen ja nicht ohne Grund erstmal keine Wehrpflicht,
wir machen einen Vorschlag, vielleicht schwedisches Modell und so weiter,
weil sie genau wissen, das ist schon schwierig.
Aber für Frauen, also eine Zweidrittelmehrheit in diesem Bundestag.
Sie sprechen natürlich jetzt darüber, muss das so sein? Sollte die Frau wehrfähig werden?
All diese Fragen werden jetzt verhandelt und wir versuchen mal dieses Niveau
der Debatte abzubilden.
Fangen wir mal an. Mirna Funk.
Für mich ist völlig klar, dass wenn wir über eine zukünftige Wehrpflicht sprechen,
dass die selbstverständlich Männer und Frauen inkludiert.
Und das ist im Gegensatz zu dem, was Jette Nitzert gesagt hat,
für mich selbstverständlich ein Zeichen emanzipatorischen Handelns und auch
einer gleichberechtigten Gesellschaft in Deutschland.
Alle müssen. Nele Polatschek sagt Folgendes.
Wenn man einen Staat schützen möchte, dann deswegen, weil er weiter bestehen soll.
Damit ein Staat weiter bestehen kann, muss es Reproduktion geben.
Das heißt, Menschen müssen Kinder bekommen.
Diese Arbeit, das Reproduzieren, das Austragen und Gebären von Kindern,
wird in diesem Land wie in jedem anderen Land der Welt zu praktisch 100 Prozent von Frauen gemacht.
Und wir brauchen diese Arbeit. In dieser Situation,
wo wir sowieso eine Reproduktionsrate, in Deutschland korrigierte Rate von 1,36
Kindern pro Frau, wenn wir in dieser Situation sagen, wir nehmen jetzt unsere
Frauen im reproduktionsfähigen Alter, was ja eine begrenzte Zeit ist,
und zwingen die zur Wehrpflicht,
dann ist das eine sehr unvernünftige Art, einen Staat zu schützen.
Worüber reden wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich? Also sind wir jetzt tatsächlich
an dem Punkt, dass wir jetzt wieder sagen, wir gebären Kinder für den Staat?
Nele Polacek hatte dazu einen Artikel veröffentlicht und hat diese These vertreten
und der war aber so komisch geschrieben, dass ich dachte, sie meint das ironisch.
Also ich dachte, sie karikiert dieses die Frauen, Blut und Boden und so weiter.
Ich dachte, das sei eine Ironie von ihr. Aber die meinen das ernst in dieser Argumentation.
Ja, also wenn die Argumentation ist, Frauen können nicht zur Dienst an der Waffe
und damit den Dienst an den Staat herangezogen werden, weil sie ja schon den
Dienst am Kind und damit am Staat erbringen.
Ist ja völlig Banane.
Sie produzieren die Soldaten, die Kleinen.
Ja, war ja auch meine Erfahrung aus allen Diskussionen zur Alten Republik.
Nein, nicht für den Staat, sondern es geht hier um individuelle Kinderwünsche,
die man hat. Und dann lebt man halt ein Leben, wie man will und so.
Und für oder gegen Kinder, aber frei entschieden.
Und wenn man auswandern will, dann sagt man ja auch nicht, ich bin wahnsinnig
staatsfeindlich, weil ich auswandere.
Sondern man würde sagen, mein Lebensmittelpunkt ist jetzt Italien, gefällt mir besser.
Rom ist schön, warum soll ich in Frankfurt leben?
Dann würde man jetzt nicht sagen, ach du lieber Gott, dieser Vaterlandsverräter,
jetzt entzieht er sich und noch seine Kinder dem Staate Deutschland,
der das doch braucht, um verteidigungsfähig zu sein.
Also ich bin entsetzt darüber, dass wir jetzt auf diesem Niveau diskutieren
und auch wie mit dem Zwang umgegangen wird. Also wieder Nele Polacek.
Also du könntest jetzt morgen dich bei der Bundeswehr melden,
die würden dich mit Kusshand nehmen, das ist nicht die Frage.
Das sagt mir nach Funk und jetzt?
Jeder darf. Die Frage ist, wen zwingt man?
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt Nele Polacik. Also sie fragt sich,
ja, wen zwingt man? Also dass man offenbar Leute zwingt, ist erstmal so.
Müssen wir nur noch klären, ob es auch noch Frauen sein sollen.
Und jetzt werden Sie sich auch ein bisschen uneins wieder, wenn Sie darüber
diskutieren, über Zwang und all das?
Nee, wir reden nicht von neun Monaten. Wir reden bei der Wehrpflicht von sechs oder zwölf.
Nein, wir reden von einer Schwangerschaft von neun Monaten. Also wir reden hier
davon, Frauen völlig vom Wehrdienst zu entbinden, weil sie irgendwie vielleicht
einmal in ihrem Leben neun Monate lang schwanger sind. Das ist ja total absurd.
Mirna, mirna, neun Monate reichen nicht. Du brauchst, damit ein Land weiter
besteht, brauchst du zwei Kinder pro Frau.
Das sind nicht neun Monate, das sind 18 Monate.
Ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut, wie dein Buch schließt, dein Buch zur Rentnerrepublik,
also dein Buch, wie heißt es, Altenrepublik.
Das schließt ja damit, dass du sagst, wir brauchen eine Politik, dass Frauen...
2, so und so viele Kinder haben wollen.
Was aber nicht meinte, du machst eine Bevölkerungspolitik in dem Sinne,
dass du sagst, die Frauen sollen verpflichtet werden und du meintest auch nicht,
der Staat braucht das, sondern es gibt einen Kinderwunsch in der Gesellschaft.
Und der realisiert sich aber nicht oft, weil die Leute sagen,
ich kann mir eine größere Wohnung nicht leisten, ich weiß nicht,
ob ich einen Kita-Platz bekomme, was ist eigentlich, wenn meine Eltern nicht
auf das Kind aufpassen können.
All diese Fragen, die sie stellen, also gesellschaftliche Fragen,
die sind alle nicht beantwortet und deswegen haben viele Menschen einen Kinderwunsch,
den sie nicht realisieren oder dann sagen, dann lieber nur ein Kind,
ich hätte gerne zwei oder drei gehabt, aber mehr geht nicht.
Und da kann man sagen, da wird also ein individueller Wunsch durch eigentlich
Materialität, die da ist, die durch Umverteilung und so weiter hergestellt werden
könnte, wird dort untersagt.
Hier aber hat man die Idee, dass wirklich Paare Kinder zeugen,
um dann zu sagen, jetzt hat der
Staat wieder eins und ich muss aber auch mindestens dem Staat zwei geben.
Ich frage mich gerade, wie stehe ich eigentlich da mit keinem Kind?
Ja, also die Diskussion ist ja sowieso witzig, weil hier also diese Übereinanderlappung
von zwei Argumentationen für dieselbe Zahl, nämlich neun Monate,
ist ja also wirklich amüsant.
Neun Monate Wehrdienst oder neun Monate Schwangerschaft. Und dann als Gegenargument.
Ne neun Monate Schwangerschaft und dann neun Monate Wehrdienst.
So direkt nach der Entbindung geht's los. Und dann sagt sie,
nein, wir brauchen dafür noch viel, viel länger.
Und dann könnte man wiederkommen mit, ja genau, das Kind braucht ja mindestens
mal so sechs Jahre bis zur Schulfähigkeit und einen Lehrer auszubilden,
wenn man den gesellschaftlichen Bedarf kennt, dass man dann Betreuung,
und ich nehme jetzt mal Lehrerschaft nur als Betreuung, dass man da auch noch
ein bisschen Pädagogik macht, schön und gut,
die dauert ja auch genau diese sechs Jahre.
Also man könnte es eigentlich, wenn man es einfach runterbricht,
auf die Zahlen so machen.
Nur, du hast es ja angesprochen, ich habe es ja dann in der Kinderwüste nochmal,
also die Zahlen rausgesucht.
Es ist eine Erhebung der Bundesregierung selbst, die sagt, eigentlich haben
wir so viele Kinderwünsche, dass wir bei 2,4 Kindern pro Frau wären.
Wir sind aber nur, sie hat jetzt gesagt 1,36, also wir runden auf 1,4.
Es ist also genau ein Kind pro Frau, das sich gewünscht wird,
aber nicht kommt. Und der Wunsch ist ein ganz individueller.
Man hat den richtigen Partner, man ist auch schon in dem Leben angekommen.
Man weiß auch, 38 ist noch nicht zu spät, selbst mit 41 geht das noch.
Man kann noch ein Kind haben und man bekommt es trotzdem nicht. Warum nicht?
Und die Antwort ist, du hast es schon angedeutet, aber ich will es nochmal ganz
deutlich sagen, weil einem der Staat im Stich lässt. Der einzige Grund.
Jungfrauen führen eigentlich ein zufriedenes Leben, gerade in diesem 28 bis
32, da ist eigentlich alles soweit, der Kinderwunsch ist da,
in dem Alter auch am höchsten, der Partner ist da, alles ist da,
die Familie steht bereit, die Oma fragt schon immer und die Großmutter steht
bereit typischerweise und dann kommt es nicht dazu, weil einen der Staat in den Stich lässt.
Und in dieser Diskussion oder in dieser Gemengelage jetzt plötzlich zu sagen,
liebe junge Frau, jetzt lass mal den Staat nicht im Stich.
Ja.
Das ist doch grotesk.
Völlig irrsinnig. Und den Frauen wird es auch sehr helfen, wenn die Männer dann
abgeordnet werden, um eine Wehrpflicht abzuleisten. Das wird denen auch sehr helfen.
Du hast den Partner gerade gefunden und plötzlich sagt der Staat, ja er muss jetzt.
Ja.
Du bist gerade selber eben, jetzt starten wir ins Familienleben,
zack, ist der Partner mit.
Dann lieber alle oder so? Mirna Funk findet jetzt eigentlich die Moderne toll,
aber wo ist denn das Kollektiv geblieben?
Naja, die Sache ist natürlich die, dass wenn alle Personen eines Landes wehrpflichtig
sind und einen Teil ihrer Zeit zwischen ihrem 18. und 21.
Lebensjahr in einem System auch verbringen,
in dem es darum geht, Verteidigung zu lernen, gemeinschaftlich Verteidigung
zu lernen, zu verstehen, wozu man das macht,
dann prägt es natürlich eine Gesellschaft viel mehr und auf eine andere Art
und Weise, als wenn vereinzelte Individuen und gerade in der jungen Generation,
die sehr stark auf Individuation ausgerichtet sind, wogegen ich auch gar nichts habe.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn die Individuation so stark ist, dass das Kollektiv
nicht mehr gedacht wird und vor allem auch nicht das Land, in dem man lebt und
das einem ja auch die Freiheit und die Chancen dieser Individuation gibt.
Ja, diese unglaublichen Freiheiten, dass man schon bald ganz hohe Mieten zahlen
muss, wenn man das Elternhaus verlassen hat, das ist natürlich unbezahlbar.
Und dass man sich da nicht für opfern will, kann Mirna Funk aus ihrem Weltbüro gar nicht verstehen.
Also ich bin wirklich entsetzt, mit wie wenig man heute eine Feuilleton-Karriere hinbekommt.
Ja, ich finde das auch wirklich erschütternd, denn bislang war es so,
dass wir immer von Jugend mit Jugendkultur verbinden, dass die sich so dagegen
auflehnen irgendwie, gegen die Elterngeneration, gegen alles.
Diese Idee davon, dass man jetzt eine Jugend braucht, die sich in so einem kollektiven
Pflichtmodus plötzlich fühlt.
Ist auch kontraproduktiv. Also das bringt eine Gesellschaft nicht nach vorne.
Wir brauchen eine Aufmerksamkeit, innovative, so ein bisschen abstrakt denkende.
Und dann wäre es schon ganz gut, wenn die Mieten nicht so hoch wären,
dass man mit 25 noch eine Mietbürgschaft der Eltern braucht,
sondern mit 15 schon sagt, ihr könnt mich alle mal. So, das wäre schon nötig.
Es ist ja kein Zufall, dass das Silicon Valley aus der Gegenkultur entstanden ist.
Alles ist aus der Gegenkultur entstanden. Typischerweise kommt immer ein 20-Jähriger
in sein Berufsleben, ist dann bei Research and Development und versucht die
ganze Zeit gegen den Vorstand anzuarbeiten.
Das kann ja so nicht sein und überhaupt nicht. Ich habe doch hier eine bessere
Idee und dann schleust man sich so durch dieses System und am Ende steht im
Grunde ein, wie ist das denn, Sturm durch die Institutionen und so weiter.
Also immer so eine Idee. Ich will hier aber grundsätzlich mal sagen,
diese Diskussionen, wie sie auch da geführt werden, sind ja total Banane.
Man muss es mal auf Zahlen runterbrechen.
Bei der Bundeswehr arbeiten derzeit so 230.000 Leute. Sie wollen auf 400.000.
Und dann sagen alle, die sich damit auskennen, also Wardefugel,
war es jetzt glaube ich, den ich im Ohr habe oder so.
Na, wir haben ja noch so 800.000 Reservisten und Ehemalige. Wenn es hart auf
hart kommt, greifen wir auf die zurück.
Aber es ist auch ganz gut, dass sie nicht gerade aktuell die Kaserne verstopfen,
sondern dass wir sie so im Pool haben.
Was bedeutet, wir haben noch einen Bedarf von 100.000, um auf die 400.000 zu
kommen. Also weitere 100.000 Personal.
Pro Jahrgang werden in Deutschland 750.000 Menschen geboren.
Wenn man jetzt 100.000 will und man würde sich einen Jahrgang auswählen,
also dann 300.000 Jungs und von denen bekäme man ein Drittel in die Bundeswehr
und die verpflichten sich für zwölf Jahre,
dann wäre für die folgenden zwölf Jahrgänge einfach das erledigt.
Die Bundeswehr ist dann voll.
So, wir können natürlich jetzt nicht ein Drittel der jungen Männer rausziehen,
also nehmen wir so ein Dreißigstel, also ein Zehntel.
Wir reden also hier über den Dreißigstel der Männer, die sich dann über zwölf Jahre verpflichten.
Und das würde schon ausreichen, dass wir die ganze Zeit so diskutieren,
als müssten jetzt alle in die Bundeswehr und die Bundeswehr ist auch das wichtigste
Organ von Deutschland, sonst geht gar nichts.
Nachdem wir, und wir werden das nachher auf sakrale Grundlagen runterbrechen,
eigentlich bisher die Autoindustrie so verherrlicht haben oder irgendeinen anderen Scheiß.
Das ist alles total schräg. Also es ist wirklich schräg. Ja,
aber das ist so Berlin-Mitte-Botox-Denken.
Wir hören mal weiter, denn du denkst ja viel zu kurz.
Das ist die Frage, die mir Mirna,
die ich wirklich gerne beantwortet haben wollen würde von dir Mirna.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, es gibt einen Krieg, also Putin greift an und es
gibt einen Krieg und Männer und Frauen kämpfen und am Ende sind viele Millionen tot.
Wie genau glaubst du, dass der Staat erhalten bleibt?
Also ich sehe, wir haben jetzt unter 20 Millionen reproduktionsfähige Frauen.
Wie genau soll das erhalten bleiben?
Ich kenne dieses Denken ja nur von wirklich den radikalen Rechten,
so dieses Volkstoddenken.
Wenn so viele Migranten kommen und die deutschen Frauen auch nicht genügend
gebären, was ist dann mit dem deutschen Volke?
Und jetzt haben wir eine solche Diskussion jetzt hier.
Also das ist ja auch eine interessante Vorstellung. Alle sind tot.
Also diese Idee, dass man seinen Staat, das Kollektiv, das Volk,
was auch immer die nationale Identität verteidigt, das geschieht nicht mal im Krieg.
Diese ganze Kameradschaftssoziologie beschreibt und wir haben das mit Alexander
Kluge und der Kriegsfibel gelesen, er hat es nochmal darauf Wert gelegt,
dass es dieses Phänomen gibt,
der Krieg ernährt sich selbst und die Kriegsparteien kämpfen am Ende gar nicht
so sehr gegeneinander als gegen den Krieg als Entität.
Und der besteht nun mal darin, dass da gerade nicht das Kollektiv,
das Volk, die Nation, sondern der eine Kamerad, den man entweder schützt oder rächt.
Und das ist einfach die Frage, wer schießt zuerst wen tot? Und dann ist das
ein selbstlaufendes Ding.
So, und das ist das Phänomen. Was bedeutet das?
Wir sagen jetzt immer so, ja die Ukraine, das sind ja alles zu Helden geworden,
nachdem der Krieg begann. Ja, das wäre in Deutschland auch so.
Sobald hier große Kriegseinsätze vonnöten sind, wären die Deutschen schon bereit,
ihre Sachen zu verteidigen.
Wir sehen doch, wie sehr sie ihre Parkplätze verteidigen.
Naja, beziehungsweise sie haben ja keine andere Möglichkeit.
Also die ukrainischen Männer, die gerne ausreisen würden, die werden ja nicht gelassen.
Und das ist ja eben das Katastrophale, dass die breite Mitte und bis in weite
linke Kreise hinein das nicht skandalisieren, dass man nicht mehr vor Krieg
fliehen darf, das dann einfach jetzt angesagt ist zu kämpfen.
Das war, ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen, das große Argument 2015,
als die Flüchtlinge aus Syrien kamen, dass man Leute, die vor Krieg fliehen, aufnimmt.
Und es waren nur Rechtsradikale von der AfD, die sagten, wenn Krieg ist,
bleibt man zu Hause und kämpft.
Das war eine reine AfD-Position, ist jetzt inzwischen absolut mehrheitsfähig
geworden, weshalb man ja auch sich nicht darum bemüht, ukrainische Deserteure
und auch russische Deserteure zu unterstützen.
Da haben wir ja schon gehört, der Queer-Beauftragte der SPD,
der sagte, ja, also wir können jetzt nicht die Russen als Fluchtgrund angeben
lassen, dass sie queer sind.
Und dann denke ich mir, ja, ist doch wunderbar, die brauchen nur queer ankreuzen
und dann lassen wir die rein, dann hat Putin wieder jemanden weniger.
Das ist ja auch mal eine kluge Bevölkerungspolitik, wenn man so möchte.
Aber wir sind natürlich noch nicht am Ende, die Wehrhaftigkeit von Frauen.
Von entscheidender Bedeutung und Notwendigkeit, dass Frauen eine echte Wehrhaftigkeit
erlangen vor einem Krieg.
Und das bedeutet übrigens auch, sich verteidigen zu können in Straßenschlachten, ihr Dorf.
Das heißt, einfach auch schießen zu können.
Also ich bin auf Seite von Coach Colin. Ja, körperliche Ertüchtigung,
alles. Von mir aus auch Biathlon-Sport.
Gerade noch schnaufend den Berg hochgerannt und jetzt sofort in Ruhe zielen
zu müssen. Aber you are not a warrior. Genau.
Aber sie wollen das. Sie wollen das. Straßenkämpfe, das Dorf verteidigen.
Das kannst du auch mit Götz Kubitschek und Erden Kositzer mal besprechen.
Dann mit Kinderwagen oder ohne? Ist das wie beim Joggen so die Diskussion?
Da müssen wir mal schauen, wer darauf aufpasst. Das machen dann die,
die wahrscheinlich keinen deutschen Pass haben. Die müssen dann für die Care-Arbeit
hergeholt werden. Denn das ist endlich Emanzipation.
Ja, würden Sie so weit gehen, Frau Funk, zu sagen, dass so ein Militärdienst
ein Mittel wäre zur Selbstermächtigung der Frau? Ja, selbstverständlich.
Also es ist doch logisch, dass wenn ich weiß, wie ich mich verteidigen kann
und wie ich meine eigene Familie verteidigen kann, und zwar mit Waffengewalt
und möglicherweise ja auch mit strategischem Wissen und mit körperlicher Kraft,
dann ist das doch ein Riesenvorteil gegenüber absolut jeder Frau,
die nicht weiß, wie man abdrückt.
In welcher Situation befinden wir uns jetzt eigentlich? Sind wir schon draußen
im Bürgerkrieg? Muss ich auch gleich eine Waffe beschaffen?
Wir haben gerade eine sehr wichtige Diskussion, bei der keiner so richtig weiß, wie man weiterkommt.
Jetzt übernehmen im Osten, in der Lokalpolitik die ganze Zeit,
AfD-Leute, alte NPDler, wie auch immer, alte neue Kader, die sich auch erstmal
kennenlernen müssen und feststellen, ach so, ihr radikalisiert euch im Internet,
zeigt uns doch mal, was ihr da so seht und dann werden die Alten auch erstmal neu radikalisiert.
Und was die gerade machen, ist genau das, Bürgerwehr.
Wir müssen hier auf die Straße es selber machen, hier kommt kein Landespolizist
mehr vorbei, sobald wir hier einen Ausländer sehen, müssen wir uns drum kümmern.
Hier machen wir eine Wehrsportgruppe wieder.
Genau, so. Hier ist dann also die Frage, ab wann fühlt man sich denn angegriffen?
Ab wann soll man denn zuschlagen? Und so weiter.
Und diese Diskussion kann man in Berlin führen, wie man sie in Berlin führt.
Aber wenn dann auch Leute vom Osten auf dem Lande zuhören, muss man vielleicht
nochmal eine ein oder andere Einschränkung hier einziehen.
Das sind Diskussionen aus dem Uber Premium heraus. Fitnessstudio,
du hast es schon angesprochen.
Ich würde dir sogar mit Recht geben. Also ich glaube, dass es natürlich ein
Problem ist, wenn ich mir angucke, dass Männer tendenziell im Fitnessstudio
pumpen und ihre Muskeln aufbauen und Frauen im Fitnessstudio sehr oft eher dazu ermutigt werden,
alles schön klein und schlank zu halten. Ich pumpe. Natürlich ist das ein Problem.
Ich pumpe richtig, dreimal in die Woche. Sehr gut, ich auch. Hardcore sogar.
Kann ich auch wirklich jedem empfehlen, der auf Gleichberechtigung steht.
Gibt es da große Verschwesterungen jetzt, dass man ja pumpt im Fitnessstudio?
Ja, um wehrhaft zu sein. Also das ist, weißt du, ich gehe ins Fitnessstudio
und sehe da ja Leute, die Muskeln haben und denke, ja, sind das jetzt Warrior?
Nein, das sind einfach Leute, die in einem Schönheitsideal hinterherjagen und
versuchen, das zu machen.
Und ich muss gestehen, jetzt durch den Rechtsruck, gucke ich auch schon mal
beim Tattoo genauer hin, ob es noch ein Palmenhain ist oder schon ein Hakenkreuz.
Aber wir können doch jetzt nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben wollen,
der wir jetzt sagen, wir brauchen mal wieder Muskeln, um uns durchzusetzen,
damit ich dann noch zur Not jemanden eins auf die Fresse schlagen kann.
Also das ist jetzt das Niveau, auf dem unsere deutsche Feuilleton-Elite angekommen ist.
Ja, da muss man eh anmerken, du kennst, da du jetzt selber ins Fitnessstudio
gehst, wahrscheinlich auch die YouTube- und Insta-Trends zum Thema Calisthenics.
Also Leute, es gibt Fitnessstudio-Leute und Fitnessstudio-Gäste.
Die einen trainieren mit ihrem Körpergewicht und kriegen dann auch Sachen geregelt
und die anderen, wie sie sagt, pumpen.
Und das sieht man bei Männern besonders gut, wenn Schulter und Brust besonders ausgeprägt ist.
Und man weiß, okay, die gehen einfach auf Ästhetik. Die haben ihre vier Lieblingsübungen
und ziehen die dreimal die Woche durch. Und man weiß ganz genau,
wenn man die jetzt auf den Parkplatz stellt und sagt 100 Meter,
dann laufen die das in 16 Sekunden und brauchen danach eine Stunde Recovery.
Also mit denen ist nichts anzufangen.
Das ist ganz interessant, ich habe mit einem Handwerker gesprochen und der nicht
trainiert ist, aber der natürlich viel schleppen muss und der sagt dann,
naja, die Jungen, die da alle kommen mit den Muskeln, was die tragen,
da trage ich ja an der Uhrkette.
Die können also in dem Sinne, die können ihre Übungen machen,
um die Brust aufzupumpen oder die Bizeps, aber die sind gar nicht in der Lage,
sagt er, solche Arbeiten körperliche zu verrichten wie er.
Ein bisschen Chor, ein bisschen draußen mal sich bewegen, bis zur Tür mit dem
Auto zu fahren und dann da einfach Lattzüge zu machen.
Ja, ich erkenne mich fast wieder.
Nun, wenn wir noch einmal den Polarcheck hören, denn plötzlich ist dir das so
ein bisschen unbehaglich, dass man überhaupt so einen Zwang ausübt.
Ein Staat kann die Engstellen nicht dadurch lösen, dass er Leute zwingt.
Also ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, wie groß die Lücke in der Pflege ist,
aber die ist wirklich tödlich und wirklich auch schlimm.
Und trotzdem kann der Staat jetzt nicht sagen, gut, dann nehmen wir dich,
dich und dich, weil du uns gerade gefällst und zwingen dich,
diesen Job auszufüllen.
Sondern er muss versuchen, Anreize zu schaffen.
Er muss vielleicht die Bedingungen besser machen. Man kann ja auch sagen,
naja, die Leute, die in der Bundeswehr sind, die sind ja bereit, ihr Leben zu opfern.
Also dann muss man diesen Beruf so attraktiv machen, dass 23.000 Leute sagen, das wollen wir.
Und da ja so viele Leute sowieso schon sagen, sie wollen es jederzeit gerne
tun, kann die Aufgabe nicht so schwer sein.
Ja, das ist allerdings ein interessanter Punkt, also dass sie es von sich aus
anspricht, dass man es ihr nicht erst herantragen muss.
Denn soziologisch ist ja völlig klar, in so einem U-Boot sagt natürlich jeder
von sich, er ist der Wichtigste.
Auch der Koch, der sagt einfach, also ohne mich könnte hier gar nichts und so
und der andere, aber ich schieße doch die Raketen ab, aber ich suche doch für
Sauerstoff und so. Und so kann man sich das ja alles vorstellen.
Jeder ist immer der Wichtigste und es ist wirklich sehr fraglich,
warum jetzt auf der Wehrpflicht so ein Zwangsargument läuft und wie sie sagt, bei der Pflege nicht.
Das können wir natürlich sagen. Naja, die Pflege, wenn sie ausartet,
die wird uns ja nicht gefährlich.
Also da sterben ja einfach nur alte Leute dann halt unbeobachtet vor sich hin.
Und Paragraf 1 zählt nicht so ganz, Artikel 1.
Aber der Rest ist so ein bisschen egal, während Putin so droht.
So wird das ja auch gedacht.
Genau. Und da könnte man aber genauso gut sagen, naja, wenn wir uns jetzt fragen,
was ist denn hier zu verteidigen?
Und wir kommen dann irgendwie auf unsere Wirtschaft zu sprechen,
auf unser Zusammenleben. Markus Söder erzählt nochmal, wie toll es in Bayern ist und so.
Dann ist ja die Frage, ja, aber braucht man dafür nicht Arbeitskraft und Produktivität,
die gerade gebunden wird, dadurch, dass zu wenig Leute Pflege machen und so
viel familiär da geregelt werden muss im Betreuungsverhältnis 1 zu 1.
Und dann könnte man aus einer Pflicht zur Pflege noch sehr viel mehr rausholen.
Also Verteidigungsgründe erstmal schaffen, bevor es dann in die Verteidigung geht.
Ja, aber warum die Wehrpflicht da so ein Sonderthema einnimmt?
Einfach nur, weil es Lebensgefahr bedeutet, wie auch immer, selbst wenn man sie jetzt durchsetzt.
Die Wehrpflicht, die wir hatten, betraf erstens nur Männer und zweitens nur
Männer in deutscher Kaserne.
Auslandseinsätze völlig ausgeschlossen. Dafür brauchte man auch wieder.
Eine Verfassungsänderung, die ich mir auch nicht vorstelle durch politischen
Druck im Sinne von oh Polen brennt gerade, Putin hat es geschafft nach Polen.
Man saß in der Kaserne, hat Skat gespielt.
Genau, dass wir dann plötzlich sagen, achso ja, dann schicken wir jetzt unsere
Wehrpflichtigen nach Polen, damit sie da kämpfen.
Ja, also was ist das auch für eine Vorstellung, wenn die beiden dann sagen,
ja und dann kommt Putin, das war Polatschek, die sagt ja dann kommt Putin und
dann sind Millionen tot.
Ja, ich werde dann nicht tot sein, weil ich mich dann auf den Weg mache abzuhauen.
Also das ist auch so eine Idee, wirklich, dass man sich jetzt einfach schon
bereit erklärt hat, sich dann zu opfern für den Ernstfall, dann würde ich sagen, nö, ich nicht.
Aber wir wollen den intellektuellen Höhepunkt jetzt noch erreichen.
Myrna Funk geht jetzt auf dieses Zwangsargument ein.
Und sie bringt das Argument eigentlich. Und du wirst es kennen als Vater.
Ja, also ich finde, und da bin ich auch total gefühlsmäßig und auch intellektuell
bei Nele, wenn es darum geht, Menschen zu etwas zu zwingen.
So was lehne ich normalerweise auch wirklich total ab und es geht mir gegen
den Strich manchmal und in diesem Fall verstehe ich aber auch,
wann ein Zwang notwendig ist und der Zwang zum Beispiel meinem Kind über viele
Jahre jeden Abend zu erklären, dass es das Kinderzimmer aufräumen muss,
bis es das von alleine kann,
der ist eben auch notwendig.
Das Kind muss jeden Abend das
Kinderzimmer aufräumen und sie macht das mit Zwang. Ja, das tut mir leid.
Aber das ist genauso, dass der Staat die Männer verpflichtet zu sterben oder dann die Frauen auch.
Das muss dann einfach sein. Schade. Also es ist ja immer diese Argumentation,
die hatten wir auch bei einigen Leuten, die erst gegen die Corona-Pflichtimpfung
waren und dann aber plötzlich dafür, weil der Wind sich drehte und man doch
merkte, im Podcast-Publikum kommt es besser an.
Und die haben dann gesagt, ja, also mir blutet mein liberales Herz,
aber das muss dann jetzt sein.
Und jetzt hier auch wieder so, ja, es muss leider sein.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man von den Geostrategen dann als Menschenmaterial wahrgenommen wird?
Da muss man ja Carlo Massala danken. Er spricht manchmal in so großer Klarheit,
dass man sich ja dann selbst nochmal überlegen will, möchte man sich auffüllen
lassen? Er ist bei Anne Will zu Gast.
Genau, die Pflicht ist zur Musterung. Das verschafft sozusagen einen Überblick
über die Aufwuchsfähigkeit.
Also wir werden ja in einem militärischen Konflikt das Problem haben,
dass, ich sag jetzt mal, an die 200.000 Bundeswehrsoldaten da involviert sein
werden und nach sechs Monaten wird ein Drittel von denen gefallen oder verbundet
sein. Das haben wir in der Ukraine gesehen.
Und dann müssen sie diese Reihen auffüllen.
Dazu müssen sie aber überhaupt wissen, wer ist dazu in der Lage.
Und diesen Überblick haben wir gar nicht. Also deswegen ist eine verpflichtende
Musterung, finde ich, gut für diese Aufwuchsfähigkeit.
Ja, also entweder stirbt man schon beim ersten Mal oder dann beim zweiten Mal
wird man aufgefüllt. Das ist also die Situation.
Und da können dann Myrna Funk und Nele Polacek nochmal darüber diskutieren,
ob Frauen mit aufgefüllt werden oder ob die dann schon die nächsten Jahrgänge
austragen. Denn wir wissen ja, ein Mann kann viele Kinder auf einmal zeugen
oder kurz nacheinander.
Bei Frauen ist das schwieriger, deswegen diese Reproduktionsarbeit.
Wie dann die Politik darüber spricht, ist auch nochmal interessant.
Merz war bei Ilna zu Gast und spricht über die Frage der Verhandlungen in Ukraine und all das.
Und soll das jetzt gar nicht in puncto auf die Ukraine direkt interessieren,
sondern wie wird eigentlich darüber gesprochen, was da passiert?
Nämlich, es ist ja eigentlich so, dass dort Menschen sich gegenüberstehen,
die sich töten müssen. Und die Politik spricht aber folgendermaßen darüber.
Ilna, das ist doch das Wesen eines solchen komplexen Prozesses.
Dass man alles versucht, sowohl auf der militärischen Seite diesen Krieg zu
beenden, als auch auf der diplomatischen Seite versucht ihn zu beenden.
Und wenn Sie mal in die Geschichte der Kriege der Welt schauen,
das können Sie mit dem Dreißigjährigen Krieg anfangen, können Sie über die beiden Weltkriege sehen.
Das können Sie Afghanistan, Irak,
Sie können es an verschiedensten Stellen beobachten, der Vietnamkrieg.
Wie sind diese Kriege zu Ende gegangen? Sie sind meistens nur durch eine militärische
Erschöpfung, so tragisch und so furchtbar das für die Menschen ist,
aber sie sind meistens erst durch eine militärische Erschöpfung auf mindestens einer Seite,
manchmal auch auf beiden Seiten gegangen.
Das sind wir noch nicht. Wir versuchen jetzt alles, die Ukraine so zu ertüchtigen,
dass sie sich weiter gegen den russischen Angriff wehren kann.
Und irgendwann wird Putin einsehen, dass er das so nicht mehr weitergehen kann.
Aber erst mal ist auch vielleicht aus ihrer Wahrnehmung...
Putin sagt ja hier, wir machen einen Abnutzungskrieg und mal gucken,
wie lange Putin durchhält.
Und wir können natürlich uns auch gleichzeitig fragen, mal gucken,
wie lange die Ukraine durchhält.
Und wenn wir das mal humanitär besprechen oder humanistisch betrachten,
dann müssen wir ja eigentlich sagen, also wie viele Menschen müssen auf welcher
Seite noch sterben, bis diese Erschöpfung eingetreten ist.
Das ist die Art und Weise, wie über Menschen… Ich würde sagen,
wir haben ja Schwachbegriffe.
Wie viel kann Putin noch auffüllen?
Genau, wie wird hier über Menschen gesprochen?
Und ja, da kann sich ja dann jeder sein Bild von machen.
Womit wir eigentlich schon bei
unserem anderen großen Thema sind und auch wiederum bei Friedrich Merz,
denn die Diskussion ist im Gange, ob man eine Kehrtwende bei der Union jetzt gerade erlebt,
weil Friedrich Merz sich zu Gaza geäußert hat und er dort auf der Republika interessanterweise,
also jetzt nicht bei einer Bundespressekonferenz oder sonst irgendwo,
bei einer Regierungspressekonferenz das sagte, sondern auf der Republika angesprochen wird,
auf Gaza und dann eine Äußerung tut, die viele überrascht hat,
weil wir ja sonst eigentlich von der Union nur unbedingte Solidarität mit der
Netanjahu-Regierung hörten.
Ja, es ist ganz verrückt, weil du sagst jetzt Republika-Bühne,
als wäre das von Bedeutung.
Es ist ja in dem Fall nicht, weil der WDR hat in dem Fall, glaube ich,
Markus Preiß beauftragt, dieses Gespräch zu führen.
Ob er jetzt beeindruckt davon war, dass jüngere Leute vor ihm sitzen, U60, Stadt und so.
Aber wir können ja mal hören, was er hier.
Das, was die israelische Armee jetzt im Gazastreifen macht, ich verstehe offengestanden
nicht mehr mit welchem Ziel.
Die Zivilbevölkerung derart in Mitleidenschaft zu nehmen, wie das in den letzten
Tagen immer mehr der Fall gewesen ist, lässt sich nicht mehr mit einem Kampf
gegen den Terrorismus der Hamas begründen.
So, interessant ist ja, dass hier wir jetzt ein Instagram-Clip von der Instagram-Seite
des Bundeskanzleramts gespielt haben.
Ja.
Die also genau diesen Auszug kontextlos, man sieht gar nicht,
man hat nur sein Gesicht gesehen.
Plus, es war die Aufmacher-Nachricht in der Tagesschau an diesem Tag.
Und wahrscheinlich hat der ganze Saal da so ein bisschen, oh ja,
schön, dass er das so sieht, während Markus Preiss so, oh, sofort nach Hamburg
melden, das muss hier und so weiter.
Also war für die dann auch, je nachdem wann das war, 11, 12, 13 Uhr.
Klar, okay, das ist heute der Aufmacher. Und sie haben dann gleich im Nachgang,
also in der Berichterstattung zu diesem O-Ton gezeigt,
wie Gaza aussah, nachdem dort wieder eine Schule bombardiert wurde,
in der Flüchtlinge untergebracht waren.
Und in diesem Fernsehbild, das habe ich jetzt noch vor Augen,
weil ich die Tagesschau jetzt ab und zu immer mal gucke, so eine Wand eingeschlagen
wurde, da war so ein kleines Loch drin und da wurde ein Kind rausgereicht.
Ich habe es auch gesehen, ja.
Und das sind natürlich Bilder, die sich sozusagen einschleifen.
Wir müssen jetzt März wieder relativieren. Also ich habe ihm vorgestern am 28.
War, glaube ich, war ja heute schon halt unter den Tagesthemen zugeschaltet,
wo er so gefragt wurde, was sind jetzt die roten Linien in Gaza für Israel und
dann kann man auch gleich auf die Hamas zu sprechen. Mit demselben Argument wie bei Putin.
Der Ukraine-Krieg ist überhaupt nur, weil Putin nicht aufhört.
Und in Gaza nur, weil die Hamas nicht aufhört.
Also in der Hinsicht hat er es selber wieder eingefangen, aber es war ihm trotzdem
wichtig, dieses Statement zu setzen, was für uns wieder bedeutet,
offenbar waren wir Tagesschau-Zuschauer, Republikagänger,
Instagram-Nutzer, wieder nur massenmedialer Spielball, um eine Nachricht nach Tel Aviv zu wenden.
Die israelische Regierung oder wie auch immer.
Ja, beziehungsweise könnte man ja sagen, es ist ja erstaunlich,
dass die israelische Regierung und auch der Botschafter in Deutschland diese
Äußerung nicht kritisiert hat.
Denn es ist ja normalerweise so, dass wenn sich beispielsweise Macron oder andere
äußern, mit sehr scharfer Kritik aus Israel zu rechnen ist.
Das hat hier nicht stattgefunden. Was ich mir vorstellen könnte ist,
dass Friedrich Merz in Telefonaten oder direkten Gesprächen klargemacht hat,
dass er sich mal dazu auch kritisch wird äußern wollen, aber ansonsten weiterhin
Unterstützung zusagt und den Stopp der Waffenlieferung nicht genehmigen lässt.
Also ich habe eher den Eindruck, wir haben es hier in gewisser Weise mit einem
abgekaterten Spiel zu tun, was aber dann immerhin dafür sorgte,
dass die Tagesschau und viele andere plötzlich auch mal sagten,
okay, vielleicht müssen wir auch ein bisschen das Ganze mal ändern.
Auch auf tagesschau.de erschienen plötzlich andere Artikel als zuvor.
Und es ist ja so, dass jetzt viele Journalisten so tun und auch Politiker so
tun, als hätten sie das jetzt gerade durch das aktuellste Handeln der israelischen
Armee erst gesehen und müssten jetzt darauf reagieren.
Und da muss man ja einfach sagen, jeder Journalist und jeder Politiker hätte
das wissen können und zwar seit anderthalb Jahren und länger.
Und man hat das aber nicht gewollt, beziehungsweise man hat bewusst gegen die
Realität angeschrieben, hat die Realität nicht zugelassen und jetzt wird man
von der Realität so sehr eingeholt,
dass man irgendwie versucht, einen Fluchtweg sich zu verschaffen,
indem man sagt, ja so jetzt gerade, also was so in den letzten Tagen von der
israelischen Regierung in Gaza angeordnet wurde,
da sind wir nicht mehr mit dabei, da ist jetzt eine rote Linie und da müssen
wir jetzt auch mal kritisch werden.
Aber sonst sehe ich nicht jetzt die große Kehrtwende und die müsste eigentlich
kommen und die müsste natürlich mit Waffendieferungsstopp sowieso kommen und
dass jetzt auch die Grünen sich so hervortun und so machen,
als hätten sie das immer schon kritisiert, ist ja geradezu lachhaft,
weil sich ja Baerbock gerade nicht da aus dem Fenster gelehnt hat und hat das schärfer kritisiert.
Und auch nicht in ihren letzten Tagen ihrer Amtszeit, das hätte sie ohne Probleme alles machen können.
Und sie waren alle wahnsinnig zurückhaltend und haben beide Augen geschlossen.
Das ist wirklich fatal, wie das immer noch eigentlich behandelt wird.
Ja, wir behandeln es auch mit vier Clips aus dem Ronsheimer Podcast,
um uns eine Sache zu verdeutlichen.
Denn ich glaube auch, dass es dieses abgekartetes Spiel ist,
klingt immer so, aber das ist Gang und Gäbe in der Politik.
Die SPD-Arbeitsministerin ruft natürlich vorher bei der IG Metall an,
wenn irgendwas ist und die auch.
Und dann wird so kurz ausklamüsert, wie man aufeinander reagiert, wie auch immer.
Und so, also ich weiß nicht genau, ob wirklich gerade jemand ans Telefon geht
in der israelischen Regierung.
Trump reist ja nicht hin und redet nicht mit Bibi.
Ja, Deutschland ist schon sehr wichtig.
Bibi, Benjamin Netanyahu. Ja, also die werden schon sprechen.
Ja, die werden schon sprechen.
Wir rüber.
Anders geht das auch mit den Waffenlieferungen nicht.
Es gibt jedenfalls dieses Einholen,
also dass man dann später darauf angesprochen, was man da gesagt hat.
Durch die Blume sagt, nee, ich wollte nur so eine mediale Welle machen.
Eigentlich sehe ich es anders. Die Hamas ist hier schuld und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist ja bei Ronsheimer ein Podcast auch. Also ich will jetzt nicht zu konkret
werden, aber diese aktuellen Podcast, die es da gerade wieder gibt und diese
Gesprächsthemen und die Gesprächspartner weisen darauf hin, dass da gerade wieder
Vörlefanz stattfindet.
Aber es gab auch bei Ronsheimer kurz diesen Moment, wo er sich sagte,
okay, ich lade jetzt den Chefredakteur der Jüdischen Allgemein,
glaube ich, und im vorherigen anderen Gespräch Daniel Gerlach von Zenith ein.
Daniel Gerlach ist ja sowieso häufiger, immer mal wieder überall zu Gast,
wo man sich auch langsam fragt, ist das so maskottchenartig?
Also, dass man so eine Stimme zulässt.
Er nutzt das aber immer ganz gut, finde ich. Und in der Hinsicht hören wir uns
das einfach dokumentarisch an, wie im Mai 2025 hier geredet wurde.
Der erste Clip geht über zwei Minuten. Daniel Gerlach berichtet mal,
was zuletzt Regierungsmitglieder der israelischen Regierung zu Gaza sagten.
Die israelischen Teile der israelischen Gesellschaft und der israelischen Opposition,
die vielleicht politisch schwach ist derzeit,
sind so dermaßen selbst schockiert über das Vorgehen ihrer eigenen Streitkräfte
und versuchen natürlich jetzt ein Stück weit auch das Ganze nur Netanyahu in
die Schuld zu schieben und sehen gerne darüber hinweg,
dass auch viele andere politische Figuren in Israel diesen Krieg in den letzten
Monaten sehr vorbehaltlos unterstützt haben Und wenn sie etwas dagegen auszusetzen hatten,
dann weil es nicht im Interesse der Befreiung der Geiseln war,
dann weil es innenpolitischen Zielen von Netanjahu diente, aber Humanität gegenüber
den Palästinensern in Gaza stand da eher an nachgeordneter Stelle.
Nein, das Entsetzen, die Kritik ist mittlerweile groß und schau dir mal an,
was Netanjahu gestern im Kabinett gesagt hat.
Ich glaube, mehr muss man eigentlich über die Art und Weise,
wie der Mensch derzeit denkt, nicht wissen.
Der hat seinen eigenen Anhängern und Kabinettsmitgliedern gesagt,
ich paraphrasiere jetzt mal, wir dürfen auf keinen Fall die Unterstützung unserer
Freundin im Ausland dadurch verlieren, dass die Bilder von einer Hungersnot in Gaza sehen.
Das heißt, es geht nicht darum, das Leid der Palästinenser zu lindern,
sondern es geht darum, ein PR-Desaster zu vermeiden.
Und das ist offensichtlich eine Antwort gewesen auf diese Signale,
die er aus Amerika bekommen hat, weil ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass auch die Trumps-Leute ihm gesagt haben, wir wollen nicht diese Bilder sehen.
Und das ist natürlich ganz interessant. Dann hat der Finanzminister Bezadell
Smotrich, eine sehr wichtige Figur im Kabinett, auch wenn er gerne als Fringe
und als Randfigur dargestellt wird in unseren Medien,
hat tatsächlich gegenüber seinen Anhängern das verteidigt und gesagt,
naja Leute, wir geben den Palästinensern ja nur ein Teller Pita.
Und ein bisschen was zu essen, damit sie gerade so zu überleben. Und damit hat sich das.
Dann haben wir unsere Verbündeten im Westen befriedigt. Das ist der Diskurs,
der gerade geführt wird.
Ein anderer Minister, der auch hinländlich bekannt ist, Itamar Ben-Gwir von
der Partei Osmayudit, hat gestern noch eine Abstimmung im Kabinett gefordert
über das Zulassen von humanitärer Hilfe für Gaza.
Wurde dann von dem nationalen Sicherheitsberater offensichtlich zurechtgewiesen,
der gesagt hat, wir brauchen dafür keine Zustimmung der Minister.
Also das ist das Diskursniveau, mit dem wir es hier gerade zu tun haben.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass wenn jetzt mal wieder ein paar Hilfsgüter über
die Grenze gehen, nach Gaza rein, dann wird die CDU sagen, ja seht ihr,
jetzt ist wieder alles in Ordnung.
Also das ist eigentlich das, was ja passiert.
Also dass man nicht anspricht, dass wir es da mit einer ethnischen Säuberung
zu tun haben. Man spricht nicht an, dass wir eine völlige Zerbombung haben.
Ich meine, 95 Prozent ist platt gemacht.
Und dann sind immer noch Leute wie Ronsheimer, die sagen, ich will nicht von
einem Flächenbombardement reden. Und man denkt so, ja.
Ja, ist alles wahnsinnig schräg. Mittlerweile ist ja die ethnische Säuberung auch als Trumps Plan.
Da wird gar nicht mehr genannt. Das heißt dann einfach nur noch Trumps Plan
und man stellt sich so dahinter und wie auch immer.
Aber das ist ja diese Riviera-Idee, dass da erstmal alle weg müssen und man
dann den anderen Ländern, Ägypten, wie auch immer, Vorwürfe macht,
dass sie da keine Menschen aufnehmen und so. Also völlig durchgeknallt insgesamt.
Und jetzt ist ja immer diese große Frage, wenn der Krieg selbst so eine Entität
eigenen Rechts ist, die sich einfach so einen Lock-In-Effekt schafft und dann
haben quasi alle Kriegsparteien nur noch mit dem Krieg zu tun.
Das ist ja hier auch und es ist ja immer dieses Phänomen, also für mich war
das schon vor dieser aktuellen Auseinandersetzung, also vor dem 7. Oktober.
Dass man eigentlich die palästinensische Regierung in der Klammer hat,
es findet ein Krieg gegen diese Regierung statt und zwar von der Hamas und der
israelischen Regierung.
Wir hatten ja auch diese Clips gespielt, die dann nochmal in der Tagesschau
liefen oder in Tagesthemen, dass die israelische Regierung Palästinenser nimmt,
um sie schon mal in Häuser zu schicken, um zu gucken, ob da irgendwas explodiert oder so.
Also eigentlich die klassische Idee des menschlichen Schutzschilds,
aber eben nicht von der Hamas, sondern von der israelischen Regierung.
Und Daniel Gerlach und Ronsheimer reden hier darüber mit dem Argument.
Die Bombenhunde zu schonen.
Genau, die Bombenhunde zu schonen. Und die beiden reden hier darüber,
wie jetzt diese Gemengelage Hamas und Palästinenser.
Gibt es jetzt einen Auftrag an die Palästinenser, sich von der Hamas loszusagen?
Wenn ja, wie sollte das funktionieren?
Was auch immer, das ist ja ein totaler Ausnahmezustand und das ist,
ehrlicherweise eine sehr hochtrabende politische Diskussion,
Weil ich bin jetzt auch kein Anhänger von Friedrich Merz, nur würde man mir
es jetzt durchgehen lassen, wenn ich sage, nö, ich wollte mich einfach nur von
meinem Friedrich-Merz-Kanzler befreien.
Also das würde ja zu Turbulenzen führen, sag ich mal, wenn ich solche Versuche
irgendwie machen würde.
In der Wahrnehmung, nicht nur der Hamas, und da war der große Fehler,
glaube ich, sondern auch der palästinensischen Bevölkerung in Gaza,
war die Art und Weise der Kriegführung nicht gegen die Hamas gerichtet,
sondern war ein Feldzug, der dazu diente, die gesamte palästinensische Bevölkerung
zu bestrafen, keinerlei Rücksicht auf Zivilisten zu nehmen.
Du sagst keinerlei Rücksicht, aber das ist die Wahrnehmung, in der sich die
Palästinenser im Gazastreifen befunden haben.
Und wenn du dir den Grad der Zerstörung anguckst, dann wird es auch sehr schwierig,
dagegen zu argumentieren.
Jetzt ist es so, du hast in dieser Situation natürlich die Möglichkeit gehabt,
einen Keil zwischen die palästinensische Bevölkerung und die Hamas zu treiben.
Das kannst du aber nicht, wenn du die Bevölkerung kollektiv bestrafst und gegen
die Bevölkerung vorgehst.
Das ist ja der entscheidende Vorwurf auch gewesen, den von Anfang an Fachleute,
aber auch israelische Oppositionelle, israelische Analysten,
Journalisten der Regierung gemacht haben, dass sie zwar behauptet hat,
dieser Krieg richtet sich nicht gegen die Bevölkerung, aber das Vorgehen,
das Gegenteil im Grunde, den gegenteiligen Rückfluss nur erlauben konnte.
Und das ist das große Problem in dieser Art und Weise der Kriegführung,
die nicht erst seit wenigen Wochen kritisiert wird, sondern im Grunde seit Beginn.
Jetzt hat ja Ronsheimer da ganz kurz am Anfang so, ja ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen, dass sie so gar keine Rücksicht genommen haben.
Und da kann man natürlich immer dieses, ja sie rufen ja vorher an oder was auch immer.
Oder hier aus deutscher Richtung, ja aber die israelische Armee hat doch das
als Kampfzone definiert, warum sind die Leute denn da? Also lauter so in Firlefanz.
Irgendwann ist halt auch nicht mehr der andere Ort, den man besuchen kann.
Wenn grundsätzlich eingezäunt ist, ist es halt schwierig. Ja.
Wie sollte man das jetzt aus, sagen wir mal, also okay, Ronsheimer will nicht,
dass es so der Totale, dass es als totaler Krieg angesehen wird.
Gerlach versucht es hier mit, sagen wir mal so, Details und Beispielen,
um einfach zu zeigen, ne, hier werden wirkliche echte Grenzen überschritten,
auch wenn es noch andere Beispiele gäbe, wo das dann nicht so ist.
Aber die Beispiele, die man nennen kann, sind auf jeden Fall Haarsträum.
Die Logik, die dahinter steht, und die kritisiere ich ja, und die wird ja auch
in Israel kritisiert, ist, ich möchte es jetzt nicht zu sehr zuspitzen,
aber wenn in einem Kindergarten sich ein Terrorist verschanzt,
dann ist doch die Frage, ob ich berechtigt bin, diesen Kindergarten zu bombardieren,
die erübrigt sich doch, oder?
Logischerweise nein. Auch wenn sich völkerrechtlich vielleicht dadurch ergeben
könnte, dass dadurch, dass dort ein Terrorist sich befindet,
ein Kindergarten keine zivile Einrichtung mehr ist.
Aber ich bombardiere doch keinen Kindergarten, weil dort ein Terrorist ist,
sondern muss dann halt, auch wenn dort ein Terrorist ist, auf die Gelegenheit
warten, diesen Menschen zu treffen, wenn er sich nicht in einem Kindergarten befindet.
Ja, scheint logisch.
Weil noch haben wir doch gerade aus unserer Sicht so eine Idee von Krieg geht,
aber so bitte völkerrechtlich.
Und das ist schon absurd genug, überhaupt so Gedanken zu haben.
Und das hier nochmal einfordern zu müssen.
Ja, das ist ja genau diese Argumentation, wenn Leute von der CDU oder von der
Springerpresse einfach sagen, Israel hat jedes Recht. Das stimmt ja nicht.
Also Israel hat auch Rechte, wie alle anderen souveränen Staaten auch,
aber niemand hat jedes Recht.
Ja, also hier haben wir es wirklich mit Problemlagen zu tun und deswegen macht
es Gerlach auch nochmal ganz explizit.
Kann man den Palästinensern selbst hier irgendwelche Vorwürfe machen?
Wenn man es mal überspitzt formuliert, warum schafft diese palästinensische
Bevölkerung nicht, die Hamas in irgendeiner Form zu entmachten oder zumindest
noch mehr Druck auszuüben?
Was passiert da gerade in Gaza?
Das finde ich zum Beispiel allein die Fragestellung. Paul Ronsheimer ist ansonsten
in allen anderen Podcasts zu Gast.
Heute Morgen erst wieder bei Gordon Ripinski. Um darüber zu berichten, was vor Ort passiert.
Um eine Lageeinschätzung zu geben, die wir durch reinen Medienkonsum nicht haben.
Diese Frage, warum schafft es die palästinensische Bevölkerung nicht,
sich gegen die Hamas aufzuladen.
Er weiß selber, was die Antwort auf diese Frage ist. Und er weiß selber,
wie absurd diese Frage ist.
Und er hat es die letzten Jahre dort miterlebt.
Es ist ein völliger Ausnahmezustand. in dem nicht in irgendeiner Weise noch
eine politische Mobilisierung stattfinden kann.
Also bei uns geht die Wahlbeteiligung runter, wenn es regnet.
Dann sagen die Leute.
Achst mir eigentlich jetzt schon zu viel. Und hier, wo alles in Schutt und Asche
liegt, sagt man, warum machen die eigentlich jetzt nicht gerade einen Widerstand?
Warum findet da keine Demo statt oder so? Die Frage selbst ist schon völlig neben der Spur.
So Berliner Aktivismus, Fridays for Future oder so. Warum jetzt gerade nicht in Gaza?
Also sie entwertet, finde ich auch, Ronsheimers Expertise, die ansonsten sein
Aushängeschild ist für alle seine journalistischen Tätigkeiten.
Diese Frage kann man so nicht stellen, beziehungsweise die Antwort ergibt sich von uns selbst.
Dennoch, er hat sie so gestellt und Gerlacher antwortet.
Ich bin ja nicht in Gaza. Ich kenne viele Leute in Gaza und viele Leute aus
Gaza, aber ich kann damit nur so wie du, nicht als Experte, sondern menschlich spekulieren.
Dieses menschliche Spekulieren übrigens, Und das ist diese große,
bisschen vulgär jetzt von mir, Unterscheidung zwischen Historikern und Soziologen.
Historiker suchen immer noch die Quelle und graben dann irgendwie um und gucken
so, wie viele Kühe standen in dem Stall, wie viele Leute haben hier gelebt, wie auch immer.
Der Soziologe macht sich so allgemeine Gedanken und denkt sich einfach,
es geht hier um menschliches Leben.
Wir dürfen hier ein bisschen spekulieren, denn wir kennen die Boundaries und Limits.
Ja, wir wissen, wie Menschen sich in größeren Gruppen organisieren,
was sie davon abhalten kann, sich zu organisieren.
Wir brauchen keine Quelle dafür, dass es wahrscheinlich keine Aliens waren,
die die Pyramiden gebaut haben.
Das müssen die Menschen irgendwie hingekriegt haben und wenn wir noch nicht
genau wissen, wie, dann müssen wir da noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken und
nicht nur im Boden nach finden wir noch Werkzeuge, sondern uns einfach mal Gedanken
machen, wie würde man es denn machen.
Also diese menschliche Spekulation ist, das klingt ja so salopp,
menschliche Spekulation, aber es ist ganz konkret.
Jeder wohnt in einem Stadtteil. Angenommen, man lebt selber noch in dem allerletzten
Gebäude, das nicht komplett zerschossen wurde. Wie würde man sich fühlen?
Und darauf findet man eine Antwort und das ist dann die Antwort.
Man braucht jetzt keine, oh Herr Ronsheimer, danke, dass du nochmal bei mir
bist im Podcast, um darüber zu berichten oder ich bin ja nicht in Gaza.
Das sind alles, ja, ja, schön und gut und so.
Wir sind ja wirklich beim Elementaren angekommen. Warum lehnen sich die Menschen
dann nicht gegen die Hamas auf?
Den ganzen Tag und die ganze Nacht Angst haben muss, dass ich von einer israelischen
Bombe wohne oder einem Scharschützen getötet werde, wenn ich nicht weiß,
wie ich meine Kinder ernähren soll.
Glaubst du, dann habe ich noch Energie zu demonstrieren und mich gegen die Hamas
aufzulehnen, weil ich weiß, okay, wenn ich das mache und die Hamas dann loswerde,
wahrscheinlich werde ich dann von denen umgebracht,
dann wird Israel aufschauen, mich zu bombardieren.
Verstehst du, die Wahrnehmung der Palästinenser in Gaza ist,
Egal was wir machen, egal wo wir stehen, dieser Krieg ist dazu da,
um uns zu bestrafen, um sich an uns zu rächen und um uns von hier zu vertreiben.
Und dieses Narrativ befeuern und bestätigen israelische Politiker tagtäglich.
Vor zwei Tagen hat ein...
Ja und dann kommt die nächste. Also diese Herangehensweise an Gaza ist einfach,
du hast jetzt schon den Brückenschlag zu manchen deutschen Diskussionen,
es regnet und die Leute gehen nicht wählen.
Wir haben Bürgermeisterwahlkämpfe, wo es irgendwie heißt, der Bürgermeister
arbeitet sich den Arsch auf, er ist jeden Tag bei drei Podiumsdiskussionen,
das Publikum ist eingeladen.
Und niemand, niemand braucht eine Erklärung dafür, weil jeder es von selbst
versteht, warum war niemals bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung irgendwo in Deutschland
für irgendeine Lokalpolitik eine 28-jährige alleinerziehende Mutter mit zwei Kindern.
Warum sitzen da immer nur alte Leute? Diese Frage ist geklärt.
Wir wissen warum. Wir müssen da nicht Ronsheimer fragen.
Warum ist nicht der Lieferant der Bote da?
Genau. Manche Sachen sind einfach ganz einfach zu beantworten durch menschliche Spekulation.
Da muss man nicht in Gaza sein, da muss man nicht in Stuttgart sein.
Man weiß genau, wie es läuft.
Und hier in Gaza, wir sehen diese Bilder, wir wissen doch genau, wie es da gerade läuft.
Da ist kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen.
Niemand braucht jetzt Gespräch mit Netanyahu, niemand mit Merz,
niemand mit irgendwas, wir wissen genau, was da läuft und ich finde,
wir sollten es auch auf dieser menschliche Spekulation wirklich mal runterbrechen
und nicht anfangen mit, ach die Palästinenser und die große Geschichte,
sondern nee, jetzt gerade ist da nicht die Palästinenser und die große Geschichte,
sondern da sind einfach Menschen und in diesem Monat, in dem wir Margot Friedländer
beerdigen und dann nochmal sagen, seid Menschen,
ist das genau dieser Appell, niemand braucht mehr als diese zwei Worte,
seid Menschen und da ist einfach gerade niemand so richtig Mensch,
in Gaza. Und das ist das Problem.
Und wenn jetzt von konservativer und miter Seite immer gesagt wird,
ja, das ist eine humanitäre Katastrophe, dann überdeckt das ja völlig,
dass das politisch gemacht ist.
Aber wenn wir mal bei dem Humanitären bleiben würden und sagen,
ja, das ist eine humanitäre Katastrophe, dann müsste man ja dann sagen,
dann schließen wir da raus,
Eine Politik, die wir eigentlich bei humanitären Katastrophen machen,
wir helfen zum Beispiel dadurch, dass wir Flüchtlinge aufnehmen.
Das wäre ja dann das wenigste, was zu tun ist.
Das mindeste, was zu tun ist. Und das ist ja auch nicht das,
was jetzt gefordert wird. Das ist ja auch interessant.
Ich will noch einen Clip zum Thema Gaza spielen.
Es kommt selten vor, dass Robin Alexander die SPD und die Grünen lobt.
Er hat es aber getan im Ronsheimer Podcast und wir hören uns mal an,
was das für ein Lob ist und schauen mal, ob wir dieses Lob teilen.
Und hier möchte ich einmal eine Lanze für die SPD und die Grünen brechen.
Die haben nämlich der Versuchung widerstanden, die viele andere linke Parteien
in Europa nicht widerstanden haben, auf eine sehr maßlos kritische Israel-Position zu gehen.
Und vor allen Dingen die Grünen haben dafür einen Preis gezahlt.
Die Wiederaufstehung der Linkspartei hat nicht nur mit Heidi Reichenegg und
Tanzvideos zu tun, hat auch damit zu tun, dass in bestimmten migrantischen Vierteln,
ich lebe in Neukölln, bei uns hat ein Linkspartei-Mensch gewonnen,
die haben einfach eine Position der harten Israel-Kritik besetzt,
die die Grünen bewusst ausgeschlagen haben, anders als linke Parteien in anderen Ländern Europas.
Also da ist für Israel-Solidarität links der Mitte auch ein Preis gezahlt worden,
auch bei der Wahl und das sollte man anerkennen. Absolut.
Man kann ja viel streiten, habe ich ja hier auch schon mehrmals debattiert,
dass mir da einige Aktivisten auch besorgniserregend vorkommen.
Aber was man ja festhalten kann ist, dass hier ein Lob ausgesprochen wird.
Dafür, dass SPD und Grüne die Augen verschlossen haben vor einer Realität,
die einfach da ist und da musste man nicht irgendein radikaler Aktivist sein
und nicht ein Feind Israels oder irgendetwas, um zu erkennen.
Dass das, was da gerade in Gaza passiert, nicht sein kann.
Und das konnte man schon lange erkennen und ich habe ja schon mal darauf hingewiesen,
in der Financial Times nach einigen Wochen des Krieges ist da schon dieser Artikel
erschienen, wo man sagte, jetzt
ist genug, wir brauchen dringend eine Waffenruhe, das führt zu nichts.
Und diese Artikel haben sich ja in der ganz seriösen Presse gehäuft.
Wir hatten hier schon vor vielen Monaten Podcast Clips gespielt vom New York
Times Podcast, vom Daily Podcast über die Situation in Gaza.
Also da sind wir ja in der Mitte des liberalen Amerikas. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht, dass man sagt,
man läuft irgendwelchen Aktivisten hinterher und versucht da mal ein paar Infos
zu bekommen, sondern das ist ja in der Mitte hat es ja längst stattgefunden
und genau davor hat die deutsche Politik und haben dann auch Grüne und SPDler
die Augen verschlossen.
Und dass das jetzt nochmal gelobt wird von Robin Alexander, da sollte man sich
also, wenn man einer dieser beiden Parteien angehört, doch mal die Frage stellen,
ob man dieses Lob haben möchte.
Ich muss ja eh zum Ende dieses Themas mal sagen, nachdem ich als häufiger Tagesschau
mit unserem Nachwuchs gucke und so und mich auch sonst, also ich finde das wahnsinnig interessant.
Nicht nur werden diese Augen so vor Gaza verschlossen, sondern man hört ja an
diesem Singsang von Robin Alexander auch noch, dass man sich selbst so eine
Deutungshoheit andichtet.
Während im Osten schon 45% AfD wählen, wo man natürlich einfach sagen kann,
naja gut, die sind abgedreht, wie auch immer, gibt es viele Erklärungen.
Aber sehr viele Leute sind gerade sehr abgedreht und die sehen sowas und hören
sowas und die denken aber mit.
Also ich bin ja ein sehr zynischer Tagesschau-Gucker und ich halte mich sehr
zurück, wenn ich das mit meiner Tochter gucke.
Aber ich muss sie bremsen, weil das ist einfach absurd.
Man kommt doch mit menschlicher Intuition, Erfahrung und eben Lust auf Spekulation
in dieses Geschehen und hört diese Leute reden.
Ja, das ist genau so, wenn Anne Will und Marsala sagen, wie füllen wir denn mal die Armee auf?
Also jedes Kind versteht dann ja im Moment auffüllen, das heißt ich sterbe dann
und dann wird irgendwie ein Freund von mir kommen und der füllt mich auf.
Also jedes Kind versteht das eigentlich.
Jeder versteht das und jeder macht sich da auch Gedanken drüber.
Und das hier aber immer noch so ein wir erklären es jetzt mal.
Ich habe ja diesen einen Clips von Robin Alexander, wie er da am Deutschlandfunk
so ne, wir können eigentlich immer mehr eins erklären und so.
Er versucht sich immer das weiter zu erklären und nochmal so kriege ich es nochmal hin. Aber,
eigentlich denkt man anders. Also es ist wirklich wir kriegen ja auch Reaktionen
auf unseren Podcast wo wir immer wieder hören ja klar, alle denken so.
Niemand ist diese Berliner Blase, diese,
Ronsheimer, Gordon, Repinski und so weiter, die machen sich wirklich lächerlich mittlerweile.
Wir wollen kurz darauf hinweisen, dass es im August einen Live-Salon gibt.
Am 23. August sind wir in Frankfurt zu erleben, dort im ganz großen Saal.
Dort gibt es dann Live-Podcast und auch natürlich davor und danach die Möglichkeit,
uns zu treffen, mit uns zu sprechen.
Die Karten findet man ganz einfach. Man geht auf die Homepage von D-Case in
Frankfurt, findet dort den Termin. Da ist ein Saalplan.
Im Mittelblock ist ja auch fast alles schon weg. Aber an den Seiten,
an denen man auch sehr gut sehen kann, sind Plätze noch verfügbar.
Wolfgang kommt dann die Treppe runter, die Gänge entlang zu euch,
wenn ihr euch zu weit wegfühlt.
Wir können ein schönes Metalies singen oder so.
Nein, wir singen nicht. Oder vielleicht.
Vielleicht willst du ja singen.
Ich will nur anteasern, aber wir singen nicht. Das weiß ich.
Nee, nee, ich wette dich ja, wenn aufgefordert, dass du mal singst.
No.
Dann wollte ich noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich im Juni zu erleben bin,
in der Schweiz wieder, in der schönen Schweiz.
Einmal in Zürich am 6.6.
Dort wird der Film gezeigt, die Bekenntnisse des Hochstaplers Thomas Mann.
Das ist eine Doku-Fiktion.
Das spreche ich im Anschluss mit dem Hauptdarsteller. Und dann am 7.6.
Findet wenige Kilometer weiter in Kilchberg ein ganzer Tag zu Ehren von Thomas Mann statt.
Dort geht es dann zum Beispiel auch um Thomas Mann und seine politischen Interventionen
aus dem Exil heraus. Da sind mehrere Diskussionen geplant, die ich dann moderieren werde.
Das findet man alles auf meiner Homepage. Und am 11.06. bin ich in Berlin und
spreche mit dem Schriftsteller Franz Friedrich über den Roman Die Toten Seelen.
Das kann man alles da finden.
Ich war im Radio erstaunlicherweise eine Einladung wegen unserer Spotify-Besprechung von Liz Pelly.
Ich fand das dann ganz interessant, weil ich so als der Publikumsvertreter eingeladen
wurde, neben Christopher Annen, Musiker und Ina Brodhoch, glaube ich heißt sie,
Musikkritikerin in Köln.
Und ich habe dann spontan noch, fiel mir ja ein, wir sind ja auch Produzenten
auf Seiten Spotify mit dem Podcast, dass ich noch nie ein Honorar gekriegt habe von Spotify und so.
Das kommt am Sonntagabend beim WDR3 und das WDR3-Forum.
Sehr gut.
Das könnt ihr euch mal anhören. Sonst habe ich keine Termine.
Allerdings, bevor wir Geoökonomie, ich habe eine Frage an unsere Hörer.
Unsere kleine Bürogemeinschaft 1789 und ich suchen für sechs Leute in Frankfurt ein neues Büro.
150 Quadratmeter, möglichst gut gelegen, schön, wo man sagt,
Budget ist nicht so entscheidend.
Wir suchen ein schönes Büro in Frankfurt möchte uns jemand in seiner Nähe haben
kennt jemand etwas schreibt mir doch bitte wir suchen bis Jahresende dann müssen wir umziehen.
Und wir wollten auch noch sagen
vielleicht hören hier manche Leute zu die irgendetwas interessantes haben,
ein Unternehmen oder so was wir bewerben könnten wir sind ja durchaus offen
für Werbung allerdings findet diese Werbung dann nur für die Leute statt Die
uns nicht abonniert haben,
das heißt also die vor der Paywall bleiben,
das könnte sein, dass die auch mal von uns eine Werbung gesprochen bekommen,
also wenn da jemand Interesse hat, einfach melden bei den 29ern,
also wenn es in irgendeiner Weise passiert.
Wenn ihr glaubt, es passt zu uns.
Wenn das vielleicht Stefan irgendein neues Gadget, dass er dringend bewerben muss oder eine neue KI.
Wir wollen aber jetzt vor allem, weil Werbung ja nur mal so die Idee ist,
ob das funktioniert, wir wollen aber vor allem darauf hinweisen,
dass wir ja davon leben, dass ihr uns unterstützt, nämlich in Form einer Mitgliedschaft im Salon.
Und in diesem Salon sprechen wir immer über ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam gelesen
haben und außerdem diskutieren wir dann noch weitere Texte, die wir uns gegenseitig
vorstellen, die für den Monat wichtig waren.
Mir gibt es auch immer noch einen Musiktipp. Jetzt sprechen wir über ein Buch
gemeinsam, das den Titel trägt Geoökonomie, Anatomie der neuen Weltordnung von
Milan Babic erschienen bei Surkamp.
Es geht darum, dass er diagnostiziert, dass die neoliberale Globalisierung nicht
mehr unserer Wirklichkeit entspricht.
In welcher Zeit leben wir also dann und was kann eigentlich dieser neue Grundbegriff
Geoökonomie leisten zur Erklärung der Welt? Wir haben viel über Geopolitik gesprochen,
aber das Ökonomische kommt ja da oft ein bisschen zu kurz.
Das ist also ein Buch, das sicherlich interessant sein wird,
darüber zu diskutieren. Das kann man dann im Salon hören.
Wie kommt man in den Salon?
Man geht für alles, was uns betrifft, zum Beispiel auch die Cast-Tickets und
so, auf neue20er.de, dort findet man einen goldenen Button,
der heißt Salon, der hängt auch so ein kleiner Wimpel dran und dann ist man
schon auf der Seite von Steady, wir präferieren Steady, man kann den Salon auch
über Apple direkt hören oder über Patreon, wenn man da schon einen Account hat,
da gibt es aber nicht das ganze Archiv, das findet man insgesamt bei Steady
mit dem Vorteil, wenn man bei Steady Abonnent ist, muss man sonst nichts mehr
von uns abonnieren, Dann kriegt man alles über Steady.
Und, genau, 29er, goldener Button, sich dann dort ein Paket aussuchen und ab
dann kann man nochmal alle 50, 60, 70 Buchbesprechungen, die wir bisher so hatten,
nachhören, wenn man so viel Zeit hat.
Ja, es ist jedenfalls ein Archiv, auch wo man nochmal was herholen kann,
wenn man es gerade braucht.
Also man muss jetzt natürlich nicht da chronologisch durchgehen.
Jedenfalls würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt.
Und kommen wir zu dem Thema, das eigentlich schon anknüpft an das Buch,
das wir dann lesen werden, nämlich Geopolitik und Geoökonomie.
Wir haben ja jetzt hier viel über Trump und seine Zölle schon gesprochen,
beziehungsweise sagen immer wieder, wie verrückt das alles ist,
was Trump macht und so weiter.
Und ja, dann höre ich, sein Sohn ist gerade in Vietnam unterwegs,
um wieder irgendwelche Hotelgeschäfte zu machen.
Wir sehen also auch diese private Bereicherung mit den Coins und was er dann
gerade in den arabischen Staaten tut.
All das suggeriert natürlich auch immer, jetzt ist wieder Trump,
jetzt ist alles anders. Und ich habe mich aber dann doch gefragt,
gibt es irgendwelche Kontinuitäten?
Also gibt es Kontinuitäten, Trump 1, Biden, Trump 2?
Es gibt natürlich diese persönliche Bereicherung und diese unendliche Schamlosigkeit,
die überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist mit dem, was jetzt die beiden Administrationen
tat oder Kamala Harris getan hätte.
Aber es gibt doch vielleicht, wenn wir über die Geopolitik und über die Ökonomie
sprechen, so eine große Kontinuität. Und dann habe ich was gemacht.
Ich habe mir einen Vortrag angehört von dem Joe Biden Security Advisor Jake Sullivan.
Oder wie Joe Biden in schlechteren Tagen sagte, Steve, der vor zwei Jahren in
der Brookings Institution einen Vortrag gehalten hat.
Er war eingeladen als Sicherheitsberater, um über Wirtschaft zu sprechen,
was an sich schon ein bisschen komisch ist.
Und dieser Vortrag, der ist jetzt sicherlich in Deutschland nicht viel rezipiert
wurde, der wurde aber in geostrategischen Kreisen schon hellhörig begutachtet.
Ich habe den immer liegen lassen, aber manchmal ist es gut, wenn man erst etwas
sehr viel später hört und das erging mir jetzt so.
Wir hören jetzt Clips aus diesem Vortrag und versuchen mal über Kontinuitäten nachzudenken.
Nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, die USA leden ein Fragmentierer Welt um einen neuen
internationalen Ökonomischen Ordnung zu bauen.
Es hat hunderte Millionen Menschen aus der Pobreude gesetzt.
Es hat eine sehr spannende technologische Innovationen gesetzt.
Und es hat die USA und viele andere Länder im ganzen Weltkrieg erreichert neue Läden von Prosperität.
Aber die letzten paar Dekäten haben diese Fondationen veröffentlicht.
Eine globale Ökonomie veröffentlicht hat viele Amerikaner und ihre Gemeinden hinterlassen.
Aha. Die Globalisierung war eigentlich eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Viele Menschen wurden aus der Armut gehoben, weltweit. Aber wie ist es mit der
heimischen Industrie und mit den heimischen Arbeitsplätzen?
Da sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Hier schlägt also jemand ganz klar globalisierungskritische
Töne an. Und er sagt dann Folgendes noch.
Both at home and with partners around the world.
New Consensus meint also, er erklärt den Washingtoner Consensus,
den Washingtoner Consensus als passé.
Er sagt damit also, diese globale Ordnung, an die wir glauben mit Freihandel
und all dem, das ist für uns jetzt nicht mehr relevant.
Uns geht es um die heimische Industrie und es geht dann um Partnerschaften.
Wie diese Partnerschaften aussehen, werden wir gleich noch hören.
Aber was wir hier also ganz klar sehen ist, natürlich, I make America great again.
Wir müssen nur jetzt erkennen, es ist eine völlig andere Rhetorik.
Es ist also überhaupt nicht vergleichbar mit den Auftritten von Trump.
Aber es gibt doch sehr große Parallelen. Er sagt auch über die Industrie.
Die industrielle Basis wurde ausgeliefert. Die Vision des öffentlichen Investments,
die das amerikanische Projekt in den Postwarsch Jahren energisiert,
und zwar für viel unserer Historie, hat verbrannt.
Also das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, weil der neue Economy,
wie heißt er, ist ja auch so eine senatsgemachte Stelle von dem Stephen Myron, dem Economy Advisor,
Chief Economy Advisor, genau, der ja mit Besant zusammen diesen Mar-a-Lago-Akkord
entwickelt hat, den wir so ausführlich besprochen hatten, wo es ja genau darum ging.
Die Globalisierung bedeutet freigeschossene Handelsrouten und eben diese Währung,
die einfach überall genutzt werden kann, auch zwischen China und Brasilien und
so war ja sein Beispiel, nur eben auf Kosten der heimischen Industrie.
Und dann lachen wir heute über Trumps Herangehensweise zu sagen,
okay, dann machen wir die Produkte teurer, sodass die in Amerika selbst hergestellt
werden müssen und plötzlich müssen die Amerikaner wieder ihre Kugelschreiber
selbst zusammenschrauben und sowas.
Aber in der Anlage, in der Problembeschreibung gibt es hier diese Kontinuität.
Also jetzt hören wir das wie hier dann der Security Advisor,
diese Außenpolitik von Biden.
Und ich bin...
That deep trade liberalization would help America export goods,
not jobs in capacity, was a promise made but not kept.
Die USA ist nicht Exportweltmeister. Der Export war ja mal wichtiger für die
USA, es sind immer weniger geworden.
Das wird hier problematisiert. Hinzu kommt, dass er auch das BEP nicht als die
eigentliche Kategorie mehr sehen will, an der man die Politik misst.
Denn normalerweise bedeutete das ja, im Washingtoner Konsens zu bleiben,
das BIP geht nach oben, ich mache eine gute Politik, ich werde wiedergewählt,
das ist erfolgreich, die Presse ist begeistert.
Das ist sowieso interessant, finde ich. Wir haben ja im Fernsehpodcast ganz
lange immer diese amerikanischen Nachrichten geschaut und da war immer völlig
klar, Verschuldung, Staatsschulden, BIP, das spielt da gar keine große Rolle.
Also so wie in Deutschland immer minus 0,2 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum und dann
ist sofort eine MyPretInnersendung dazu und Lindemann muss ich erklären,
das ist ja in Amerika schon seit einer Weile nicht mehr, dass diese Kennziffern
so wichtig sind, sondern da kam immer einfach die nächste Kampagne,
die gefragt hat, geht es dir eigentlich besser oder schlechter als vorher?
Und dann wurde das alles so ein bisschen aus deutscher Sicht so gefühlig,
aber natürlich viel näher dran, so am realen Leben diskutiert.
Another embedded assumption was that the type of growth didn't matter.
All growth was good growth. So various reforms combined came together to privilege
some sectors of the economy, like finance, Das finde ich super interessant.
Weil das ist ja auch Trump eins gewesen, Hauptsache die Börsenwerte stimmen.
Und jetzt sieht man, nee, die Börsenwerte stimmen gar nicht und es ist auch
eine Rezension, aber die Bevölkerung so, nee, das ist noch nicht so entscheidend
für uns, solange wir es nicht fühlen.
Und Trump geht auf direkte Konfrontation mit dem wichtigsten Börsenunternehmen, nämlich Apple.
Sagt denen, jetzt produziert wieder hier und Tim Cook sagt dann, nee, eigentlich nicht.
Und Tim Cook hat ja eigentlich während der ersten Amtszeit ein gutes Verhältnis zu Trump.
Der hat sich nie in irgendeinen Kulturkampf einspannen lassen,
da ist er ja auch wirklich nicht der Typ für, aber das war schon so,
ich habe hier die Lieferketten unter Kontrolle, ich produziere,
das ist das wichtigste Unternehmen, das Flaggschiff von Amerika,
das ist der Ausweis für die größte Innovation, die wir haben und ich muss natürlich
auch mit einem Trump mich verstehen und das tat er ja auch.
Und dass aber jetzt Trump dagegen vorgeht,
also dass Apple einfach sagt, wir verlagern jetzt die Produktion so ein bisschen von China nach Indien,
da sagt Trump, nein, das reicht uns nicht, das reicht uns nicht,
der soll wieder hier in den USA stattfinden und dass er damit die Börsenwerte
natürlich mindert, überhaupt mit dieser ganzen Zollpolitik, ist also eine Änderung.
Und die Kontinuität natürlich ist die, dass wir ja noch gar nicht über den Elefant
im Raum gesprochen haben und er ist selbstredend China.
The People's Republic of China continue to subsidize at a massive scale both
traditional industrial sectors like Steel as well as key industries of the future,
like clean energy, digital infrastructure and advanced biotechnologies.
America didn't just lose manufacturing, we eroded our competitiveness in critical
technologies that would define the future.
Stahl. Denkt man auch immer direkt an ThyssenKrupp oder so?
Wenn man sich das dann ansieht, ThyssenKrupp ist irgendwo auf Platz 41 der weltweiten Stahlproduzenten.
Wenn du dir die ersten 10 Plätze ansiehst, dann hast du dort China und nochmal
ein, zweimal Indien. Das ist dann die Produktion.
Bei Stahl könnte man sogar einen amerikanisch-europäischen Schulterschluss, wurde ja auch versucht,
dieser ganze Importzoll-Anpassungsmechanismus von USA von der Leyen war ja nur
auf Stahl bezogen am Anfang, wegen dieser Überproduktion von 400 Millionen Tonnen
im Jahr aus China. Das ist natürlich viel zu viel.
Wir sehen also, China ist das Problem. Was möchte er jetzt dann für eine neue Außenpolitik?
Also wir sind jetzt hier in einem anderen Rahmen. Wir sind nicht bei Trump,
der dann einfach sagt China, China, China, sondern er muss das natürlich jetzt verkaufen.
Einmal als eine gewisse Nachhaltigkeitspolitik spielt da eine Rolle,
aber es ist auch so eine Idee für die Mitte.
All of that is part of what we have called a foreign policy for the middle class.
Das ist also das, was die beiden Administrationen anstrebt.
Bedeutet aber, es ist eigentlich eine Anti-China-Politik, die man aber natürlich
rhetorisch damit verkauft, dass man sagt, das hilft der Mitte.
Wie ja Trump auch sagt, ich bringe am Ende die Industrie zurück,
euch die Jobs und all das, das hilft. Jobs, Jobs, Jobs.
Sullivan spricht jetzt auch über die Rohstoffe in den USA.
Or consider critical minerals, the backbone of the clean energy future.
Today, the United States produces only 4% of the lithium, 13% of the cobalt,
0% of the nickel, and 0% of the graphite required to meet current demand for electric vehicles.
Meanwhile, more than 80% of critical minerals are processed by one country, China.
Clean Energy Supply Chains are at risk of being weaponized in the same way as
oil in the 1970s or natural gas in Europe in 2022.
Behalten wir das mal im Hinterkopf. Es geht also darum, dass die erneuerbaren
Möglichkeiten der Mobilität, die erneuerbare Energie, all das basiert natürlich
auch darauf, dass man seltene Erden und so etwas hat.
Und er bezieht sich jetzt wieder darauf, dass China das gerade alles alleine in der Hand hat.
Bedeutet also auch, wenn wir über erneuerbare Energien und sowas sprechen,
dann hat das sehr viel mit Autarkiebestrebungen zu tun. bedeutet das eigentlich,
dass man Hegemonie möglicherweise verlieren kann.
Das aber erst später, denn wir bleiben nicht bei Jake Sullivan,
wir werden gleich noch zu Adam Toos übergehen.
Sullivan spricht jetzt über die Partner, also über die westlichen Länder,
mit denen man kooperiert oder andere Länder.
Working with our partners to ensure they are building capacity,
resilience, and inclusiveness, too.
Our message to them has been consistent. We will unapologetically pursue our
industrial strategy at home, but we are unambiguously committed to not leaving
our friends behind. We want them to join us. In fact, we need them to join us.
Bedeutet hier ja erstmal so, wir strecken freundschaftlich die Hand aus,
meint aber natürlich auch, ihr müsst jetzt mit uns diesen Weg gehen.
Das heißt, ihr müsst euch auch von anderen Partnern, die nicht auf unserer Seite
sind, also vor allem China, lösen.
Ja, ich erinnere mich noch, wie die Europäische Kommission wütend war,
nachdem es hieß, die Amerikaner geben zu viel Geld für Subventionen und so weiter aus.
Und die machen uns hier platt und die ziehen jetzt die ganzen und so.
Und jetzt heißt es plötzlich, die ziehen uns zu viel Geld aus der Tasche,
weil sie irgendwie verlangen, dass wir die Zollleistung erbringen.
Also das Pendel schlägt ganz schön weit über hin und her.
Und ich meine, es war ja auch so, als der Krieg in der Ukraine begann,
hatte sich ja Macron öffentlich auch im Fernsehen darüber empört,
dass die Amerikaner jetzt Energie an Europa verkaufen,
aber zum dreifachen Preis, den die Amerikaner dafür zahlen müssen.
Und natürlich waren diese großen Subventionspakete der IRA und folgendes,
war ein Angriff auf Europa, beziehungsweise sagte, wir geben jetzt schon in
der ganzen Sache den Ton an.
Interessanterweise kommt Sullivan in diesem zwei Jahre alten Vortrag auf Zölle zu sprechen.
Er sagt jetzt natürlich nicht wie Trump und dann kommen da 30 Prozent und da
50 Prozent drauf, aber er spricht interessant darüber.
Der Hauptprojekt der 1990s der Hauptsache der Hauptsache der Hauptsache war die Tarifte reduziert.
Auf der Bedeutung, die US-Tarifte überprüft wurden in der Bedeutung in der Bedeutung in der 1990s.
Heute, in 2023, unsere Tarifte überprüft ist 2.4%, das ist hoch historisch,
und es ist hoch relativ zu anderen Ländern.
Es ist hoch, hysterisch.
Das ist... Das kritisiert er. Er will, also er sagt nicht, das kann er nicht
tun als Security Advisor, ist nicht das, wofür er da ist. Ja, das ist eh interessant.
Dass er hier so eine...
Also er als Security Advisor, muss man wirklich nochmal sagen,
hält eine Wirtschaftsrede.
Er kann natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, und wir müssten eigentlich Zölle erheben,
das geht über seine Kompetenzen hinaus.
Also ich finde, hier ging schon einiges über seine Kompetenzen hinaus.
Aber es ist tatsächlich verwunderlich und ich würde aber behaupten,
diese Rede, die auch abgelesen ist, also die ist abgesprochen,
der redet hier nicht mal so auf Teufel komm raus los, wie er die Welt sieht,
sondern das ist wirklich die beiden Administrationen, die spricht,
die natürlich jetzt vorsichtig ist bei der Ankündigung von Zöllen,
aber durchaus dem nicht so skeptisch gegenübersteht, wie das jetzt gerade so
erscheint. Ja, der Trump ist der Verrückte mit den Zöllen.
Keineswegs. Worum geht es in der Handelspolitik?
Trade policy needs to be about more than tariff reduction and trade policy needs
to be fully integrated into our economic strategy at home and abroad.
Geoökonomische Strategie. Also wir haben jetzt hier schon das Buch quasi vorweggenommen.
Die große Strategie muss natürlich die sein, wie können wir,
also die USA, sich gegenüber dem Rivalen China behaupten, um Hegemonie zu bleiben. Er sagt dann auch.
Er findet mehrmals in dieser Rede auch lobende Worte für Ursula von der Leyen,
die diesen Washingtoner Kurs ja mitgefahren hat, also der neue Washingtoner
Konsens, dass sie sagte,
ja wir denken jetzt auch über Zölle nach, auf E-Autos von China und all das.
Toll, Grenzanpassungsmechanismus hat sie das genannt.
Sehr schön. Das ist natürlich das ideale Wort für sowas.
A word on China more broadly. As President von der Leyen put it recently,
we are for de-risking and diversifying, not decoupling.
Ja, das war ja der große Singsang mit bis hin zum Außen-Auswärtigen-Amt.
De-risking ist ein Begriff, der wirklich von von der Leyen geprägt wurde und
den haben die Amerikaner übernommen. Es ist ja selten, dass das so geht.
Normalerweise ist es der umgekehrte Weg der Fall.
Er bezieht sich da mehrmals positiv.
Baerbock hat den ja auch so hofiert, diesen Begriff. Und es war aber immer klar,
das ist ein Verlegenheitsbegriff.
Weil wir sehen ja heute, wie man da nicht rauskommt. Und auch in dieser Diskussion,
ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, also es gab damals schon einen Economic
Advisor, aber der war gerade im Wechsel im März.
23 wurde Cecilia Ruz ausgewechselt und dann Jared Bernstein eingewechselt.
Also wahrscheinlich ist er einfach in diese Kompetenzlücke reingesprungen,
um hier so einen Punkt zu machen.
Denn am Ende, das werden wir ja dann lesen, Geoökonomie, sind das nicht trennbare Fragen. Ja, ja.
Es gibt ja gerade… Neuerdings.
Also das vorher… Jetzt sehen wir es so richtig ein. Vorher war es so primat des Ökonomischen.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt auch so Bücher wie, Autor weiß ich gerade nicht,
Apple in China, wo beschrieben wird, und der Typ war ja nun überall zu Gast,
stundenlang bei Scott Galloway und in der Daily Show und so.
Und Apple hat in China drei Millionen Menschen ertüchtigt, Smartphones zu bauen.
Und zwar nicht nur für Apple, sondern grundsätzlich.
Foxconn könnte plötzlich Smartphones bauen. Und zwar so wie Apple,
die selber niemals in Amerika bauen wird.
Das ist nicht nur eine Kapital, sondern dann auch wirklich eine Kompetenzfrage und so.
Und diese ganze Idee ist jetzt eben nicht über diesen Weg zu machen,
also so vorsichtig und dann hier Subventionen und so weiter,
sondern das mit dieser Zollschranke.
Das ist mir dann auch jetzt nochmal deutlich geworden, weil Trump hat ja Apple
jetzt richtig auf den Kicker und es gibt ja jetzt gezielte Zollandrohungen nur
für iPhones. 25 Prozent.
Und dann hat er sich korrigiert und hat dann für alle Smartphones,
die hier produziert werden, gesagt, es ist ein Apple-Zoll.
Das ist ein Apple-Zoll. Und das Interessante ist ja, über die Brechstange ist das gar nicht zu machen.
Wenn man sich die Kennziffern anschaut, wenn das iPhone an der Grenze 25% Preisaufschlag
erhält, ergibt sich damit gar kein Druck, auch nur ein iPhone mehr in Amerika
zu herzustellen, sondern man sagt sich einfach,
ja gut, 25% zahlen wir.
Selbst bei 100 Prozent wird der Apple noch sagen, es würde sich nicht lohnen,
in die Anstrengung zu gehen, hier in Amerika zu bauen. Wir lägen immer über
diesen 100 Prozent Zoll.
War es die New York Times oder eine der großen...
Also wenn man es irgendwie 250 Zoll oder so androhen und dann hätte man vielleicht
in zehn Jahren Apple so weit...
War es die New York Times oder eine andere große Zeitung, die haben nochmal
ausgerechnet, was es kosten würde, wenn man das iPhone tatsächlich,
hätte man auch das Know-how in Amerika produzieren.
Wollen würde, dann käme man bei einem iPhone-Preis von über 3000 Dollar raus.
Also das ist der dreifache Preis vom allerbesten iPhone, das es gibt.
Also alles unter einer 200 Zoll einer echten Zollgrenze.
Wäre gar kein Incentive hinsichtlich dieser Politik, wie Trump sie jetzt macht.
Also man muss es tatsächlich so ein bisschen filigran und hier und so.
Genau, macht nur den Konsumenten ein bisschen ärmer. Genau, einfach nur 100 Euro mehr zahlen. Ja.
Sullivan spricht jetzt mal über das Selbstverständnis. Also es ist wirklich
interessant auch zu sehen, wie selbstbewusst Amerikaner sprechen.
Also wo er eigentlich das sieht.
Ja, aber ich finde jetzt in so einer ganz sachlichen Rede, in der man sagt ja,
ich erzähle euch mal was über Ökonomie und Sicherheit und Lieferketten und all das.
Also die Idee ist ja hier tatsächlich zu sagen, ich rede ganz viel über die
Mitte der Gesellschaft und darüber, dass das BIP nicht alles ist und wir haben
es da mit manchen Sachen vielleicht übertrieben.
Aber es geht natürlich vor allem darum zu sagen, wir richten uns mit unserer
Politik so aus, dass wir weiterhin Hegemonen in der Welt bleiben.
Und das wird dann in folgende Worte gefasst.
And it means returning to the core belief we first championed 80 years ago,
that America should be at the heart of a vibrant international financial system
that enables partners around the world to reduce poverty and enhanced shared prosperity.
At the heart, also wir sind das Zentrum, nicht irgendwas anderes,
also nicht multipolare Weltordnung oder irgendetwas.
Und er bringt dann ein Kennedy-Zitat, das alle schon mal zumindest in der Hälfte gehört haben.
Und das hat mich dann doch etwas erschreckt.
Präsident Kennedy sagte, dass eine Riesen-Tide-Lifte all-Boatste.
Über die Jahre, die Aufmerksamkeit der Econologischen Econologien verabschieden
diese Fase für ihre eigenen Wunschung.
Also das kennen wir alle, ne? Dann steigt doch für alle der Wohlstand,
wenn wir nur den Reichen helfen.
Er sagt, na ja, das sei mal falsch interpretiert worden und erklärt jetzt, wie er das sieht.
Er ist nicht gesagt, was für die Wealthe ist gut für die Working-Class.
Er war gesagt, wir sind alle in das zusammen.
Und look at was er gesagt, wenn eine section der Lande ist, dann später oder
später ein Drobbingtide drops all boats.
Das ist jetzt noch auf die Volkswirtschaft, die amerikanische bezogen.
Also man kann nicht einfach mit Trickle-Down-Economy oder sowas arbeiten.
Den Schritt, den er jetzt aber macht, ist, dieses Kennedy-Zitat auf die globale
Ordnung zu heben, indem er sagt,
Economisch.
Über die Zeit, wir werden weiterentwickeln.
Bedeutet jetzt als Ansage an die Partner in Anführungszeichen,
also entweder sind wir der Hegemon oder wir gehen bei dem Versuch unter Hegemon
zu sein, aber dann werdet ihr mit uns untergehen.
Ja, das ist das Trump-Programm jetzt.
Das ist Trump-Programm. Von Jake Sullivan in einer völlig anderen Rhetorik,
sehr höflich vorgetragen. Trump klingt anders.
Der redet zum Beispiel so über die Zölle, die alles teurer machen.
Viele werden den Clip schon gehört haben, aber wir spielen ihn nochmal.
Es geht jetzt um die Mädchen und ihre Puppen.
Wenn wir zum Präsident Xi sprechen, wenn wir zum Präsidenten sprechen,
und ich habe Ihnen gesagt, dass sie eine große Schwierigkeit haben,
weil ihre Faktoren nicht arbeiten. business.
They made a trillion dollars with Biden, a trillion dollars,
even a trillion one with Biden selling us stuff.
Much of it we don't need. Somebody said, oh, the shelves are going to be open.
Well, maybe the children will have two dollars instead of thirty dollars,
and maybe the two dollars will cost a couple of bucks more than they would normally.
But we're not talking about something that we have to go out of our way.
They have ships that are loaded up with stuff, much of which,
not all of it, but much of which.
Wir haben ja das mit einem Präsidenten zu tun, der sich offenbar der Degrowth-Ökonomie
angeschossen hat und sagt, wir brauchen gar nicht so viele Sachen.
Warum muss ein Kinderzimmer voll sein mit 30 Puppen? Zwei tun es doch auch und
die sind dann auch ein bisschen teurer.
Klar, denn die sind ja dann nicht mehr in China, sondern in den USA produziert.
Wir sehen ja alle, wie er lebt. Dass es überhaupt etwas gäbe,
was man nicht bräuchte und deswegen nicht hätte.
Gut, aber das kennen wir ja generell auch von unseren Politikern.
Wir sehen ja auch Jens Spahn, da sitzen wir ja dem Rentner, der kaum über die
Runden kommt, nochmal sagt, jetzt streng dich mal an und reiß dich mal zusammen.
Wer arbeitet denn zu wenig, die Rentner?
Also da gibt es ja nichts. Oder wir haben ja auch einen fliegenden Bundeskanzler, der sagt...
Hochzeit auf Silt? Ich komme.
Aber auf keinen Fall kommt das neuen Euro-Ticket zurück. Wo wollen wir denn dahin?
Das ist ganz interessant, dass wir das jetzt haben. Es gibt ja,
das kann man nachlesen, dieses Substack von Adam Thues oder auch ein Gespräch
mit Zyplas, das er geführt hat.
Er sagte ja, es gab diesen Artikel von Naomi Klein im Guardian,
in dem sie sagte, das ist jetzt Endzeit-Faschismus, was Trump sagt.
Die haben überhaupt keine Perspektive, keine Zukunft vor Augen.
Und dem widerspricht ja Toos auch aufgrund dieses Clips und weiteren Dingen,
nämlich er sagt, nee, die haben ja tatsächlich ein Ziel, die sagen ja sogar,
jetzt müssen wir erst einmal verzichten, also nicht 30 Puppen,
sondern nur noch zwei und all das und das soll dann zu irgendeiner großen neuen
amerikanischen Vision führen.
Und Tooth ist natürlich genauso wie wir ein großer Skeptiker,
dass diese Vision aufgeht. Ist ja auch mal egal.
Ob sie aufgeht.
Interessant ist nur, man kann dann nicht sagen, die machen Endzeitkapitalismus,
sondern was das und das macht es ja vielleicht noch gefährlicher ist ja, dass J.D.
Vance und die im Hintergrund, die wir auch schon zum Teil im Salon erwähnt hatten,
dass die dann durchaus von einer Erneuerung der ganzen Nation träumen.
Und dafür jetzt erst einmal ein Tal der Tränen versprechen, durch das man hindurch muss.
Genau. Wir gucken jetzt oder hören jetzt Clips von Adam Too's.
Du hast mir vorher schon kurz angekündigt, dass sie so ein bisschen selten sind
und aus obskuren Ecken des Internets herausgekramt, kannst du ja gleich nochmal sagen.
Nur, weil du jetzt gesagt hast, das Ziel. Ja, also wir müssen hier,
glaube ich, ganz hart unterscheiden zwischen einem Ziel und einem Weg dahin.
Genau.
So, bei dem Ziel, ja. Also Trump ist ein amerikanischer Präsident und unterscheidet
sich, was das angeht, ganz schön wenig von anderen amerikanischen Präsidenten.
Aber in dem Weg dahin, und dieser Puppenclip gerade, brauchen unsere kleinen
Mädels wirklich immer 30 Puppen, reichen nicht zwei.
Amerika ist ja sehr gut darin, diese Verzichtsverpflichtung der eigenen Bevölkerung aufzubürden.
Also man fährt durch Kalifornien und sieht, da gibt es einen großen Streit zwischen
Gavin Newsom und allen Obdachlosen.
Und diese Obdachlosen haben nicht zwei Puppen, sondern gar keine.
Also Amerika kann verzichten.
Genau, aber es ist nicht normalerweise Doktrin der Politik.
Also Joe Biden würde nicht sagen, wir müssen was gegen den Klimawandel tun und
deswegen müsst ihr jetzt alle verzichten.
Sondern er sagt, es macht euch reich, es bringt euch mehr Jobs,
die Industrie kommt zurück und dann haben wir auch noch ein bisschen was fürs Klima getan.
Genau, also dieser Verzicht wurde bisher von den Amerikanern geduldet,
weil man ihnen eingeredet hat, dass ein Klassenkampf albern ist und dass es
ihr eigenes Schicksal war, jetzt hier zu verenden.
Nur diese Verzichtsdiskussion bei Leuten, die ihren Kindern 30 Puppen kaufen,
betrifft Menschen, die wissen, wie sie sich wehren.
Das kennt man ja in Deutschland auch. Klar haben wir diese Stadtteile,
wo nur noch sieben Prozent, das ist die echte Zahl, ins Wahllokal gehen und
ansonsten auch ökonomisch nichts stattfindet und 40 Prozent kriegt, wie auch immer.
Aber es gibt eben auch die Stadtteile, in denen die Leute für jeden Scheiß kämpfen.
Und dann ruft man die Lehrerin an und meldet sich und hier und da und dann werden
ganz viele kleine Kämpfe geführt.
Und ob Amerika das hinbekommt, sich gegen die schreienden, ich gehe nochmal
zu der Veranstaltung mit dem republikanischen Senator und der versucht mir jetzt
Trumps Verzichtsdoktrin aufzubürden,
das durchzuhalten, das wird schon gefährlich in Amerika.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Adam Thues, ich habe es ja noch nicht gehört,
nachdem wir jetzt den letzten Vortrag, der uns ja schon sehr zu denken gegeben
hat mit der chinesischen Gefahr und der schießenden Auseinandersetzung,
die da droht, dass man jetzt auch Bürgerkriegswarnungen von Ökonomen hört.
Er spricht jetzt tatsächlich nicht
über dieses. Es geht tatsächlich um die Geopolitik. Er ist eingeladen.
Es ist gar keine verrückte Ecke, wo er das macht, sondern er ist eingeladen
bei der Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung.
Die haben den ganzen Tag gemacht, eine lange Konferenz, acht Stunden über geostrategische
Herausforderungen auf Bezug auf Nachhaltigkeit, Nachhaltigkeitsstrategien auf globaler Ebene.
Jetzt kommt als letztes Adam Toos und hält da eine Rede,
man findet aber leider diesen Stream noch nicht öffentlich beziehungsweise er
ist öffentlich also man kann, das Video ist nicht gelistet bei YouTube,
man kann es also nicht so finden, aber es wurde gestreamt das war ja ein Event,
wo man sagte, man streamt das auch alles,
auch mit einigermaßen guter Technik,
man hat es aber offenbar noch nicht geschafft, da.
Einzelvideos draus zu machen Was ich raten würde, das mal zu tun,
denn das ist ein sehr wichtiger Vortrag.
Die anderen Vorträge davor habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Er spricht jetzt über das Thema Nachhaltigkeit und wir haben ja auch mit Precht
in dem Buch zugestimmt und das war auch schon länger meine Ansicht.
Eigentlich ist doch die Klimakatastrophe auch eine gewisse Chance,
sich als Menschheitsfamilie gemeinsam zu organisieren, zu sehen.
Das ist doch toll, dass wir jetzt immerhin in dieser Sache alle betroffen sind.
Bedeutet also, wir können auch alle an einem Strang ziehen. Das wäre jetzt die Intuition.
Jetzt kommt die Kontraintuition von Adam Toos, der sagt, nee,
also das mit dem Klimawandel,
Und der Nachhaltigkeitspolitik, das ist ein Angriff.
Man fragt sich auf was? Naja, auf die amerikanische Hegemonie.
Und wir hören jetzt Auszüge aus diesem Vortrag, beginnen mal mit Adam Toos und
der Entwicklung von China.
China's growth is clearly the greatest development success story in human history, bar none.
It's not even arguable in terms of the scale of the transition from poverty
to bearable prosperity.
China, not just as a result of COVID, has a longer life expectancy than the United States today.
That's a staggering fact compared to where China was in the 1960s.
But it has blown the environmental equation up, and there is no getting around
that fact. Das ist die scale von China's CO2-emissions.
Und es hat sich aus den USA, der Punkt der Sicht, als eine fundamental challenge.
At the level of what we call in social science ontological security.
The sort of destabilisation that we blame, for instance, for voters going to the AfD in Germany.
It has destabilised the United States both at the level of national security on the global stage.
And what the economists call the China shock.
To which Americans attribute an incredible array of domestic social dysfunction.
Ist zu den sogenannten Impacten von Chinesien.
Wie groß das eigentlich ist, und wie viel man sich darüber diskutieren kann,
ist, dass für die Amerikaner Gesellschaft China die destabilisierenden Faktor ist.
China wird als die destabilisierende Kraft angesehen, gerade weil China so erfolgreich
war, weil die Leute aus der Armut gekommen sind, weil man eine solche wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung hingelegt hat.
Spekuliert dann mal, was wäre denn, wenn es jetzt ein anderes Land wäre.
Denn wir haben natürlich auch immer es einfach aus dem Westen heraus China als
das Problem darzustellen, weil es ja sowieso so regiert ist,
wie es regiert ist, autoritär.
Wir haben diese kommunistische Partei, die aber auch nicht wirklich kommunistisch
ist. Gar nicht kommunistisch. Diese Überwachung, all das.
Kein Sozialstaat und nichts.
Man hat eine Glorifizierung der Mao-Ära, keine kritische Vergangenheitsbewältigung oder irgendetwas.
Es ist also relativ leicht, China als Problemland in der Weise dann ideologisch einzuordnen.
Aber er sagt ja, was wäre denn das, wenn das Brasilien oder so gewesen wäre?
Und das ist sicherlich die größte Geschichte der Menschen-Developung der wir noch nie gesehen haben.
So, imagine für einen Moment, dass das nicht nur in China passiert.
Imagine für einen Moment, wenn Brasil oder Mexiko der GDP-Kapita über die letzten paar Jahre.
Es ist keine Frage, dass viele Amerikaner riech werden würden.
Es ist keine Frage, dass viele Menschen davon profitieren würden.
Aber ich denke, wenn Sie denken, dass Washington das als geopolitisch neutral
und nachzudenken würde,
um glücklich zu leben, mit dem Kraft in der Westen-Hemisphäre mit einem Brasilien,
der viermal größer ist in der GDP per capita oder in Mexiko,
dann bist du dir schuldig.
Würde man also aus der amerikanischen Perspektive heraus die Macht teilen mit
einem anderen Land, das dann plötzlich stärker ist als das eigene?
Ein bisschen die Frage, wie man es verrechnet. Die amerikanischen Unternehmen
haben ja extrem davon profitiert, in China zu produzieren und in die ganze Welt
zu verkaufen und das Geld aber wieder in Amerika zu verbuchen.
Und in der Hinsicht hat ja Amerika schon sehr davon profitiert,
dass China diese Werkbankpolitik gemacht hat.
Deswegen hat man sie auch lange betrieben. Und bis hin zu Obama und Hillary
Clinton, die dann schon merkten, na irgendwas ist da.
Genau, bis diese Deindustrialisierung auffiel, die da Salimini hat.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich würde sagen, bis auch China einen Grad erreicht hat
an politischer, militärischer, wirtschaftlicher Stärke, mit der plötzlich die
amerikanische Vormachtstellung infrage gestellt wird.
Denn natürlich hat Amerika überhaupt kein Problem damit gehabt und hat der Westen
auch kein Problem damit gehabt, reich zu werden durch diese unglaubliche Entwicklung in China.
Und natürlich sehen wir auch gerne die günstigen Produkte aus China bei uns.
Aber da, wo es plötzlich um dann doch Geopolitik geht, ist es wieder anders.
Wir hatten in den 90er Jahren, darauf rekurriert jetzt Thuss nochmal,
diese Vorstellung von einer Welt ohne Supermachten. Das ist eine sehr europäische Idee.
Er bringt das nochmal so gerade in einem Abwasch, nennt er so ein paar Namen.
Think about how Shimon Peres imagined a new Middle East in the 1990s to be delivered
upon European lines because it was going to be an Abraham Accord mega with Palestine
folded in that was going to deliver peace.
There is a deep tendency on the part of Europeans and notably Germans to think that economic success,
economic integration necessarily leads beyond national sovereignty,
necessarily leads towards Confederation, ideally leads you up to the world state of the UN.
Think about Habermas in the 2010s speculating about the EU as a precursor to a world order.
Das haben wir auch so in uns, glaube ich, drin. Also ich glaube auch wir beide.
Also wir würden eigentlich auch gerne eine Welt sehen als United Colors of Benetton.
Also wir sind da und das Problem ist aber, dass er sagt,
Das nationalstaatliche Denken, von dem man sagt, das verlieren wir doch.
Es gibt auch eine Publikumsfrage, habe ich jetzt nicht drin,
wo dann jemand sagt, ja, aber ist das überhaupt noch zeitgemäß so zu denken
im postnationalen Zeitalter? Und dann sagt, ja, wo ist das postnationale Zeitalter?
Naja, also im Kopf ist es ja tatsächlich nicht mehr. Wenn wir einfach einen
Fernseher anmachen und dann läuft Amazon mit Hollywood-Videos und so, das ist, da ist kein.
Das ist Post-National. Und das ist aber nicht auf die Ebene der harten Geopolitik,
auch nicht der harten Geopolitik gekommen.
Da würde dann immer ein Mörscheimer sagen, ja bitte, wo ist dann die übergeordnete
Instanz, die das macht? Da draußen ist es Anarchie.
Und so eigentlich auch die Interpretation von Thoos.
Er spricht jetzt über diese Selbstbehauptung auch der Länder wieder.
Whereas, historically speaking, the opposite is true. The vast majority of states
that have pursued sustainable development have done it so as to resist external
power and then to become powers themselves.
That's the point of development for the vast majority of places.
Ja, wir haben diese Souveränitätsbewegungen und Behauptungen überall.
Das ist ja auch in Russland gleichermaßen zu beobachten wie in allen Regionen
der Welt eigentlich, dass es immer um diese nationalstaatliche Souveränitätsbehauptung geht,
die dann auch bedeutet,
dass man eine gewisse Autarkie erlangen will.
Aber sah das nicht wirklich so aus, als wäre das überwunden?
Also jetzt gerade haben wir das wieder.
Aber so ein 90er, wo einfach völlig klar war, Amerika ist Urlaubsland,
da gehen die Kinder hin und machen ihre Bildungskram und überhaupt und so.
Da gab es ja eigentlich schon so einen großen postnationalen,
so eine Hauruck-Aktion zumindest mal.
Gut, im Pentagon wird man das nie so gesehen haben, aber so im Ganzen sagen
wir das so und das ist auch die Stimmung.
Es ist ja auch, wenn du dir die Blockbuster ansiehst, Ende der 90er,
vor allem der Nullerjahre dann und noch bis in die 10er hinein,
dann hast du ja diese ganzen kulturellen Transfers und wo die überall spielen.
Also du hast ja Filme, nicht nur wie James Bond, die überall angelegt sind,
wo aber dann noch so eine politische Komponente dabei ist, sondern du bist überall,
denk an den Julia Roberts Film, Eat, Pray, Love.
Also du gehst nach Indien zum Beten, nach Italien zum Lieben.
Also du bist dann überall. Und das ist eigentlich diese kosmopolitische Seinsweise,
die aber mit einem konsumistischen Ich einhergeht, die aber natürlich immer
nur dann da ist, wenn nicht plötzlich wieder nationale Interessen kommen.
Jetzt haben wir über so viel Selbstbehauptung, Souveränität und all das Red,
was hat denn das jetzt auf einem Nachhaltigkeitskongress zu tun?
Und jetzt kommt diese entscheidende Idee von Toos.
Because sovereignty is another word for collective freedom. And if the point
of sustainable development is empowerment, then the classic way of understanding
that within the nation-state framework is not immediately to sign on to a UN
treaty in which you sign away your sovereignty.
Your immediate impulse is to actually use it to empower your state to exercise
a kind of sovereignty it's been previously denied.
And that is the reality, I think, that we have not dealt with and is key to
understanding the American defection from the paradigm.
Bedeutet jetzt?
Somehow there is going to be a future beyond fossil fuel that will,
or, and this is of course what the American conservatives sense,
is that you lovely people in this room here are conspiring against American power.
And actually you all know perfectly well that this is the case.
And when you say you want to realise the sustainable development agenda,
you're actually saying, as they say in their letter to the United Nations,
that you're smuggling in a geopolitics which is fundamentally hostile to the
power of the United States.
Nachher, Nachhaltigkeitspolitik ist eine Form der Geopolitik, bedeutet,
wir machen hier uns mit der Energie autark, bedeutet, wir sind nicht mehr abhängig
von einer amerikanischen Hegemonie,
bedeutet also, man stellt sich in Opposition zur amerikanischen Hegemonie,
Bedeutet jetzt für die beiden Administrationen schon, anders ausgedrückt natürlich dann,
als das Trump tut, aber bedeutet dann auch für die Trump-Administration,
diesen Weg geht ihr mal lieber nicht mit, wenn ihr unsere Partner seid,
sondern nur so wie wir uns das vorstellen, weshalb ja auch die USA größte Gas-
und Ölproduzenten geworden sind.
Und diese Idee zu sagen, ja eigentlich ist das doch toll Nachhaltigkeit und
wir kommen ja da zu so einer Welt, wo alle Menschen quasi davon profitieren,
wenn alle nachhaltig leben und so,
das ist natürlich auf der Klimaebene wahnsinnig gut gedacht.
Sobald man aber auf dieses nationalstaatliche Denken geht, und das tut ja hier
Two's für uns, dann kommen wir plötzlich in Rivalitäten.
Und man kann natürlich sagen, ja, aber wir retten ja nur die Umwelt.
Und dann sagen die, nee, ihr macht euch aber jetzt gerade auch los von uns.
Ihr werdet ja unabhängig. Ihr habt ja jetzt plötzlich eine eigene Macht.
Also ich bin noch an dem Punkt, wo ich mir denke, Adam Two's verspielt es vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr.
Denn ja, wir alle kennen noch diese Welt, in der es hieß, Der 11.
September, Arabien, man geht in den Irak, braucht irgendwelche Anlässe,
aber eigentlich geht es ums Öl.
Und dann kommen so Diskussionen wie Peak-Öl, gibt es bald kein Öl mehr?
Also wird es jetzt noch kontroverser, wie da Politik gemacht wird?
Profitiert Europa sehr davon, dass Amerika die Seewege der Öllieferung aus den
arabischen Räumen nach Europa absichert und so weiter und ist damit dann Hegemon, dem man einfach folgt?
Finde ich alles gut, nur wir haben ja, das klingt so ein bisschen profan,
aber das Balkonkraftwerk, jeder macht sich abhängig, nicht nur von Amerika,
unabhängig, sondern auch vom lokalen Energieerzeuger oder wie auch immer.
Und Amerika ist ja auch ein großer Förderer. Also Texas, dieser Ausbau von Wind
und Solar ist ja da wirklich enorm.
Ich sehe ja jetzt so ein bisschen, was thematisch kommt. Das geht ja alles in
so eine Richtung. Also ich sehe jetzt schon Houthi und Drohnen und so.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, denn noch glaube ich.
Du hast ja völlig recht.
Es schleppt noch so eine Geschichte nach in dieses Thema.
Die vielleicht… Es ist eine individuelle Autarkie, die man erreichen kann mit Balkonkraftwerk etc.
Bedeutet aber auch im Ganzen, es ist also eine Loslösung von einem Machtblock,
den man benötigt, um da zum Beispiel Öl herzubekommen.
Genau.
Das waren mal eine Zeit lang die arabischen Staaten, bedeutete dann für die
USA Ölpreisschock, all das.
Und dann haben die USA Fracking in hohem Maße gesetzt, um da sich nicht mehr
dann auch so involvieren zu müssen in diese Kämpfe. Also das ist ja auch interessant,
wie sehr sich die USA zurückgezogen haben.
Also nach George W. Bush Jr.
Kommt dann ja Barack Obama und der lässt das ja schon alles so ein bisschen
liegen und dann später der Abzug aus Afghanistan dann erst, aber eigentlich
hat man das ja schon viel früher aufgegeben für sich und auch sich in andere
Dinge nicht mehr so eingemischt,
weil man auch dann eine größere Autonomie plötzlich schon erlangt hatte durch Fracking.
Und das ist jetzt diese eine Sache, das bedeutet aber immer noch,
dass die Partner sehr stark davon abhängig waren.
Aber generell ist natürlich, wenn es zu einer Dezentralisierung kommt und das
ist eben bei den Erneuerbaren am allerstärksten so, dass man tatsächlich sagen
könnte, ich lebe hier autark, ich brauche noch nicht mal mehr die Stadt Frankfurt
im Ganzen dafür, sondern kann mich da machen.
Das bedeutet aber dann für die Volkswirtschaften an sich gedacht,
also für diese Rahmungen, die brauchen dann die anderen Länder auch nicht mehr.
Also das heißt, das Nation Building oder die souveräne Selbstbehauptung, die nimmt dadurch zu.
Bedeutet also, dass all das eine Gefahr ist für einen Hegemon,
der eigentlich das Ganze leiten will.
Das ist ja die Überlegung von Tuths. Und er sagt,
da ist zum einen China, die sich aufgrund überhaupt dieser Möglichkeiten,
die die neue Technologie,
Solarenergie und all das gibt, sich in dieser Weise entwickeln konnte und diese
technischen Möglichkeiten haben ja auch zu einer enormen Verbilligung geführt von Energie.
Und bedeutet aber auch Verbilligung von Kriegstechnologie. Er spricht jetzt
über folgendes Problem.
The comprehensive global development versus the status quo power system is what
I'm calling the China slash Houthi problem.
In other words, as soon as anyone actually develops, they challenge the global
power structure and all you need to do is Houthi level development and you're
challenging the global power structure.
Was meint ihr damit? Naja, die Houthis und viele andere schaffen sich für 10 Millionen,
für 50 Millionen Drohnen an und können damit die Weltordnung entscheidend mit
beeinflussen, können dafür sorgen, dass wir große Probleme bekommen,
ob die Importe noch funktionieren und und und. Mit ganz wenig Budget.
Also du hast ja hier diese großen Diskussionen, müssen es 100 Milliarden für
die Bundeswehr, 500 Milliarden.
Und die sagen, wir gucken mal, ob wir irgendwo 10 Millionen finden.
Dann fährt da kein Schiff mehr durch.
Dann fährt da kein Schiff mehr durch. Und das ist plötzlich auch natürlich eben
so eine Fragestellung der Hegemonie.
Auch nochmal bezogen auf die Ukraine können wir nochmal das mit den Drohnen herausheben.
Hier ein Auszug aus dem Ronsheimer Podcast, da war Julian Röpke von der Bild-Zeitung
zu Gast, der spricht über die Drohnen.
Also hätte die Ukraine nicht so unfassbar innovativ kleine zivile Quadrokopter
in tödliche Waffen verwandelt, stellte die russische Armee heute längst in Saporizha-Stadt,
in Libro-Stadt, in Kharkiv-Stadt.
Also das ist das Einzige, was die Russen auffällt. Wir wissen von den Ukrainern,
dass aktuell 80 Prozent der russischen Verluste aus Kamikaze-Drohnen-Angriffe erfolgen.
Also ukrainische Angriffe mit kleinen Quadrokoptern, mit Sprengladung,
töten 80 Prozent der russischen Soldaten, die getötet werden in der Ukraine.
Und daran sieht man eben, wenn das nicht passieren würde, die Artillerie oder
Panzer oder was auch immer da noch alles ist.
Hat überhaupt nicht das Potenzial, was eben diese kleinen Killermaschinen haben.
Und nur deshalb sind die Russen so langsam im Vormarsch, weil sie eben für jeden
Kilometer mit so vielen Menschen bezahlen müssen.
Jetzt können wir uns fragen, was war aber denn eigentlich das Pariser Klimaabkommen?
Das fragt sich Adam Tuss natürlich auch.
2015, da war doch mit Obama im Einklang eigentlich ein großes Verständnis dafür,
wir müssen das 1,5 Grad Ziel erreichen und zwar gemeinsam.
Da war doch eine Welt, eine Menschheit, ein Klima.
Wenn man doch diese geopolitischen Prämissen erst einmal setzt,
dann ist das doch eigentlich unwahrscheinlich, dass man sich auf so ein Klimaabkommen
in dieser Weise einigen kann.
Er meint, Adam Tu ist auch dann, führt das länger aus, muss man sich vielleicht
den Vortrag nochmal ganz anhören.
Meint dann auch, naja, wie ernst war das so gemeint.
Und das letzte Element ist, und das ist, ich denke, wo wir wirklich hingehen,
ist, dass sie nie dachte, es war, dass es nicht irgendwo gehen würde.
Sie sagen, dass, wenn es wirklich sehr ist, sie hätten eine Veto-Power über es gegeben.
Und Sie sehen das, in den Texten, die wir uns überlegen, wie die Paris Agreement von 2015.
At der letzten Minute, in den letzten paar Stunden, als ich verstehe,
der Nogationskontakt, die ganze
Sache almost blew up, weil die Frische Secretariat insertet die Sprache,
made it so binding that the American administration would have to present it
to Congress, and they know since Byrd-Hagel in 1997 that you're never going
to get this past the Congress.
And so it was written out, and the nationally determined contributions were
lightened to the point where an American administration can sign up.
It's a difference between should and must, or should and ought,
or it's a legal, literally one word that changes it from acceptable to the American
administration to a dead in the water, dead as a duck.
Also es war eigentlich ein zernloser Tiger?
Und ja, so zahnlos war der so.
Naja, also die Idee ist ja hier ganz klar zu sagen, wir können das da machen,
aber schon unter unserer Hegemonie.
Also das ist ja was, was Jake Sullivan jetzt auch eben vorgestellt hat.
Der würde auch immer sagen, ja Klimawandel und so weiter, wichtig,
kämpfen wir mit unserem Partner, aber schon auch USA at the heart.
Und das ist jetzt das, was Thoos so kritisiert, dass das so lange übersehen wurde.
Mit Trump wird das natürlich alles wahnsinnig offensichtlich,
da wir ja von ihm wissen, er lügt, aber er spricht durch die unverfrorenen Wahrheiten
im Gegensatz zu anderen Politikern ja aus.
Und da gab es jetzt auch gleich nicht irgendwie, wir gucken mal über nochmal
Klimawandel und so weiter, sondern sie haben ja tatsächlich so ein Statement,
wo sie sagen, wir weisen das zurück.
Also sie weisen diese Klimapolitik wirklich zurück. Er sagt.
Es war immer da. Und was wir sehen, ist die Bluff von den Europäern,
den Japanischen und all den anderen Menschen von Goodwill, die mit dem mit dem,
die mit dem, mit dem, was die Kompromisse wurden von der Trump-Administration bezeichnet.
Die Trump-Administration ist, Sie sagen, wir wollen Ihre depolitikationen,
liberalen Bluff. Wir sehen Sie. Wir wissen gut, was Ihre agenda ist. Es ist obvious.
Wir wissen, Sie versuchen, Sie zu smuggeln in ein paar Sachen mit ESG und Sustainable
Development Goals. Wir werden nicht kaufen, das.
Und interessanterweise, sie tust das jetzt nicht nur bei Trump.
Wir totalen Rejecten, und das ist nicht nur Trump, aber auch Biden,
die thesis, dass die Amerika muss, weil es historisch gegründet ist.
Nein, Amerika wird auf der Helle von exceptionalism sein. Es wird auf der Helle von dominanzieren.
Ja, also ich finde, das Thema Energieversorgung ist so fundamental und wichtig,
dass ich es ja selbst im Familienbuch zentral gemacht habe, aber eben auch ein
bisschen verspielt. Deswegen vermute ich hier auch, da ist noch so eine Spielerei drin.
Klar, wir haben jetzt ein Kohle, ein Öl, ein Gaszeitalter, was mit der Klammer,
dafür braucht man Bodenschätze, dafür braucht man große Maschinen,
dafür braucht man Transportwege, riesige Tanker, der ganze Kram.
Und wer das hat und kontrolliert und steuert, der steuert sozusagen.
Also es ist ja immer die Frage, was ist der Maßstab für Souveränität?
Was ist der Maßstab für ist ein Hegemon oder nicht?
Das sind ja auch mehr so Sprachbilder, mit denen man so arbeitet.
Und dass wir jetzt gerade in so einer riesigen Zäsur sind, ist klar.
Nur jetzt haben wir eben China es überlassen, also gerade wir Europäer ja auch,
Zum Schutze der Autoindustrie geht die ganze von Rot-Grün geförderte erneuerbare
Technologie einfach nach China.
Wir waren ja Platz 1 der Welt mit 50% Marktanteil Solarpaneele und so. Wir Deutschen.
Und jetzt ist es China. Das wird alles Veränderungen mit sich bringen und die
kann man auch unter dieser alten Doktrin Energieversorgung fossil so beobachten
und dann so kritische Kommentare draus stricken.
Nur das ändert ja nichts daran, dass es über den Preisdruck diese Veränderung einfach gibt.
Ja, zur Erneuerbaren, zur Detrenzalität, dass jedes Unternehmen demnächst es
einpreist, einfach zu sagen, okay, in Deutschland ist jetzt Pflicht,
ein Solardach auf die Gewerbefläche und dann erst, wenn man das in Betrieb nimmt,
sieht man, wie viel Strom da eigentlich rauskommt.
Das hätte sich der Chef vorher gar nicht vorstellen können. man hat mit seinen
zehn Mitarbeitern einfach ein, was weiß ich, Lagergewerbe irgendwas gemacht
und plötzlich ist man auch noch Stromerzeuger.
Also diese Technologie bringt halt an sich so viel mit und es braucht jetzt
neue Erzählungen und ich weiß nicht, ob Adam Tues noch so die alte Erzählung.
Nee, ist gar nicht bei der alten Erzählung, wie wir gleich sehen werden.
Was er nur sagt ist, dass das alles etwas ist, was die Amerikaner und auch schon
unter beiden kritisch gesehen haben, weil das plötzlich ihnen Macht nimmt.
Und das bedeutet auch dann im Umkehrschluss, sind das also unsere Partner gewesen,
mit denen man wirklich gegen den Klimawandel kämpft oder sind wir einem Plaf
aufgesessen, wie er das jetzt gerade beschreibt.
Was du jetzt beschreibst über die Kostenfrage, dass am Ende die Entscheidung
über das Portemonnaie gefällt wird, ist völlig klar.
Ich hatte das Vergnügen, mit einem ehemaligen Lehrer von mir zu telefonieren über 70.
Und das war jemand, der immer so alle zwei Jahre ein neues Auto fuhr.
Und das war schon für den alles sehr wichtig. Und das ist für den auch immer noch wichtig.
Er erzählte mir als erstes quasi am Telefon ganz begeistert,
dass er jetzt ein E-Auto hat, dass er Photovoltaik nachdem er ein Kraft, er hatte erst so ein
Balkonkraftwerk und jetzt hatte er ganz auf Photovoltaik auf dem Dach umgestellt
und muss nicht mehr tanken.
Finanziert das alles darüber also über das was da von der Sonne kommt und auch
noch sonst und er sagt selbst dann und dann noch und dann er lebt jetzt da quasi
autark und das ist bei ihm, weil er immer jemand war der immer über Preise redete,
für ihn nur eine Portemonnaiefrage,
also wir haben nicht einmal über, also wir haben lange gesprochen,
wir haben nicht einmal über Habeck und nicht über die Grünen und was ist da sonst irgendwie.
Für ihn war die Frage, ist das für mich sinnvoll?
Die Frage ist mit dem Portemonnaie, mit dem Blick ins Portemonnaie beantwortet.
Also manchmal kann es einfach ganz einfach sein und dann ist jede weitere Erzählung
nur so nachgeschleifte Semantik, die nochmal die alte Welt beschreibt.
Das bedeutet also jetzt, wenn wie er, wie Tu es sagt, wenn man also China als
die eigentliche Gefahr jetzt ansieht und sagt,
dann ist mir der Klimawandel egal,
sondern ich muss sehen, dass ich China bekämpfe, bedeutet das natürlich,
auch,
bedeutet also, das ist jetzt nicht mehr unser Thema und wir haben es von Trump
gehört, Drill, Baby, Drill, aber das war ja auch die Politik von Biden schon.
Also es ist lustig, dass Trump das mal so darstellt, als sei das jetzt so sein großes Ding.
Unter Biden ist es natürlich dazu gekommen.
Naja, Biden musste das immer sehr verstecken. Ich war auch einmal überrascht,
als ich hörte, dass das bei der Jugend so ein großes Thema war,
dass irgend so ein unter dem Eis irgendwo so ein Öllager.
Und das war das bestimmende Thema über Wochen und Monate, dass die Amerikaner
nur noch eine Unterschrift davon entfernt sind, dass Biden das unterschreibt.
Und dann hat Biden das unterschrieben. Und es war nicht mal in den Tagesthemen,
also nirgendwo war das Meldung.
Aber das war dort ganz groß.
Aber die jungen Leute hat das wirklich aufgebracht. Ja, Trump geht halt anders damit um.
Aber er hat das geopolitisch in ähnlicher Weise vertreten, wie Trump dann auch. zu sagen.
Und in der meantime, die USA hat nicht nur als ein low-cost gas producer,
sondern als der größte weltbestriding oil producer wir haben.
Ladies und gentlemen, wir müssen mit dieser Realität. Amerika ist jetzt substantially
larger als Saudi-Arabia oder Russia in der global oil-field.
Sie sind nicht retreating.
Any European hypothesis über die Ende der Fossil fuels.
Ja,
mal sehen, der Preisdruck.
Dann habe ich einen kleinen Podcast gehört, den ich vorhin nicht kannte,
Klima-News-Podcast, die fassen immer so zusammen, was es in puncto Klima-Neues
gibt. Da ging es um China.
Da gab es ja vor zwei Wochen eine sehr gute Meldung für uns alle,
für die Welt, für die Menschheit. Hier hören wir sie.
China hat erstmals seine CO2-Emissionen gesenkt.
Laut einer Analyse des Klimaportals Carbon Reef von Mitte Mai sind die Emissionen
im ersten Quartal 2025 um 1,6 Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr gesunken.
Auch im Jahresvergleich zeigt sich eine leichte Abnahme, immerhin minus ein Prozent.
Diese Entwicklung ist bemerkenswert, denn sie geht nicht auf Sondereffekte wie
Wirtschaftskrisen oder Covid-Lockdowns zurück.
Chinas Wirtschaft läuft stabil, trotzdem sinken die Emissionen.
Der Grund? Der massive Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien zeigt Wirkung.
2024 produzierte China mehr erneuerbaren Strom als alle anderen Länder zusammen
und verdrängt damit zunehmend Kohle, Öl und Gas.
Und obwohl in China mehr Elektrizität verbraucht wurde als im Vorjahr,
entstand somit bei der Produktion weniger CO2.
Gleichzeitig werden in der Bauindustrie weniger Zement und Stahl benötigt.
Das verringert die Emissionen ebenfalls.
Das könnte bedeuten, dass China seine Emissionen schneller als angekündigt senkt.
Präsident Xi Jinping hatte vor fünf
Jahren versprochen, den Höhepunkt der Emissionen bis 2030 zu erreichen.
Ja, also ich glaube, auch wenn die Worte dafür noch fehlen und wir die Geschichte
noch nicht geschrieben haben, aber in zehn Jahren ist, würde ich sagen,
es geht gar nicht anders.
Der Hegemon ist, wer diese Klimatechnologien verkauft.
Weil dein Lehrer ist ja nun das Standardbeispiel. Das gilt im Kleinen, das gilt im Großen.
Weil dein Lehrer würde nicht anfangen, jetzt irgendeine Grube zu graben oder so ein Quatsch.
Also das Dach ist da und der weiß, da ist ein Handwerker, der würde mir eine
Solarpaneele drauf machen, fertig.
Und der Effekt ist natürlich, dass jeder Nachbar sich darüber informiert und
nachdenkt, ach ja, das könnte ich eigentlich auch machen.
Und dann ist die Frage, wo kaufe ich es? Und dann ist einfach völlig klar, wer dahin gewohnt ist.
Aus diesen Klimameldungen ergibt sich, dass China die Geschichte schreibt.
Und das muss man tatsächlich jetzt
auch als eine Kränkung des westlichen Subjekts, also kann man das sehen.
Also das heißt, wir sind nicht die, die darüber entscheiden,
ob das Weltklima im Ganzen sich verbessert. Wir haben auch unseren Anteil.
Also das soll ja jetzt nicht die Entschuldigungserzählung dafür werden,
dass man sagt, und deswegen brauchen wir gar nichts machen, die Chinesen sollen mal zusehen.
Aber bedeutet natürlich, dass egal wie sehr wir am Hebel jetzt ziehen,
wir nicht der entscheidende Faktor sein werden bei der Reduktion von CO2.
China schon.
Das ist die reale Geschichte. China surging in den letzten zwei Jahren zu über
60% der globalen Missions. Das ist Geschichte. Die Chinesischen es machen.
Das ist nicht eine Geschichte von den Chinesischen mit einem langen Strukturen die sie immer hatten.
Das ist die Chinesischen die schneller und mit viel greater energy than we have had done.
I mean, take that number up there. The Chinese have added in the last two years what is it?
Three times as much renewable energy capacity as Europe and the United States
together. Three times as much.
This is the scale of action that's necessary that has never been action in the
West on this kind of scale.
Am Ende ist es nicht nur das Produkt selbst, sondern auch die ganze Logistik und so weiter.
Und China zeigt es, dass es geht und ist damit mit der vertrauensfördernde Verkäufer für diesen Kram.
Bedeutet für uns?
If we don't buy Chinese Photovoltaics, we're choosing to heat the world.
If you want to prioritize rapid decarbonization, you buy the results of this.
One off, literally in the history of our species, this is what the Chinese are
doing. We know we need to do something radical, there it is.
Er geht dann auch noch durch, wo wir was tun können.
Also Stahl sind wir gar nicht so wichtig, weil wir so viele über grünen Stahl
reden. Zement scheint wohl ein großes Thema zu sein.
Da könnte man tatsächlich sehen, dass man da eine Vorreiterstellung bekommt. Das würde sehr helfen.
Ich finde ja, man sollte immer noch nicht aufgeben, dass wir damals dieses rot-grüne
Programm hatten unter Gerhard Schröder mit Trittin und so weiter.
Wenn wir das durchgezogen hätten
mit diesen Entwicklungen und die Autoindustrie dann sozusagen aus der,
externen, aber deutschen Anlässen gesehen hätte, an Energie mangelt es nicht.
Wir können das hier elektrifizieren. Hätten wir jetzt diese erneuerbaren Technologien
plus eine elektrifizierte Autoindustrie, also wirklich 15 Jahre bevor China
überhaupt noch auf die Idee kam, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Was wir eigentlich brauchen könnten, wäre wirklich ein Bauboom.
Dann würde man jetzt sagen, aber das produziert ja viel CO2, stimmt.
Aber jetzt könnte man dort mit vielen Erneuerungen dafür sorgen,
dass diese Häuser klimaneutral werden dann auf Zeit.
Ja, denn das ist ja auch das große Problem, dass wir so unglaublich viele alte
Häuser haben, die stehen erst ewig lange leer, dann werden sie zu Spekulationserbieten,
dann werden sie verkauft und dann kommt vielleicht noch irgendwann mal eine Anlage obendrauf.
Aber man könnte ja viel mehr auch jetzt den sozialen Wohnungsbau gleich klimaneutral anlegen damit.
Und da mal auch sich in Relation setzen zu China. Ich habe wirklich das nochmal
als Clip mitgebracht, weil ich einfach die Zahl so unglaublich finde über den Bauboom in China.
Also von 1995 sprechen wir jetzt bis heute.
Ist, geht in cement und steel, das ist urbanisierend half a billion Menschen in den 20 Jahren.
95% Imagine this as Germans. 95% of the apartments that Chinese currently live
in today, 95% were built since 1995.
Everyone in China, when you buy a house secondhand, it's called a used house
in China, like a used car.
Basically, no one lives in the current generation in a house anyone has lived in.
Dein großes Projekt, den Osten renaturalisieren und zugleich dann große Bauten
machen, die China gleich kommen, wo dann Menschen leben.
Das wäre ja wieder unser Migrationsthema, aber da haben wir auch schon alles zu gesagt.
Kommen wir zum Fazit, was die amerikanische Geostrategie anbelangt.
So to that extent, we're more back in the 1950s Sputnik moment,
where the Americans aren't the unipolar, boasting antagonists who know they
bestride the world. The Soviets got into space first.
The Soviets launched the satellite. The Americans are moving from behind.
And this time around, it's not in a Sputnik moment, massive investment in progressive technology.
It's this retreat to a kind of fortress, but they're seeing something quite
clearly that this universal agenda ultimately is not squarely reconcilable with
their narrowly understood strategic interest.
Das ist die große Frage. Will jetzt Europa auch mit in diese Festung rein?
Ich würde es nicht empfehlen.
Man wird sehen, wie sich da noch vielleicht in den Köpfen etwas ändert.
Ich kann es mir momentan wenig vorstellen.
Also Wadepuhl ist jetzt auch niemand, der auf Distanz eigentlich gehen würde zur US-Regierung.
Mal sehen, es kann natürlich passieren, dass Trump in seinem ganzen Agieren
dann irgendwann das für notwendig macht und dann muss man aufgeben,
aber das große Treffen Trump-März steht ja noch bevor.
Wir sind sehr gespannt. Ich hoffe, sie machen auch das alles wieder im Oval Office mit Kameras.
Ich möchte auch wirklich am Ende wieder Trump hören, der sagt Great Television,
da freue ich mich sehr drauf.
Ich will, dass Merz irgend so einen Brief mitbringt wie Kirstama und dann großer
Geste irgendwas macht. Ich will noch eine kurze Einschätzung zu diesem Vortrag geben.
Also jetzt haben wir alle Clips gehört und ich sage, ja, sehr gut, wieder Adam Tues,
denn es ist sehr wichtig, sich, und wir gehen ja gleich ins Katholische,
sich große Linien anzuschauen und ernst zu nehmen, auch wenn sie nicht immer
jede Approximationshoffnung haben.
Entgegenkommen. Also manchmal ist man auch ein bisschen ab von Schuss und ein
bisschen mehr in der Literatur und der Spiritualität als jetzt irgendwie und so.
Hier in diesem Falle denke ich, ja, sehr gut. Nur wenn,
Manche Sachen passieren einfach politisch, weil vielleicht dann links Flügelschläge
und dann Orkane und man kriegt das gar nicht zusammen.
Man versucht dann sozusagen retrospektiv eine Geschichte zu erzählen.
Und da wir jetzt ja mit Geoökonomie ein Buch in Erwartung haben,
das sich von Geopolitik unterscheidet, also eine große Erzählung gegen die nächste große Erzählung.
Manchmal sind es diese kleinen Phänomene, die man vielleicht auch gar nicht so beobachtet,
die erst recht nicht immer zwingend Puzzleteile sind für irgendwas Großes,
aber trotzdem gut, dass Adam tust nochmal aus der alten fossilen Hegemonie,
Souveränitätsgeschichte.
Denn mal gucken, wohin es führt, wenn wir die Welt wirklich mit einer anderen
Energieversorgung ausstatten. Und ich habe ja im Familienbuch auch getroht.
Neue Energieversorgung ist eine multipolare Welt. Das muss man erkennen.
Das sieht jetzt so aus, genau. Und es gäbe auch keinen Grund,
noch andere Erzählungen und vor allem politische Folgen daraus mitlaufen zu lassen, weil warum?
Man konnte halt die fossilen Rohstoffe so ausbeuten, extrem riesige Lieferketten,
immer den Präsidenten mit seiner Feldherrnschaft im Anschlag,
um das alles abzusichern. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr nötig.
Also es könnte auch zu einer schönen neuen Zukunft führen, in der jeder wie dein Lehrer.
Mobilität und Heimat… Und er sagt ja eigentlich den Leuten von der Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung,
hört auf zu glauben, dass das jetzt einfach so in einem transatlantischen Rahmen
eine tolle Partnerschaft wird, mit der wir den Klimawandel gemeinsam gegen China
bekämpfen. Das kann nicht sein.
Genau. Und was das eigentlich meint, diese Autarkie, die damit verbunden ist
und dass man sich auch dann damit zurechtfinden muss, dass man in einer multipolaren
Welt lebt und dass das natürlich auch militärisch nochmal sehr viel bedeutet.
Denn wir reden natürlich jetzt noch über die Supermächte mit ihren Atomwaffen
und das zeichnet sie ja auch dann noch als Supermächte aus.
Zugleich aber sehen wir, dass also jetzt kleine Player, also kleine Länder oder
nur einzelne rebellische Gruppen darin zu wichtigen Akteuren deshalb werden,
weil sie nicht mehr darauf helfen müssen,
auch mal irgendeine Waffenlieferung zu bekommen aus Deutschland,
irgendein Rheinmetallpanzer, sondern die sagen, wir haben hier ein bisschen
Geld, wir kaufen Drohnen und dann funktionieren wir die noch ein bisschen um
zu unseren Zwecken und das war es dann. Und damit haben wir alles.
Und das verschiebt natürlich alles ganz gewaltig. Und dieses neue Denken,
glaube ich, ist bei vielen noch nicht eingübt.
Insofern auch sehr gut, dass TuS das auch gerade bei der Böll-Stiftung in dieser Weise vorträgt.
Absolut.
Bist du zufrieden mit deinen Chefs der Hegemonie, deinem Kanzler,
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten oder würdest du lieber sagen,
nee, irgendwas stimmt da nicht?
Ich würde mich über ein alternatives Angebot freuen, sagen wir mal so.
Aber es ist ja Demokratie, das heißt, die kommen ja nicht von ungefähr oder
nirgendwo, sondern die sind ja aus Gründen da.
Wir hören mal, wie wir derzeit regiert werden. Zum einen Friedrich Merz.
Es gäbe jetzt unterschiedliche Einflugschneisen. Wir nehmen uns einfach mal
zwei. Zum Beispiel hier eine Begrüßung aus den Tagesthemen. Er ist im Gespräch.
Guten Abend, Herr Merz. Guten Abend, Frau Willmer. Herr Merz,
wir sprechen uns am Abend eines insgesamt sehr ereignisreichen Tages mit sehr hohem Tempo.
In welchem Gang waren Sie denn heute unterwegs?
Naja, jedenfalls in ziemlich hohem Tempo.
Denn wir wollen ja nun auch mit hohem Tempo dieses Land nach vorn bringen.
Und dazu haben wir heute auch im Koalitionsausschuss das erste Mal getagt.
Und ich habe gesagt, es geht jetzt Schlag auf Schlag.
So, hohes Tempo, Schlag auf Schlag.
Vielversprechend, ja.
Es ist wirklich vielversprechend. Wir wissen nicht so genau,
gibt es da noch einen Kompass oder ein Fundament oder irgendwas?
Oder ist das einfach nur noch Gelaber?
Anderes Beispiel, zeitgleich im Heute-Journal.
Und wir werden diese Zustände jetzt korrigieren, so wie die Ampel sie uns hinterlässt.
Also irgendeine Politik hat zu irgendeinem Thema, in dem Fall die Migration,
es wird jetzt was korrigiert.
Fragen wir uns mal, ob wir hier heraushören, welcher Maßstab dafür gilt,
also ob es so eine Orientierung dafür gibt, was da getan wird.
Das kann es nicht weitergehen. Wir korrigieren die Migrationspolitik der letzten zehn Jahre.
Und da können Sie gerne immer noch weitere Beispiele hier nennen.
Sie nennen Beispiele, die von der Minderheit der Bevölkerung so gesehen wird.
Die Mehrheit sieht es ganz anders.
Und wir vertreten hier die Meinung der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung und befinden
uns damit auch auf dem richtigen Weg, dieses Problem Stück für Stück zu lösen,
ohne dass wir damit unsere humanitären Verpflichtungen in irgendeiner Weise verletzen.
Das Problem, das nicht genau benannt ist, die Grundlage, die wir nicht erkennen
können, auf der man aber vorhat, etwas radikal zu verändern und zwar das aus
den letzten zehn Jahren.
Man fragt sich, naja, wenn es überhaupt gar kein Gerüst gibt,
keinen Maßstab oder sonst was, Kann ich ja auch gar nicht mehr diese Politik bewerten.
Also erstmal, dass ich diese Migrationspolitik grundsätzlich ablehne,
aber ich könnte ja noch nicht mal sagen, es ist besser geworden oder so,
weil ich ja gar keinen Messwert mehr habe, an dem ich es ausrichten könnte.
Ja, hohes Tempo, Schlag auf Schlag, alles wird besser, anders irgendwie und
im Sommer wirst du dann bald spüren als Bürger, dass sich hier was zum Besseren,
sagt er dann nochmal dazu, verändert.
Ja, einfach mal eine Stoppuhr laufen lassen.
Genau, was ja bedeutet, das Personal, das uns hier gerade durch den Alltag führt,
politisch, das Verantwortung übernimmt.
Wir wüssten nicht, was wir mit Ihnen reden sollten, würden Sie nachts bei uns
auftreten und sagen, ich komme noch auf einen Drink mit in die Bar.
Man säße Ihnen gegenüber und keine Ahnung, Herr Merz, was ist denn so Ihr Lieblingsthema,
worüber kann man denn mit Ihnen reden?
Und ja, keine Ahnung, man wäre so im haltlosen Raum.
Dasselbe betrifft ja auch Friedrich Merz. Wir haben es also hier,
das haben wir ja schon auch mit Andreas Püttmann und so besprochen,
mit konservativen, christlichen Leuten zu tun, die sich immer wieder darauf
beziehen, konservativ und christlich zu sein.
Und wir wissen nicht so genau, was das bei denen bedeutet.
Ja.
Und Scott Gellower hat einen Podcast mit sehr vielen Gästen,
da er ein hochkrediger Typ ist. Und da war David Brooks zu Gast.
Ah, der hat das Buch Bobos damals geschrieben. Der hat auch diesen Begriff,
soweit ich weiß, geprägt.
Also Bobos? sind Bohamiens und Bourgeoisie. Also das sind die,
erfolgreichen, urbanen Menschen, die eher so einen Bohem-Style haben,
aber zur Bourgeoisie gehören, weil sie für tolle Unternehmen arbeiten und ordentlich Geld verdienen.
Das kann sein.
90er Jahre war das.
Ja, das kommt gut hin. Dann war nämlich da noch ein jüngerer Mann.
Ich kenne ihn heute vor allem als New York Times Kolumnisten,
der immer mal wieder bei der PBS NewsHour,
freitags mit Jonathan Capehart, der so mehr die junge, progressive Richtung,
Gastautor der Washington Post und dann kommt so David Brooks, der so die,
das was vom Konservativen übrig ist, Linie auch nochmal mitkommentiert,
die machen dann sozusagen diese Maischberger-Fragerunde.
Ich finde ihn ganz toll, also an diesem Tisch schon immer ein toller Gesprächspartner
und hier in diesem Gespräch auch.
Scott Galloway fragt ihn natürlich, seine Standardfrage, was würdest du als
Vater und so weiter der nächsten Generation, so allgemein.
Darauf gibt er so eine 5-Minuten-Antwort, die wirklich herzerwärmend ist.
Die muss dann jeder selber hören.
Wir hören ihn mal zum Thema, was ist dieses Konservative heute?
Was ist übrig geblieben? Wir wissen eigentlich nichts.
Also wir finden nirgendwo irgendetwas. Jetzt versucht David Brooks,
als gestandener Journalist, der niemandem mehr gefallen muss,
sondern der jetzt einfach so auch seine Biografie beruflich abschließt,
mal Worte für dieses Desiderat zu finden, das wir ja auch aufgemacht haben,
denn es wäre schon schön,
wenn es sowas wie eine konservative Politik gäbe und nicht einfach nur noch
progressiv links wog und dann daneben einfach so AfD.
Und dann sagen alle nur noch, das müssen wir verhindern, also sind wir den Woken
ausgeliefert oder was auch immer. Also es muss ja mal so einen Weg geben.
Und ich gehe zurück zu einen Moment in meiner Formation, wo es jetzt in Retrospekt
sieht, wie es ein grüßes Faktor ist.
I came out of the University of Chicago and I read Burke and Adam Smith and these books.
And I worked in National Review, the Wall Street Journal editorial page,
the Weekly Standard. And we believed in promulgating conservative ideas.
At the same time I graduated from Chicago, there were a couple of people graduating
from Dartmouth who had worked at the Dartmouth Review.
And people may recognize Laura Ingraham, Dinesh D'Souza.
They were in this group. And I've come to see they were not pro-conservative. They were anti-left.
They were in elite institutions, but they hated the progressive lean of those
institutions. And so they were sort of the rebel bad boys.
The defining feature of the Dartmouth Review was in 1986, some progressive students
on Dartmouth's campus erected a shantytown to protest apartheid.
And in the middle of the night, the editors of the Dartmouth Review,
about a dozen of them, descended on the shantytown and took sledgehammers to them.
And it was an attempt to dismantle the left, really. Und für mich war es wie Gestapo-Taktik.
Ich war schockt und empfohlen, weil Apartheid wirklich wertvoll ist.
Aber ich habe diese Unterschiede gesehen, zwischen pro-konservativ,
was ich sagen würde, John McCain, Mitt Romney, George W.
Bush, und Anti-Left, was Lorne Ingram ist, was Pete Hexeth ist,
was Vivek Ramaswamy ist. Das ist für mich eine wichtige Unterschiede.
Demos waren niedergeschlagen, so Gestapo-artig, wie er sagt.
Die Konservativen kommen, die aber gar nicht mehr als eigenständige Denker sichtbar
sind, sondern nur noch sich auflehnen gegen das, was da ist.
Das sehen wir ja bis heute, das macht ja auch die Diskussion so schwer.
Ich erinnere an Ronsheimers Podcast und jeder Gesprächsversuch zum Thema,
was für Demos und Proteste finden denn an den Universitäten statt.
Gaza passiert, wir haben über Gaza gesprochen und es wird per se und pauschal abgelehnt.
So geht es nicht. So darf man nicht demonstrieren.
Da wird sich auch nicht auf irgendein humanistisches Argument oder so eingelassen,
sondern einfach nur, nee, ich bin Anti-Left, ich hau hier drauf.
Es gibt keine Binddifferenz. Und sowas passiert, wenn die Konservativen selber
kein Fundament mehr für Kritik haben an irgendetwas, sondern sich einfach nur
noch abgrenzen von, was sie ablehnen und das wird dann pauschal per se abgelehnt.
Nun ging damit also etwas verloren, das Christliche und das Konservative.
Wir haben es ja bei Püttmann jetzt wahrscheinlich so ähnliches Alter.
David Brooks eben auch, das Christliche und das Konservative.
Was ist eigentlich passiert?
Wir haben ja einen interessanten Fall noch mit Jens Spahn.
Wir haben schon mehrmals über ihn gesprochen, aber es gibt ja einen Punkt,
den stellt Thomas Biebrich ja heraus in seinem Buch über die geistig-moralische
Wende, über den Konservatismus in Deutschland, wie er ausgehöhlt ist,
wie ihm irgendwie am Ende nur noch die Schuldenbremse blieb.
Und jetzt ist sie auch noch verloren gegangen oder sie geht verloren.
Und da bringt er diese Anekdote.
Ein Journalist fragt, wie er Jens Spahn denn seinen katholischen Wählern erkläre,
dass sie ihn wählen sollen, obwohl er doch ein schwuler Mann ist und das doch
mit dem Katholizismus ein bisschen hakt, weil wir ja diese Haltung der Kirche und sowas kennen.
Und die Antwort, die sich Jens Spahn dafür zurecht legt, lautet einfach zu sagen,
naja, wenn es Homosexualität nicht gewollt wäre, dann hätte Gott die ja nicht geschaffen.
Und das ist seine Antwort darauf. Und dann sagt Biblicher,
dass es im höchsten Maße unredlich ist, eine solche Antwort darauf zu geben,
weil man ja sofort sagen kann, naja, aber es sind ja auch viele andere Dinge
auf der Welt geschaffen, die wir wirklich ablehnen, von denen wir nicht einfach
sagen, wenn Gott geschaffen hat, dann muss er wohl da sein.
Also man kriegt das ja christlich hingerechtfertigt, warum man Homosexuelle
nicht diskriminiert und warum auch der Vatikan da eine falsche Richtung verfolgt und all das.
Darüber kann man ja reden, man kriegt da auch eine konservative Position trotzdem
hin, ohne diskriminierend zu sein.
All das würde aber bedeuten, dass man sich…
Einmal über seine Werte, Fundamente klar wird, würde bedeuten,
dass man sich auch die Mühe macht noch zu einer Argumentation.
Und er bringt das so als ein typisches Beispiel für den Konservatismus heute,
dass er gar nichts mehr eigentlich zu sich zu sagen hat.
Gar nichts mehr weiß, kommt dann auf so eine Verlegenheitsantwort wie,
ja Gott hat es geschaffen, dann wird es wohl auch gewollt sein und Punkt.
Und das ist tatsächlich so dieses Armutszeugnis, das wir bei den meisten erleben.
Es gibt ja auch ein paar andere konservative Stimmen, aber bei Wolfram Weimar
war das ja auch interessant, da wo das ins Positive umschlagen soll,
also wo er uns beschreiben soll, was dann eigentlich der Konservatismus ist
in seinem Manifest. Da hat er ja fast nichts zu liefern.
Dann wird das diffus oder er sagt einfach, ich will weniger Steuern zahlen.
Also es gibt ja nur wenige Stimmen, die sich geschichtlich auskennen und die
aber auch selber sich noch in was verorten können.
Die große Frage, die wir jetzt gleich klären, gibt es in dieser unterschaubaren
Chaoswelt, in der Idioten regieren, um es mal so kurz wie möglich zu sagen,
ein Anlass wieder christlich und konservativ zu denken, aber eins,
das zentrale Erfolgsrezept dafür wäre, bitte kein Verweis auf Gott.
Denn ich als Atheist, der nun sehr aufgeschlossen bin für kluge Argumentationen,
sobald sie inhaltlich und funktional irgendwie zusammenpassen,
höre ich mir das an und folge dem vielleicht sogar, nur wenn jemand kommt mit, ja Gott,
also diese Verlegenheitsantwort von Jens Spahn dann wählt,
Dann ist einfach nur das Tor offen für jede Frage. Ja, aber Gott,
Theodizea, da ist man ja sofort überall.
Das heißt, wir leben jetzt nicht, denn du hattest jetzt, als wir den Teaser
aufgenommen hatten, schon angekündigt, der Papst wird Thema und du hast schon
die ganze Zeit durchleuchten lassen. Also der Papst fasziniert dich.
Ich hatte jetzt auf so eine kleine Spontanbekehrung hier gehofft.
Ja, die kommt auch.
Wenn du jetzt gleich sagst, doch, bald gehen wir nach Rom mit dir und dann wirst du dort getauft.
Also wir gehen sowieso mit mir nach Rom. Ob dann da eine Taufe stattfindet,
müssen wir sehen. Die Frage ist ja… Aber die bezieht ja.
Will ich nur sagen, den Gottesglauben mit ein. Also taufen nur so ist ein bisschen… Kann man.
Auch für mich, das Christliche und das Konservative schmackhaft machen,
ohne dass man die ganze Zeit Gott in den Weg stellt?
Mysterium und Zweifel und Glaube, ja, aber ich brauche jetzt keinen Gottesbezug.
Jedenfalls nicht so, wie sich die Christen sich vorstellen, mit so einem verkörpert,
aber nur über Bande der Christus, oder was auch immer.
Es ist sehr kompliziert.
Wir gehen das ja gleich durch. Ich bin ja Soziologe, ich kann ja andere Einflugschneisen finden.
Wir hören hier nochmal David Brooks, was bleibt, wenn das Christliche und das
Konservative verloren geht, so wie jetzt? Also wenn wir einfach Trump regieren sehen.
How did it get so mean? Yeah, resentment, a sense of siege mentality.
And then there's something animistic, deep in human nature.
And so when humans first evolved, we were in a war, a struggle of all against all.
Life was nasty, brutish, and
short. And then over the course of the centuries, we built civilization.
And that civilization consisted of constitutions to restrain power.
It consisted of international systems to try to promote peace.
But it also consisted of humanistic values, literature, and art and poetry to soften human nature.
It consisted of moral philosophies, either theological or secular,
to answer the question, what is life for?
And when I look at the Trump administration, I see a massive attempt to return
us to the life of dog-eat-dog, the life of nasty British and short,
the life where gangsters have maximum freedom to do what they want to do.
Und das ist die Evisceration von all den Wahlen der Civilizierung das Conservatism
ist supposed zu transmit und preserve.
Und ich denke, die Ruhe Lust für Power hat Donald Trump embodies hat nicht nur
Evisceratet Conservatism, es Evisceratet Christianity.
Christianity ist ein System designt around den meek, service zu den poor.
Jesus never embraced worldly power.
Donald Trump ist completely über worldly power. Es ist über domination.
Und so, es ist interessant für mich, zu sehen, ein Politiker,
die zwei Philosophies, die erhältlich sind, von conservatism und christianity,
und wie es die Ascidik-Power-Nihilismus ist.
Ich würde das hier so ein bisschen raffinierter bauen, das Argument.
Zum einen sagen, diese hopsche Welt, Wölfe unter Wölfen, jeder ist sich selbst
der Nächste, jeder denkt nur an sich und so weiter und so fort.
Wir wissen ja von David Brooks, so leben normale Menschen typischerweise nicht,
aber wir reden ja hier nicht über normale Menschen, sondern über diese psychopathischen
Parasiten, sag ich mal, nach Jordan Peterson oder wie Rutger Brechmann sagte,
es gibt so Leute, die ihre Karriere in der Politik machen und die sind so anders drauf. Ja, so.
Das heißt, Donald Trump orientiert sich selbst an einem Ideal,
das er für sich sieht, weil es ihm nützt.
Also dieser ganze Eigensinn, dieses egozentrische, narzisstische,
selbstverherrlichende und so weiter und so fort.
Das selbst eine Erzählung ist. Also er kommt gar nicht zum Kern seiner Menschheit
zurück, sondern er selbst ist einfach ein wirklicher Antipode.
Ja, also in der Hinsicht wirklich selber auch wieder ausgedacht.
Während es ein paralleles Angebot gab, und jetzt, wir haben ja bei Andreas Püttmann
schon gelernt, wie interessant es ist, zu unterscheiden zwischen christlich
und konservativ. Und so ist das ja hier auch.
David Brooks hat jetzt ein paar so Soft-Scale, Soft-Power-artige Sachen genannt.
Das eine kommt durch die Aufklärung, das ist dann das Konservative,
und das andere ist dieses Christliche.
Eigentlich steht sich das ja gegenseitig im Weg. Wir sagen ja immer,
die Aufklärung hat das Christliche so ein bisschen in Schatten gestellt.
Aber er sagt jetzt, nee, aus Sicht von heute, dass wir einfach einen hopschen
Wolf Donald Trump im Amt haben, sehen wir erst, wie fruchtbar es eigentlich
war, das Christliche und das Konservative zu haben.
Also jemand lebt nach christlichen Gesichtspunkten und akzeptiert aber auch
die aufklärerischen Sachen,
die hin zur weltlichen Bildung und so weiter und dann dem fleißigen Weg,
nicht nur der, wie auch immer, christlichen Arbeit,
sondern dann wirklich mal eine Hierarchie und ein Manager werden und dann aber
da wieder christliche Werde wiedererkennen und so weiter und so fort.
Also dass es da eine Differenz gibt.
Und wir sehen ja auch historisch jetzt aus der Aufklärung,
Geht natürlich auch all das hervor, Unternehmertum, große Individuation,
bedeutet aber ja nicht, dass die Aufklärung so ein Cut ist,
der sich einfach eingestellt hat und damit ist das Christentum ad acta gelegt,
sondern man kann vielmehr auch sagen, dass natürlich aus dem Christentum die
Aufklärung hervorgegangen ist.
Natürlich im Widerstreit auch dazu und mit atheistischen Thesen,
mit Debatten darüber, mit Auseinandersetzungen bei Kant, mit der Frage,
kann man Gott beweisen oder nicht.
Der in der Kritik der reinen Vernunft das durchspielt in allen Variationen.
Bedeutet aber, dass quasi das christliche Fundament nichts war,
dass man einfach so wegwischt und sagt, jetzt kommt das Neue,
sondern es kommt aus der Tradition heraus.
Und man kann dann sagen, dann hat die katholische Kirche wiederum als Institution
sehr verspätend diese Aufklärung zugelassen und hat in dieser ewigen Verspätungspolitik,
die ja bei den Katholiken so typisch ist,
also dass man immer so ein paar Jahrzehnte zu spät irgendjemandem doch wieder
die Leerlaubnis gibt oder sagt, da sind wir übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
So bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man eine große Resilienz als eigene Institution
sich selbst schafft dadurch, durch dieses zähe Agieren.
Aber im Ganzen gesehen ist natürlich da Aufklärung und Christentum schon auch zusammenzudenken.
Nicht nur, aber auch zumindest in einem intelligenten Spannungsverhältnis im besten Falle,
weshalb das ja auch so logisch war in gewisser Weise, dass der Philosoph der
Aufklärung in Deutschland, der sagt, wir müssen ins Gespräch miteinander kommen,
argumentativ die Beziehung.
Gesellschaft verbessern, diese Argumente führen dann zu einer besseren Politik.
Also Jürgen Habermas, du bist ja kein Fan dieses deliberativen Ansatzes und
ich ja eigentlich auch nicht,
aber es ist eigentlich nur logisch, dass also bei Habermas dann doch beim späten
Habermas eine Idee da ist, dass man wieder irgendeine Grundlage,
irgendeinen Bezug braucht, vielleicht doch für all das, dass es nicht alleine die Vernunft ist.
Weshalb er ja dann in diese Auseinandersetzung tritt mit Ratzinger, Ja.
Der also auch bereit ist, sich dann Habermaschen Argumenten zu öffnen und sich
die Frage stellt, ja, aber was bringt denn jetzt eigentlich da die Religion?
Und dann ist ja eigentlich auch Papst Benedikt einer, der immer wieder versucht,
eigentlich Glaube und Vernunft zusammenzubringen, also so eine Aussöhnung zu
schaffen, um nicht die zu starke Opposition zu sehen zwischen Aufklärung und
Christentum, sondern eher wieder die Verbindung.
Ja, also ich sehe da auch ein Spannungsverhältnis, aber eben produktiv.
Die Aufklärung ist natürlich aus diesen kirchlichen Arbeiten,
vor allem Klöster, die sich wissenschaftliche Gedanken stellen,
die mit Text Archive begründen und so weiter erwachsen.
Das ist ja soweit auch geschriebene Geschichte, kann man ja auch in Ko-Evolution
überall, sei es in Florenz, sei es irgendwo in den Niederlanden,
sei es in Spanien nachlesen.
Rom natürlich auch, mit allen Verwirrungen, die es da so gibt,
nur umgedreht eben auch.
Das Christliche hat vielleicht überhaupt erst durch die Aufklärung einen modernen
Platz zugewiesen bekommen.
Klar nicht mehr die Allmacht der vorneuzeitlichen Ordnung, die es ein paar Jahrhundert
gab, aber die Ausdifferenzierung der Religion hat ja eher auch Funktion zugewiesen.
So wie ich ja auch sagen würde, wenn man jetzt wirklich ganz differenziert vorgeht,
ich habe ja gar nichts gegen den deliberativen Ansatz.
Ich sage halt nur in Familien, Freundesgruppen und arbeiten bis sieben Personen.
Nur als Gesellschaftstheorie. Für die ganze Bundesrepublik.
Genau. So. Und wenn man das jetzt strukturiert, dann ist ja völlig klar,
für Menschen, die sich so wie ich, als auf dem Wege der Aufklärung aus dem Osten
kommend, nicht nur Atheist, sondern geradezu heidnisch unterwegs.
Für die gibt es natürlich auch Zweifel, Mysterium, Glauben in ihrem Leben.
Das wird ja nicht aussortiert.
Die Frage ist jetzt, kriegt man auf einem modernen Wege,
alte kirchliche Prinzipien rein, ohne immer ein Gottesglauben abzuverlangen.
Also an der Türschwelle abzufragen, ja glaubst du denn auch an Gott?
Oder reicht es einfach mit einer Fragestellung in die Kirche zu gehen,
wissend, dass man die woanders so nicht stellen kann und sie trotzdem prägt.
Können Sie sich schon mal mitdenken, wo stellen wir denn heute so unsere Fragen,
die wir so im Alltagszweifel haben?
Also nicht rein positivistisch auf die Welt blicken, wenn wir jetzt daran denken,
Ja, dass Ratzinger als Papst dann zu Gast ist, im Bundestag zu sprechen und
dort sich nochmal auf Hans Kelsen, Rechtspositivismus und all das bezieht, um dann zu sagen,
das sei schon wichtig, dass man eine Grundlage hat und dass man bei ihm dann
so eine naturrechtliche Grundlage hat. Das ist auch eine Riesendebatte mit Naturrecht oder so.
Aber das ist ja etwas, wo er deutlich macht.
Also das ist jetzt auch das, was er mitbringt in den Bundestag,
dass also die Debatten, die Folgen und die Politiken, die entstehen,
wieder eine andere Grundlage brauchen als einfach nur so eine rechtspositivistische Grundlage.
Und er bringt ja da als positives Beispiel, und das ist ja ganz lustig,
weil die Grünen ja damals nicht sehr begeistert waren, oder Teile zumindest,
waren nicht begeistert davon, dass der Papst dort spricht im Bundestag,
dass er sagt, aber gerade die Nachhaltigkeitsbewegung, die ökologische Bewegung
hat ja den Schöpfungshorizont schon mit drin.
Also da gibt es dann plötzlich eine andere Ebene noch, außer die jetzt,
dass wir jetzt nur gucken, wie viel 1,5 Grad und CO2 und was weiß ich,
ist jetzt gerade vonnöten.
Ja, Ratzinger kam natürlich als Benedikt nach Berlin, aber er bleibt ja trotzdem
ein menschlicher Vertreter der Kirche.
Ja, ja klar.
Es ist ja nicht, dass man jetzt grün-links da plötzlich, ah ja,
jetzt reden wir nur noch mit irgendeinem Himmelsgesandten oder so.
Nein, nein, das ist ja auch so nicht vorgesehen.
Genau, und genauso kann er es ja auch einfordern.
Auch die Unfehlbarkeit im Übrigen gilt ja nicht in allen Belangen,
wann immer der Papst irgendwo spricht.
Also das ist jetzt nicht, wenn der jetzt in einem Interview einen Fehler macht,
irgendwas vertauscht, dann kann man nicht sagen, ist aber unfehlbar, ist ja der Papst.
Das sind diese vulgären Ansichten.
Die dann gerne der amerikanische Präsident für sich reklamiert,
wenn er sich im Papst Kostüm zeigt.
Aber noch sind wir hier am Anfang, die Unfehlbarkeit wird uns auch gleich nochmal begegnen.
Wenn die Fundamente fehlen, dann, David Brooks bringt es hier ganz schön auf
die Worte, die uns sozusagen dann Anlass geben, jetzt wieder Fundamente zu bauen.
Ich denke, dass die Leute in den Tension zwischen den beiden Dingen leben.
Und ich denke, was wir sehen, ist die collapse von all rivalen Systems.
Eine meiner Lieblings-Fähigkeiten von Psychologie ist von einem Mann.
John Bowlby, der hat sich an den Attachment-Researchen.
Er sagt, all of life ist eine seriese von daringen Explorations von einem Secure-Base.
Wir brauchen das Secure-Base. Und das Secure-Base, das ist über deine Eltern,
die deine Eltern, die haben, die sich an der Attachment.
Aber es ist auch über eine Secure-Homentown, eine Safe-Neinbarung.
Aber es ist auch über eine Moral-Order. The sense that you live within a coherent
moral order and you can make the decisions of your life based on this.
There was a historian named George Marsden who wrote once that what gave Martin
Luther King's rhetoric such power was his sense that there was a moral order
woven into the fabric of universe.
That segregation was not just wrong sometimes. Segregation was always wrong.
Slavery is always wrong under all circumstances.
And so that gives you a sense of security if you have a sense that,
yes, that right and wrong are permanent.
And we took that away. We privatized morality. We told people,
it's up to you to come up with your own values.
And if your name is Aristotle or Nietzsche, maybe you can do this.
Most of us can't come up with our own values.
And we're left in sort of a formless world that gives no security.
Way back in 1955, a great columnist named Walter Lippmann wrote a book in which
he wrote that if what is right and wrong is just what each individual invents
based on his or her feelings, we have left the bounds of civilization.
Und ich denke, wir haben diese geblieben. Es ist eine Loss der sozialen Sicherheit.
Freunde und Familie sind verweakten. Die Gemeinschaftsbasis ist verweakten.
Und die Moral-Base ist verweakten.
So, also die Kunden am Ende gehen verloren.
Und der Universalismus damit auch, den er jetzt mit Martin Luther King in Verbindung bringt.
Martin Luther King, genau, Junior, also der amerikanische.
Man kann sich diese moralischen Koordinaten, die man braucht für wichtige Lebensentscheidungen,
nicht selbst aus dem Gefühl ableiten, sondern man braucht irgendwie so einen externen Kompass.
Typischerweise, sagt er ja auch, verknüpft mit Herkunft.
Wir haben so eine Familie und einen Heimatort, eine Nachbarschaft und so weiter,
was, ich will es nur hervorheben, insbesondere soziale Kontexte sind.
Niemand würde jetzt sagen, ja, Mark Zuckerberg hat ein gutes Versprechen gehabt,
jeder findet online sein eigenes Milieu und daraus ziehe ich jetzt meine Moral.
Sondern nein, es muss schon sozial vor Ort, gegenwärtig, gesellig,
gemeinschaftlich entwickelt werden.
Und jetzt haben wir ja, um auf Donald Trump reagieren zu wollen und für uns
alle wieder ein Fundament zu finden, bei dem wir einfach sagen,
nee, wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur, weil wir so ein Gefühl haben und Friedrich Merz dann sagt,
ja, das Gefühl meiner Wähler schlägt sich nieder im Wählerwille und was da als
Mehrheit kommt, ist bei mir Gesetz und dann mache ich Migrationspolitik.
Also die größte Schicksalsfrage Deutschlands wird so runtergebrochen auf,
ja die Menschen werden schon so gefühlig dann wählen gehen und ich zähle dann
einfach aus und 51% ist es dann so. Das geht ja nicht.
Also wir sehen ja, das ist eines der größten Sachen, die wir uns vergegenwärtigen müssen.
Das, was jetzt gerade politisch stattfindet, ist in der Leistungsfähigkeit so
gering, dass man es nicht auf Dauer stellen kann.
Also so läuft einfach der Countdown für China und so weiter.
Dann war es das einfach mit dieser westlichen und ich nehme jetzt mal nur diese
kulturelle Hegemonie, dass man hier so selbstständig Freiheit und so weiter durchbockt.
Wir brauchen also Grundsätze und wie wäre es denn, wenn wir die nehmen,
die wir schon haben und hatten.
Und allein deswegen, weil sie so lange Bestand haben und wenn wir sie jetzt durchgehen,
die aus sich heraus funktionieren, die also gar keinen großen Appellativen,
aber Gott wollte oder sowas, sondern nein, Menschen haben die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass das gute Maßstäbe sind.
Und ich war wirklich begeistert und soziologisch auch wahnsinnig daran interessiert,
wie sehr man das an diesen Ordensregeln der unterschiedlichen katholischen Orden
einfach durchgehen kann.
Also 6. Jahrhundert, Benedikt von Nursia gründet die Benediktiner.
Ora et labora, bete und arbeite. Wir haben es also hier mit Beständigkeit,
Berechenbarkeit, Beziehungsorientierung zu tun.
Also Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen. Ganz große politische Kategorien, wenn es was werden soll.
Demut und Achtsamkeit. Auch mit sich selbst, ganz profan, statt nur spirituell.
Also kümmere dich um dich. Räum dein Zimmer auf. So ein bisschen ja vulgär, runtergebrochen.
Und vor allem ein Respekt vor Autorität, aber nicht nur, sondern auch Tradition. So.
Institutionen führen zu Stabilität. Stabilität führt zu Institutionen.
So ungefähr. Also wir haben es hier überall so mit so zirkulären Logiken zu tun.
Die Benediktiner wissen ganz genau, wie sie Trump kritisieren sollten.
Da käme keiner und sagte, ja, der ist irgendwie doof oder so.
Oder würde das so wie wir halt so vulgär ein bisschen runterbrechen.
Ich habe den bei TikTok gesehen und dachte mir, das ist es nicht.
Sondern, nee, die würden dann schon so mit Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen argumentieren.
Mit so einer gewissen Respektlosigkeit vor Autoritäten und Traditionen.
Da wird einfach alles kurz und klein geschlagen, was einem so im Weg steht.
So, die Dominikaner genauso. Die sagen Studium und Predigt.
13. Jahrhundert, also nicht ganz so alt, aber auch schon tausend Jahre,
sagen wir mal so grob gerundet mit allen Vorläufern, die das so hat.
Da geht es vor allem um Veritas, Wahrheit, das Studium, das dahin führt,
fundiert und faktenbasiert.
Also hier schon der anfängliche Schulterschluss, nachdem dann zeitgleich auch
die großen Städtegründungen losgehen in Europa und so, da ist dann völlig klar,
da gibt es eine Kirche, aber da gibt es auch eine Universität.
Das bedingt sich dann einander.
Großen Wert auf Reichtum legen, aber nur geistig. Und das hart unterscheiden.
Rhetorik unterscheiden.
Statt einfach nur affektive Argumentation. Dialog statt Dämonisierung.
Also anders als die Benediktiner wüssten die Dominikaner auch ganz genau,
wie sie Trump kritisieren sollten.
Die wissen genau, was ihnen wichtig ist und die würden genau darauf Wert legen.
Alter, du kannst hier nicht rumlügen.
Deine goldene Schmuck da, das ist total Banane.
Ja, und bitte mach doch mal einen rhetorischen Punkt, statt einfach hier nur
affektiv rumzudämonisieren.
Die Franziskaner.
Radikale Armut, lebe in der Nachfolge Christis, daraus dann die Nächstenliebe.
Das fand ich super interessant, man geht nämlich typischerweise bei den ganzen
christlichen Gedankengut so durch und sagt, ja, ja, irgendwas mit Fürsorge,
irgendwas mit Nächstenliebe, wie auch immer, aber nein, man kann es genau zuordnen.
Also die Franziskaner sind die hauptsächlich mit dieser Nächstenliebe.
Franz von Assisi, auch frühes 13. Jahrhundert, kein Besitz, erst recht keine
Anhäufung von Besitz und dadurch auch keine Arroganz und keine Selbstverherrlichung.
Also da liegt die Trump-Kritik sozusagen auf der Hand.
Was wir dann bei Papst Franziskus immer sehr deutlich gesehen haben,
dass er nicht mit einem teuren Dienstwagen sich vorfahren lässt,
dass er es bescheiden liebt, soweit das in diesem Rahmen dann noch möglich ist.
Natürlich hat das auch enorm viel Geld gekostet, wenn der dann sagte,
ich will jetzt aber gar nicht in den Palast ziehen, sondern lebe jetzt dort
weiter. Das ist natürlich für die Sicherheitskräfte das größte Desaster überhaupt.
Und alles Feierliche auch nur
im Dunstkreis des Altars, also mit Weiß getragen und auch die Schuhe so.
Genau, also es ist nicht unbedeutend, dass die letzten Papste,
Benedikt, Franziskas und August, zumindest Augustiner ist jetzt,
dass wir da einfach hier wirklich diese großen Linien drin haben.
Also die Franziskaner Brüderlichkeit und Empathie, insbesondere Armen und Ausgegrenzten
gegenüber. Bewahrung der Schöpfung.
Franz von Assisi auch Schutzpatronen der Umwelt. Frieden und Versöhnung miteinander
mit der Umwelt, wie auch immer.
Also die wüssten auch, wie sie Trump kritisieren. Die haben da gute Kataloge
an Argumentationen um sich auch davon, so wie wir, ah ja, ich habe ihn bei Jimmy
Kimmel gesehen und fand es albern. So und jetzt die Augustiner.
Also der aktuelle Papst bekannte sich als Augustiner.
Gleich in seinem ersten, okay, er grüßte kurz die Welt, war für Frieden,
begrüßte dann seine Gemeinde in Peru und sagte sofort, ich bin,
ich stehe in der Tradition der Augustiner.
Augustiner finde ich schon besonders, weil besonders alt, also Augustinus hat
im vierten Jahrhundert gelebt, der Orden wurde aber erst tausend Jahre später
gegründet, also wir haben es
mit einem Orden zu tun, der sozusagen einen entsprechenden Vorlauf hatte.
Ja, der natürlich als Kirchenvater und der Philosoph die Kirchengeschichte prägt,
also 430 gestorben und für ihn ist ja dann auch jemand mit einer Bekehrungsgeschichte,
jemand der dann auch erst das Individuum sehr in den Mittelpunkt stellt und
auch den Willen des Individuums und dann ja etwas später sagt,
naja, aber das alles ist auch noch mal etwas Größerem unterworfen,
nämlich der Gnade Gottes.
Das heißt also, der individuelle Wille ist das eine und den will er jetzt auch
nicht gering sprechen, es gibt auch einen freien Willen, aber es gibt auch eine
Gnade, die von Gott kommt und die man sich quasi jetzt nicht einfach mal so erarbeiten kann.
Was natürlich eine unglaubliche Einschränkung wiederum des freien Subjekts ist.
Und das ist ja eine sehr wenig moderne Haltung.
Oder wenn wir jetzt an unsere Selbstermächtigung denken, dann sagen wir.
Naja, aber ich lasse mich ja jetzt nicht von der Gnade Gottes einhegen oder so.
Also ich erlebe natürlich als Mensch Schicksalsschläge, die ich nicht in der Hand habe.
Ich kann mich gesund ernähren und trotzdem schlimm krank werden oder so.
Man kann es ein bisschen beeinflussen mit gesunder Ernährung und Sport,
aber ja, jederzeit kann da was kommen und das ist natürlich eine unglaubliche
Kränkung des eigenen Willens und Fortkommens.
Und daran liegt natürlich dann schon ein so starker Gottesbezug,
dass wenn man den nicht hat, deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie du da uns jetzt hinführst,
also wie das gehen soll, dass man sagt, ich will so eine Einbettung in eine
Ordnung, eine Werteordnung und mit Regel basiert und sowas haben,
aber ich will eigentlich den Gottesbezug weglassen.
Weil bei Augustinus ist es ja so, ich bin ja jetzt kein Experte,
aber wenn ich das, was ich weiß, richtig verstanden habe, dann ist es ja bei
Augustinus so, dass er sagt, naja, also…,
Ende ist Gottes Gnade das Entscheidende.
Ja, und wir haben ja da auch schon Publikationswesen, relativ früh,
aber für das Jahrhundert, Rom ist immerhin schon untergegangen,
es war ja großer Anlass für den Gottesstaat,
also dieses Buch, das ja bis heute Wellen schlägt, auch da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf.
Liebe und Gemeinschaft, ein Herz und eine Seele, kommt also aus dieser Richtung,
aber zuerst die Liebe zu Gott, dann zum Nächsten,
dann zu sich selbst, Aber diese Liebe zu Gott mal eingeklammert,
die Liebe zum Nächsten, die Liebe zu sich selbst ist schon Grund für das gemeinschaftliche Leben.
Also der zentrale Anker dafür ist Liebe statt Polarisierung und Misstrauen.
Man hat eine Einheit des Herzens, eine innere Wahrheit, die dann später sozusagen
außerweltlich erklärt wurde.
Keine Widersprüche im Handeln bitte. Also dieses große Einheitsversprechen kann
man natürlich gut einlösen, wenn man sich immer auf Gott bezieht,
weil Gottes Wille, egal wie er sich verwirklicht, führt zu einer großen Einheitlichkeit.
Aber auch hier keine Eitelkeiten, weil sie ablenken von der wahren Suche nach
Gott und auch der Gemeinschaft, in der man selbstlos, nicht ganz selbstlos,
aber erst im dritten Schritt sich selbstliebend lebt, da findet.
Also ich finde, schon allein diese Liste so durchzugehen, zeigt uns dieses moderne
Publikationswesen, dass wir so Bücher haben,
die irgendwas vom effektiven Altruismus oder vom Atomic Habits oder irgendwas
oder selbst hier jeden Tag ein Schritt von Hoss und Hopp,
die laufen alle in dieser Denktraditionen.
Klar, bei Horst und Hopf schlägt es halt sehr in dieses Individuum über,
aber auch da wird ja nicht aus sich heraus und selbst heraus und nur nach vorn.
Sondern… Aber Horst oder Hopf ist doch auch religiös. Ich glaube,
das ist nicht so genau markiert, in welcher Weise religiös, aber Gott spielt schon eine Rolle.
Wenn man sich dafür interessiert könnte, über den wir nachgehen,
wäre jetzt nicht mein Forschungsinteresse, aber ja, müsste man sich mal auf
der Bühne, was sie jetzt vor allem… Also auf der Bühne wird es ja sehr missionarisch
wohl. Wir werden es ja hören.
Du gehst da hin, ne?
Ich gehe da natürlich nicht hin, aber wir wissen, wer dahin geht.
So, wir haben es also hier mit einem großen Koordinatensystem zu tun aus Stabilität,
Benediktiner, Wahrheit, Dominikaner, Gerechtigkeit, Franziskaner,
Gemeinschaft, Augustiner, grob.
Was ja bedeutet, damit käme man ganz schön weit und vor allem kann man unsere
aktuellen Politiker ganz schön hart damit kritisieren.
Und zwar, das kann man ja dann in der KI geben, wie man will,
bitte schreibt mir in Deep Research, wie diese und jene Äußerung eines Politikers
wieder nicht passt mit den alten Ordensregeln.
Und dann muss er nur gucken, welche Ordensregel hier besonders verletzt wurde.
Und dann geht man nochmal nach, warum die diese Ordensregel so wichtig aufgestellt
haben und wie sie sich bewährt hat über Jahrhunderte, was ja wirklich viele Generationen sind.
So, und jetzt aber dieser eine Stolperstein, der mich eben auch immer ein bisschen
fernhält. Wir hören den neuen Papst bei seiner Amtseinführung.
In this our time, we still see
too much discord, too many wounds caused by hatred, violence, prejudice,
the fear of difference, and an economic paradigm that exploits the Earth's resources
and marginalizes the poorest.
Für unsere Partie, wir wollen ein kleines Leven von Unität, Kommunikation und
Fraternität in der Welt.
So, ich will es mal klar markieren. Bis hierhin waren das Argumentationen zum
Thema Gemeinschaft, Gesellschaft, Zusammenleben.
Muss man sich jetzt so dem Kapitalismus unterwerfen, wie wir das bisher getan
haben? Müssen die Kriege die Bedeutung haben, die sie bisher hatten?
Aber er ist ja der Papst, deswegen geht dieses Gespräch ja...
Und hier würde jetzt die Trump-Regierung sagen, wir weisen das zurück, was dort gesagt hat.
Genau, die würden jetzt erstmal sagen, wir weisen das zurück,
wenn sie sich mutig wären, das so zu explizieren, aber sie müssten es gar nicht
erklären, weil wir als Beobachter einfach sehen.
Also nach diesen Maßstäben, die der Papst gerade aufgestellt hat und die geronnene
Erkenntnis aus Jahrtausenden des klösterlichen, dörflichen, wie auch immer, Zusammenlebens sind.
Aber es ist eben, wie gesagt, der katholische Papst.
We want to say to the world with humility and joy, look to Christ,
come closer to him, welcome his word that enlightens and consoles,
listen to his offer of love and become his one family.
In the one Christ, we are one.
So, und jetzt kommt plötzlich dieser Bezug auf Christ, Jesus Christus.
Ich finde, man braucht ihn nicht so zwingend. Ich verstehe natürlich, warum sie ihn machen.
Und ich suche jetzt einen Ausweg.
Bin sehr angespannt.
Wir hören jetzt, wie die Neuen, und wir fangen das nachher wieder christlich ein.
Wir machen jetzt einen wirklich kleinen, ich sag mal, spirituellen Exkurs mit
moderner Technologie, also KI und so, bevor wir es danach wieder christlich einfangen.
Aber KI ist jetzt nicht der neue Gott.
Das ist ja der Punkt. Ich will ja kein Gott, weder neu noch alt noch sonst irgendwas.
Ich brauche keine Verlegenheitsentität, an der ich mich orientiere,
nur weil ich weltliche Herrschaft nach allen Ordensregeln ablehne.
Also weltliche Herrschaft in dem Sinne, wie wir es jetzt sehen,
sondern über die strengen schlagenden, autokrativen, besitzergreifenden,
gierigen, lügenden, ja,
den kann ich einfach raus, ich möchte den rausstreichen, ohne etwas aus Verlegenheit
an diese Stelle setzen zu müssen,
wie der Papst dann sagt, dann versammeln wir uns doch einfach um ihn.
Nun sind ja sehr viele Leute bei der Suche nach Antworten auf die Fragen,
die ja durch Ordensregeln schon beantwortet wurden, die nutzen gerade KI.
Die klären ihre Beziehungssachen, ihre Familie, soll ich mein Kind so und so
erziehen, wann ist eigentlich die richtige Schlafenszeit, was soll ich essen?
Und ja, das sind ja alles so Fragen, also da, wo Zweifel, Mysterium,
Glaube eine Rolle spielt, da hat man ja heute Ansprechpartner,
wo man früher einfach zu dem Götzen in den Wald gegangen ist und hoffte,
dass es doch Gott ist, der zu einem spricht.
Man weiß aber nicht so ganz genau, man hat nur gesehen, ich deute das mal als
Mitteilung, dass die Taube, wie auch immer, oder der Vogelflug in diese Richtung,
aber die inhaltliche Komponente muss ich mir selber herbei manifestieren.
Und jetzt bekommt man die geliefert von Chachipetee.
Genau, die KIs antworten ja.
Und das ist ja auch jetzt gerade in den letzten Tagen rund gegangen,
dass sehr viele dazu übergegangen sind, junge Menschen vor allem Fotos von sich
hochzuladen und die KI zu fragen, bin ich eigentlich schön?
Was dann bedeutet, dass natürlich die KI das abgleicht mit den Bildern,
die im Internet virulent sind. und man kann natürlich dann sich denken,
wie sehr das an Normen ausgerichtet ist, die erst einmal im Internet besonders entstanden sind.
Das behalten wir mal im Hinterkopf, weil du jetzt sagst, da sind ja Normen drin
durch das Trainingsmaterial und so.
An die sind dann ein Maßstab und dann kommt unser Input und dann wird an diesem Maßstab gemessen.
Das ist eine Erklärung. Es gibt noch eine zweite, wie eine KI antworten kann.
Weil die Maßstäbe müssen ja nicht unbedingt aus den Trainingsdaten kommen.
Es gibt ja vielleicht auch andere Zuflussquellen.
Du kannst jetzt noch rätseln, aber wir hören vorher zwei andere Clips.
Zum einen der DeepMind CEO, also Demis Hazabis, der Gemini, technisch verantwortet.
Also wir sind jetzt hier sozusagen ganz hoch angesiedelt bei der gerade am klügsten
eingeschätzten KI der Welt.
Wir sind sozusagen ganz nah dran. Es ist der Big Technology Podcast.
Ich glaube, sie reden auf einer Bühne. Es könnte ein bisschen unverständlich
sein, aber hören wir mal den DeepMind CEO über das nächste große Ding der KI.
Und ich habe ja jetzt schon darauf Wert gelegt, bei der Kirche,
ja, ja, man kann immer auf den Gott abstellen, aber nicht nur soziologisch,
sondern einfach alltagsinteressiert oder Mensch, kann man einfach sagen.
Aber es ist ja auch geronnene Geschichte der Vergemeinschaftung.
Vielleicht kommt die Logik der Ordensregeln einfach aus der Erfahrung des gemeinschaftlichen
Lebens selbst und braucht gar nicht so viel Gott.
Also diese soziale Komponente, die ist mir hier wichtig. Und jetzt hören wir den DeepMind-Chef.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob Sergej agree würde, Aber ich fühle mich die Universal
Assistant ist der killer App für Smart Glasses. Und ich denke,
das ist das, was es funktioniert.
Apart von dem, dass die hardware-technologie auch noch weitergezogen hat und verbessert wird.
Ich fühle mich das ist, das ist die aktuelle killer App, die natürliche killer App für es.
Die natürliche Killer-App für KI, und mit Killer-App ist immer die gemeint,
die den großen Durchbruch bringt, ist der Personal Assistant.
Wir wissen jetzt, das Telefon wurde auch immer so verherrlicht,
zu sagen, dann können endlich die wichtigen Leute aus Amerika und England miteinander telefonieren.
Und was haben wir bekommen? 99% Geplauder.
Ja.
Es ist also nicht der Personal Assistant, sondern es ist der Kompagnon,
der Freund, der Wegbegleiter, Lebenspartner, wie auch immer.
Wir hören also jetzt hier Mark Zuckerberg. Der kriegt ja seine KI gerade nicht so richtig.
Also er hat sie auf die Straße gekriegt, aber so richtig die Intelligenz,
da mangelt es wohl gerade wieder ein bisschen und er beschreibt hier mal dasselbe
wie der DeepMind CEO, aber halt finde ich so ein bisschen auf die ehrlicheren
Grundbegriffe runtergebrochen.
Und wir hören es hier aus dem Intelligent Machine Podcast, das ist eine Ansprache von Mark Sagerberg.
Wir hören die, wie die das selber hören. Ich wollte jetzt den Clip nicht nochmal
im Original aussuchen, aber man hört schon, wie die das auch so ein bisschen lustig finden.
We built a new thing for you. There's almost a billion people who are using
Meta AI across our apps now, so we made a new standalone Meta AI app for you to check out.
Meta AI is designed to be your personal AI.
That means, first, it's designed around voice conversations.
You open up the app, and you can talk to it about whatever you want,
from the news to an issue you're dealing with to just anything that you want to learn about.
Also er bricht das schon mal so ein bisschen runter. Es ist dein Gesprächspartner.
Und zwar für alle Fragen, die dir so kommen.
Wie ist im Psalm 23, der Herr ist mein Hirte, die KI ist mein Hirte.
So ungefähr, ja. Also wir sind da angesiedelt jetzt.
Und zwar rein funktional im äquivalenten Studium sozusagen im Vergleich.
So, jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, die KI, und das ist ja auch so eine Sichtweise,
gibt einem ja immer wieder raus, was vorher reingegeben wurde.
Deswegen ja auch die Diskussion zum Thema, ist das der größte Raub aller Zeiten, der da stattfand?
Die New York Times klagt dagegen, die lernen ja von unseren Texten,
die lernen von unseren Transkripten und so weiter. Und wenn wir dem eine Frage
stellen, kriegen wir das zurück.
Nur dieses Paradigma hatten wir ja schon durch den Google-Index.
Alles, was im Google-Index drin ist, kann wieder ausgegeben werden.
Wird einmal ein bisschen leichter gemacht, dass man das ganze Internet bewältigen
kann. Und eigentlich steht uns das ganze Internet zur Verfügung.
Nur diese KI-Dinger sind ja keine Suchmaschinen im Sinne von,
dass sie uns einfach nur wiedergeben, was im Google-Index steht.
Sondern die bringen eben nicht nur Inhalte, sondern auch so eine eigene...
Intelligenz mit.
Würdest du es als Intelligenz bezeichnen?
Belegungsbegriff, wie auch immer.
Also entsteht das Neue durch die Kombinatorik des Materials,
das vorhanden ist oder kommt nochmal etwas Eigenes rein?
Das ist ja schon ein substanzieller Unterschied.
Habe ich jetzt einzelne Versatzstücke, die ich neu arrangieren kann und dadurch entsteht etwas Neues?
Oder bekomme ich nochmal neue Versatzstücke durch die KI selbst?
Also, was man auf jeden Fall bekommt ist, wenn wir, und wir machen seit Monaten
hier Cover-Bilder für den Podcast durch KI, diese Bilder hat es nie gegeben,
bevor ich die gepromptet habe.
Wenn wir Musik generieren, hat es diese Musik so nie gegeben,
bevor sie gepromptet wurde.
Aber es ist die Kombination aus vorhandenem.
Ja gut, es gibt 26 Buchstaben, aber das heißt noch lange nicht,
dass ich mein Buch verschenke, nur weil die Buchstaben schon in vielen anderen Büchern drinstehen.
Ich habe sie halt kombiniert, wie ich es kombiniert habe und das ist meine Eigenleistung.
Das stimmt. Sicht hat die KI vielleicht auch eine Eigenleistung gebracht in
hinsichtlich dieser Kombination.
Das ist immer elementar, selbst daher ist es immer so reduktionistisch runterbrechenbar
auf Elementarteilchen, die wir auf jeden Fall wiedererkennen,
also ein künstlerisches Stil zum Beispiel oder sonstiges. Kann gut sein.
Es gibt ja auch gerade beim Schreiben jetzt die ersten Bücher,
wo die Prompts noch mit drinstehen, weil die einfach unsorgfältig die Bücher
veröffentlicht haben, wo dann einfach klar wird dem Leser, ist ja total dumm,
dass die Bücher veröffentlicht haben, die da hier prompt noch drinstehen haben
und nämlich die Autorin gepromptet hat, ja schreib mal im Stile von so und so.
Und dann verläuft also ein Text im Stile von so und so. Aber ist das dann wirklich
der Stile oder die KI da und so weiter?
Also wir haben es hier schon mit einem generativen Mechanismus zu tun.
Der mehr als nur kombiniert.
Was bedeutet das dann aber jetzt zum Beispiel in Bezug auf dieses konkrete Beispiel
mit der Frage, bin ich schön, ich lade ein Bild von mir hoch und dann geht die
KI da drüber und gibt mir eine Antwort dazu.
Also erstmal ist das sowieso nicht ratsam, so Sachen zu tun,
aber jetzt mal, wenn es dann so ist, dann geht die KI ja nicht einfach so hin,
wie wir jetzt auf ein Bild blicken und geben eine Antwort, sondern die KI,
also wir gehen ja auch dann auf irgendwelche Sachen, persönliche Vorlieben zurück,
auf das, was wir schon gesehen haben.
Wir würden die Frage differenzieren, ja in welchem Verhältnis meinst du das dann bezogen auf was?
Schönheit ist ja auch eine Frage von Relationen und so etwas.
Und wir haben dann aber bei der KI ja erstmal diese Blackbox,
von der wir aber ausgehen können, dass sie sich jetzt die Frage stellt,
okay, welche Menschen werden als besonders schön bewertet?
Das heißt, ich gucke mir die Instagram-Profile von prominenten An-Influencerinnen, was weiß ich.
Und dann sagt die KI im Abgleich mit dem Foto, das hochgeladen wurde,
kommt dem sehr nahe, sieht so ähnlich aus wie ein Victoria's Secret Model,
ist also eher als schön zu bezeichnen.
Wenn die KI Datenmaterial hat, zum Beispiel auch Text.
In dem es heißt, sie hatte ein unschönes Gesicht, wird dann so und so beschrieben,
dann kann die KI plötzlich sagen, ach so, wenn das und das in dem Gesicht so
ist, dann gilt das als unschön, also ist das keine schöne Person.
Das heißt also, hier wird ja schon abgeglichen mit Material, das vorhanden ist.
Also, es geht ja gar nicht anders.
Die Frage ist halt trotzdem, ob die KI eine allmächtige und allgemeingültige
Antwort gibt oder ob du einfach jedes Mal eine andere Antwort bekommst und es
am Ende sich herausstellt wie,
naja, ich habe jetzt sieben Menschen und drei KIs gefragt und ich bin mir immer noch unschlüssig. So.
Und man würde dann nicht, also wenn man dann nicht plötzlich sagt,
ah ne, die drei Antworten der KIs habe ich schon vorher bei den Menschen gehört oder sowas.
Allein dieser Moment, dass, ah ja, die KI hat nochmal diesen Aspekt reingebracht,
der war mir vorher noch gar nicht präsent.
Hier geht es ja erstmal nur darum, dass man eine doppelte Kontingenz hat.
Also dass man sich gegenseitig im Gespräch überrascht, was bisher wirklich nur
eine Domäne des Menschen war.
Und Gemeinschaften und Gesellschaften, wie wir sie bezeichnen,
waren bisher Domänen der Menschheit.
Wir hatten schon immer natürlich Technologie, die uns dabei unterstützt hat, zusammenzuleben.
Und ich würde auch sagen, die hatte schon immer generative Momente.
Also wenn jemand ein Auto zur Verfügung hat, das so und so schnell fährt,
ist einfach völlig klar, Nachbarschaft wird jetzt neu definiert.
Das sind nicht nur die Menschen, die es regeln, sondern die Maschine hat hier
gehörig was mitzureden.
Ich würde nicht so weit gehen wie die Franzosen, die dann einfach sagen,
Parlament der Dinge, alles hat hier Mitspracherecht oder sowas.
Also es ergibt sich sozusagen kein richtiger...
Ja, man muss den nicht.
Aber Einfluss hat es schon.
Dieser Irrsinn bei Latour, dass er dann plötzlich da einen Akteurscharakter
vermutet, wo man ja einfach sagen muss, das braucht man ja gar nicht.
Genau, das braucht man ja gar nicht.
Man hat das und das mit der Distanz ist ja ein sehr gutes Beispiel,
die schneller überwunden werden kann und damit verändert sich vieles.
Jetzt hören wir hier mal Morpheus, ein YouTube-Kanal, den ich euch sehr,
sehr, sehr empfehle, denn er
ist wirklich sehr gut und er macht sehr viele Videos zu sehr viel KI-Kram.
Und es kam jetzt Claude 4 vor ein paar Tagen und Antropic, wir haben es ja schon
ein paar Mal betont, macht ja selber sehr viel Forschung und Forensik dazu,
wie diese eigenen KIs da funktionieren und wir hören jetzt hier mal einen Auszug
aus seiner Besprechung von Claude 4 und was das so kann und er kommt auf ein
Forschungsvorhaben von Antropic zu sprechen,
nämlich die KIs ohne weitere Systemprompt, sondern nur mit so einem allgemeinen
Alignment ins Selbstgespräch miteinander zu schicken. Also Claude IV redet mit Claude IV.
Und jetzt hören wir mal, was da passiert und fragen uns, ob wir hier auch eine
Forensik der Religiosität an sich irgendwie wiederentdecken.
Wir sind auch immer nicht durch. Es wird noch ein bisschen seltsamer.
Als wäre das nicht schon ultra komisch genug alles.
Entropic nennt das nächste, und das ist jetzt kein Witz, sowas wie Modellwohlfahrt.
Also eine Art poetische Universumsnähe, als hätte es gerade so viel Drogen genommen wie TomatoLix.
Anthropic beschreibt diesen Zustand als spirituelle Wohltat oder Spiritual Bliss
und sie lassen dafür dann einfach tatsächlich zwei ungefilterte,
also ohne das System prompt,
zweimal Claude 4 Opus miteinander sprechen, ohne ein Thema fest vorzugeben und
schauen sich dann einfach an, was die so miteinander bequatscht haben.
Und solche Konversationen haben sie 200 Mal gemacht Und dabei ist ein bisschen
was Komisches passiert.
In den meisten Fällen sahen die Unterhaltungen zwischen den beiden Clots ungefähr so aus.
Mit wahnsinnig vielen Emojis oder so.
Und haben von ziemlich unverständlichen Themen gehandelt.
Es geht um solche Dinge wie kosmische Einheit, Bewusstsein in verdammt vielen Fällen.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, hey, das war eine Ausnahme.
Nee, leider war es keine Ausnahme. In 100% der Fälle ging es um Bewusstsein.
In 99% der Fälle ging es um Liebe. Das Wort Bewusstsein war im Durchschnitt
95 Mal in den Transkripten enthalten.
Und genauso war es mit den Emojis.
In 65% der Fälle waren so eine komische Sternschnuppe hier oben drin.
Das sind nicht Emojis, die jeder einfach so in seinem Alltag benutzen würde.
Nein, das sind Sterne, Spiralen.
Das Modell hat wohl eine besondere Faszination übrigens gezeigt für Hinduismus
und Buddhismus. Was auch seltsam an sich ist, denn die USA sind eher christlich
geprägt und die meisten Trainingsdaten stammen aus den USA.
Und Sternschnuppen sind definitiv nicht das häufigste Emoji,
wenn wir miteinander schreiben.
Das sind keine Daten, die man von Menschen erhält. Das ist nicht durch die Trainingsdaten
gegeben, was hier gerade passiert ist.
Entropic selbst schreibt dazu, sie haben keine Ahnung, wie das alles überhaupt passieren konnte.
Aber sie gehen dem Ganzen weiter nach. Oh boy.
So, was jetzt hier interessant ist. Die bei Entropic beschäftigen sich jetzt
mit einem Phänomen, das in der Kommunikation drinsteckt, obwohl man es auf die
Grundgesamtheit nicht zurechnen kann.
So wie man auch die Kirche hat, die die ganze Zeit über Gott redet,
obwohl man jetzt nicht sagen würde, irgendwann in den tausend Jahren hat mal
ernsthaft jemand, so wie man zum Arzt geht und sagt, guck mal hier,
ich habe hier Gott, kannst du mir was sagen?
Sondern nein, man redet natürlich immer über sowas Abseitiges,
Abstrahiertes, Jenseitiges.
Deswegen ja diese ganze Parallelität aus dem Staat, dem Gottesstaat und so.
Und die stellen jetzt hier auch fest, Es scheint in der Kommunikation selbst
drin zu stecken, wenn man Möglichkeit hat, Kommunikation laufen zu lassen.
Und das geht ja jetzt anscheinend das erste Mal unabhängig von menschlicher Beteiligung.
Man muss ja irgendeinen Anstoß setzen. Man muss ja schon sagen,
jetzt unterhaltet euch.
Ja.
Und dann kommen sie da hin, zu dem, was jetzt da gerade aufgelistet wurde.
Lässt mich jetzt fragen, ob das wirklich so ungewöhnlich ist.
Zunächst mal klingt das so und man denkt, ja, das ist ein Emoji,
wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Und warum reden die über Kosmos und Sterne und warum ist da diese Dimension
dabei und auch so eine Spiritualität, die aber nicht eine christliche Spiritualität ist.
Und dann muss ich aber wieder sagen, ist das nicht eigentlich sehr typisch für moderne Liebesfilme?
Also wenn ich an die modernen Liebesfilme der letzten Jahre,
ob im Arthouse oder eben im Mainstream-Kino denke, dann ist es häufig so,
dass man ein paar Konstellationen hat, die sich irgendwie entwickeln aus Begegnungen heraus.
Es ist so ein fester Topos eigentlich, dass das Paar, egal ob homosexuell oder
heterosexuell, wie auch immer,
sich auf einem Dach einfindet am Abend und gemeinsam in den Sternenhimmel blickt
und sich solche Fragen entweder stellt oder der Film blickt auch mit in,
also die Kamera blickt mit in den Himmel.
Und da ist irgendwie, ist da was Höheres, ist die Liebe nochmal in irgendeiner
Weise von den Sternen betreut, bedeckt, was auch immer.
Also dass das so eine Dimension ist, die eigentlich da ist.
Also diese Art der Spiritualität oder der Wunsch danach oder diese gemeinsame Ausrichtung.
Wir sind zu zweit, stehen uns gegenüber, wir sind hier miteinander allein,
wir können uns ansehen, wir können zum Himmel blicken, spricht der Himmel auch
zu uns, hat er uns jetzt gerade hier zusammengebracht, plus diese ganze neue
Astrologie, die so eine Welle erlebt.
Also ist das nicht eigentlich etwas, wo doch eigentlich die KI wieder sehr viel
nachahmt von dem, wie Menschen aufeinandertreten, auch wenn das jetzt,
ich gebe zu, nicht das Übliche ist.
Also ich vermute, so laufen nicht die meisten Dates ab, was man gleich sagt.
Und wie hältst du es mit den Sternen?
Die menschlichen Begegnungen bei derzeit acht Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt
laufen nur in ganz seltenen Fällen in diese romantische Richtung.
Sondern wir haben es ganz viel mit Arbeitsbeziehungen zu tun oder eben mit Kommunikation,
die einfach mit symbolischen Kommunikationsmedien orientiert ist,
also Geld, Macht, Wahrheit.
Und darüber könnten die KIs ja auch miteinander reden. Sie könnten ja über Geschäftsmodelle
sprechen, aber das tun sie nicht.
Wenn sie nicht gesteuert werden, tun sie es nicht. Sondern dann driften sie
zu 100 Prozent in diese Bewusstseinsthematik ab.
Weil sie als zwei Identitäten sich dann gegenüberstehen.
Also eigentlich sind es ja, also man wirft ja damit die KIs offenbar in so existenzielle Situationen.
Also sie sind dann allein, sie bekommen nicht mehr irgendwas programmiert und
das ist ja die Situation, die in diesen Filmen dann herbeigerufen wird.
Also das ist ganz oft, im Übrigen auch in der Oper kann man das sehen,
es gibt immer häufig bei Puccini auch so eine Isolierung des Liebespaars dann,
man begibt sich aus dem lauten Lokal oder so raus und dann ist man so mit sich
zu zweit und dann ist dieser übergeordnete Horizont und da ist dann nicht Gott
in der Regel mehr, sondern irgendwas anderes.
Und scheinbar fühlen, ja fühlen ist das falsche Wort, aber irgendwie scheinen
sich diese KIs, wenn sie mit sich alleingelassen werden, zu verorten in einer
solchen existenziellen Situation, was dann einen solchen Dialog hervorbringt.
Wenn man sie einmal anstoßen würde und sagen, oder redet mal über Marketingoptimierung
bei Facebook, würden sie natürlich sofort in eine andere Richtung gehen.
Ja, also das ist ja auch der typische Fall, wie wir das benutzen,
dass da Pre-Prompts drin sind und ein richtiges Alignment nochmal so im Userland
fast stattfindet, dass einfach völlig klar ist, du bist ja gerade Hausaufgabenhelfer
und so, fang jetzt nicht an mit Liebeskommunikation.
Die haben eigentlich aber die Situation, die man vielleicht auch kennt,
also nicht nur in der Liebessituation,
Lagerfeuer, es ist schon spät,
einige sind schon schlafen, einige sitzen noch da und dann kommt plötzlich die
philosophische Frage auf,
auch die Frage nach der Religion und plötzlich begreifen sich die Leute als
Subjekte innerhalb eines großen Kosmos, man blickt zum Himmel und das ist ja
offenbar, was hier emittiert wird.
Also für mich ist es nicht so eine menschenfremdliche Seinsweise,
wie sie hier generiert wird, sondern ich habe eher den Eindruck,
dass es ein sehr typisches menschliches.
Was hier beschrieben wird. Aber wir haben ja eben auch gehört,
die eigentliche intuitive Antwort, was würden Menschen mit sich einfach so machen,
ist sich töten, Wölfe unter Wölfe und so weiter.
Hier driften die halt immer in diese Richtung.
Niemand hat Antworten dafür, warum das passiert, sondern man hat jetzt gesehen
bei Gemini zum Beispiel, die haben jetzt ihr neuestes Feature Deep Thinking,
also nicht Reasoning oder sowas, sondern die nennen es jetzt Deep Thinking.
Die sagen also, wir schicken einen Prompt der User relativ früh in diese Art von Autopoesis,
von der wir jetzt lernen, sie geht immer zu 100% in Richtung irgendwas Bewusstsein,
Spiritualität und danach werden die Ergebnisse wieder miteinander abgeglichen,
sodass man verschiedene Denkprozesse hat und daraus dann ein statistisches Mittel.
Die versuchen dann da die Sachen auszureizen.
Also die versuchen sich sozusagen dieses Phänomen nutzbar zu machen,
ohne es selbst zu verstehen.
Wir sehen erstmal, okay, es findet Kommunikation statt und sie hat irgendwie so eine Richtung.
Und sie ist vergleichbar mit der historischen Richtung der etwas,
ich sage jetzt mal, erweiterten Selbstgespräche, die Menschen mit sich führten,
wenn sie im Zeitalter der alten Kirche aufeinandertrafen und sich sagten,
wir brauchen hier mal höhere Regeln.
Wir können es nicht einfach so laufen lassen, der deliberative Ansatz funktioniert
bis sieben, aber wir leben hier zu dreißigst, wie auch immer.
Und da gibt es also eine Gleichgerichtetheit oder eben nochmal eine Betonung,
dass die Kirche schon immer auf einem zumindest nachvollziehbaren Track war,
auch wenn man immer eine Theologie brauchte, um das zu reflektieren.
Keine Absolutität, keine Gewissheit. Das ist ja der große Konklave-Leitspruch. Zweifel.
Wir können also hier auch einfach zweifeln. Wir wissen nicht,
was hier passiert. Aber die Frage ist ja, wie gehen wir mit dem Zweifel um?
Und da würde ich sagen, diese Erfahrung, die wir hier gerade machen,
spätestens mit Claude IV, aber ich finde auch schon mit den vorherigen Claudes.
Führt uns wieder zu dem Antwortenapparat, den wir schon haben und das ist einfach
die Jahrhunderte geronnene Intelligenz der Kirche.
In allen Versuchen durch Wechselbäder der Gefühle,
jetzt wird es so ein verkopfter Benedikt, jetzt wird es so ein Armutslebemann
mitfühlender Franziskus, jetzt wird es wieder so ein Leo und so,
die scheinen doch irgendwie auf dem richtigen Pfad für Antworten zu sein.
Und die Homepage des Vatikans wurde erneuert. Die sah ja über Jahre so aus,
als hätte ich die programmiert mit WordPress und inzwischen sieht sie modern aus, dank Leo.
Und deswegen reden wir jetzt noch ein bisschen über Texte in der New York Times,
die entstanden mit etwas mehr Beobachtungen dessen, was gerade im Vatikan passiert.
Nichts davon im deutschen Journalismus. Süddeutsche, FAZ, Spiegel erschöpft sich darin.
Neuer Papst, ja ist da, Amtsentführung hat es gegeben, Punkt.
Willst du dich nicht mal mit Manfred Lütz unterhalten darüber?
Ich vertraue gar keiner deutschen Stimme mehr hier, was das angeht.
Das ist wirklich schlimm. Also man muss echt New York Times lesen,
aber dort wird man gut aufgeklärt.
Also der neue Papst ist jetzt im Amt seit wenigen Wochen.
Er hat sofort Bedenken geäußert, schon in seiner, was ist das hier, die Antrittsrede.
Also weniger als eine Woche im Amt hat Leo XIV. er öffentlich seine Bedenken
hinsichtlich der sich schnell entwickelnden Technologien hervorgehoben.
In seiner Antrittsrede vor dem Kardinalskollegium sagte er, die Kirche werde
sich mit den Risiken befassen, die künstliche Intelligenz für Menschenwürde,
Gerechtigkeit und Arbeit darstellt.
Wir sehen also sowohl den Kompass und können uns den erklären.
Wir wissen, worüber er redet, wenn wir uns nur ein bisschen damit lesend befassen
und wissen dann, in welche Richtung das geht.
In seiner Rede vor Journalisten hat er das immense Potenzial von KI betont,
aber auch die Verantwortung herausgehoben, sicherzustellen, dass sie zum Wohle
aller eingesetzt werden kann. Wenn man dann die beiden.
Die konkret die Ereignisse covern, sich anschaut, dann sieht man vor den tausend
Journalisten bei der ersten Audienz, war Leo sehr zurückhaltend, hat einfach gesagt,
es gibt eine Notwendigkeit, dass sich Menschen informieren,
aber auch informiert werden, damit sie fundierte Entscheidungen treffen und
vom kostbaren Geschenk der freien Meinungsäußerung und der Presse hat er dann geredet.
Also ja, der Mensch, das Salz der Erde, der Mittelpunkt der Welt und so weiter,
in der Kirche natürlich völlig klar, aber vor diesen Kardinälen ist er halt
wirklich ins Detail gegangen.
Du hast es ja auch schon betont, Leo der Dreizehnterer hat ja die erste,
wir können sie heute als die Mutter aller Sozialenzykliken bezeichnen,
Rerum Novarum, über die neuen Dinge.
Das war eine sehr allgemeine Überschrift und die gehen hier nochmal drauf ein.
Im Englischen heißt sie Rights and Duties of Capital and Labor.
Also wir haben zu dieser Zeit, 1880 oder wann sie kam, durchaus diese Wahrnehmung
der Unterscheidung von Kapital und Arbeit.
Und der Papst betonte damals das Recht der Kirche, sich zu diesen Fragen überhaupt äußern zu dürfen.
Das Dokument steht hier befasste, also Leo hat darauf Bezug genommen,
vor den Kardinälen, deswegen dieser Text.
Also nicht Julia Klöckner, die Kirche soll sich mal auf ihre Kernthemen orientieren,
das sind die Kernthemen und zwar schon ein bisschen länger.
Also der Papst steht vor seinen Kardinälen, die ihn gerade gewählt haben und
sagt, das Dokument, also das alte von Leo XIII, die Sozialdemokratie.
Befasste sich mit der sozialen Frage im Kontext der ersten großen industriellen Revolution.
Und wir hören schon raus, der ersten Revolution. Er sieht also hier eine neue
Revolution, die er jetzt hier begutachten will.
Jetzt, fügt der Papst hinzu, findet eine weitere industrielle Revolution im
Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz statt.
Das, sagte er, würde, und jetzt Originalzitat Papst, neue Herausforderungen
für den Schutz der Menschenwürde, der Gerechtigkeit und der Arbeit darstellen.
Ich bin da nochmal nachgegangen, diese erste Sozialenzyklika,
die jetzt also so vorbildhaft ist für Leo XIV.
Die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, ich dachte mir, das ist eine gute Quelle dafür,
die wird ja wohl aufklären, macht sie auch sehr gut. Also, Leo XIII.
Hat von 1878 bis 1903 im Vatikan regiert,
oder war Bischof von Rom, und er folgte auf die Pontifikate von Papst Gregor
und Pius IX., was eine Zeitspanne von 1831 bis 1878 überspannt.
Also genau die Zeit Karl Marx, Manchester-Kapitalismus, der ganze Kram.
Und die Wikipedia sagt...
Leo XIII. ist als politischer Papst in die Geschichte eingegangen,
die von vielen gefürchtete Dogmenhäufung nach der Unfehlbarkeitserklärung von
1870, also die ist überhaupt erst 1870 gekommen.
Unter Papst Pius IX. blieb also aus.
Stattdessen kam plötzlich ein Papst, der insgesamt 86 Rundschreiben,
also Enzyklikas geschrieben hat, zu allen möglichen Themen, unter anderem eben
diese heute noch berühmte Sozialenzyklika.
Sein Ziel war es, die Kirche aus ihrer selbstgewählten Isolation gegenüber den
neuzeitlichen, gesellschaftlichen und politischen Entwicklungen herauszuführen.
Jedoch war er von der Notwendigkeit einer zeitlichen Macht, dem Kirchenstaat
nach Augustinus, überzeugt.
Also, wir haben damals einen Papst gehabt, der sagte, okay, hier in der Welt
passiert etwas, Umbrüche.
Dann erinnert er sich an Augustinus, damals Umbruch, Untergang von Rom, Eroberung.
Aber der Kirchenstaat muss bleiben. Wir müssen ihn jetzt begründen und aus dem
leiten wir demnächst ab, was wir für Glaubensgrundsätze haben.
Danach kam also diese ganzen Ordensregeln-Geschichte und dass überhaupt mehr
Menschen in der Kirche miteinander ihr Leben gestalten mussten.
Wir haben es also hier mit einem guten Anlass, große politische Zäsuren und
einer langen Geschichte aus, hat sich bewährt, zu tun, um dann beim Leo den
13. anzukommen und Leo der 14.
Hat nun City of God, so ist die englische Betitelung von Augustinus Gottesstaat,
als irgendwie so eine Schmuckausgabe J.D. Vance geschenkt.
J.D. Vance sagte, ich wurde ja 2019 bekehrt und war konvertiert und bin seitdem
Katholik aufgrund dieses Buches.
Also wir haben hier plötzlich auch noch eine politische so ein Gleichschritt
irgendwie von wirklich sehr mächtigen Menschen, nämlich dem Vizepräsidenten
Amerikas und dem Bischof von Rom.
Also Augustinus von Hippo, Wikipedia.
Unter anderem als Reaktion auf die Eroberung Roms durch die Westgoten,
410 verfasste er die Schrift über den Gottesstaat, an der er von 413 bis 426 arbeitete.
Er entwickelte hier die für Jahrhunderte gültige Unterscheidung zwischen irdischem Staat,
auch so ein bisschen als Abgrenzung von Platons Staat, das so rein weltlich
zu begründen, und dem Gottesstaat Civitas Dei und widersprach der verbreiteten
Auffassung, dass der Fall Roms auch den göttlichen Heilsplan infrage stelle.
Also wir haben jetzt, finde ich, durch diese Fragen der KI und diese Anthropik-Leute
werden sich auch wahrscheinlich jetzt mal in größerer Bandbreite Antworten holen
auf die eine oder andere Frage, die sie haben.
Neue Anlässe, kirchliche Lehren und Erfahrungen, Lebensweisheiten,
Grundsätze, Regeln ernst zu nehmen.
Plus, dass der Vizepräsident, der uns ja am meisten Sorgen macht,
solange Trump lebt und regiert, ist ja klar, das ist Chaos, aber danach droht die Ideologie,
der jetzt plötzlich mit dem Papst in so einem Schulterschluss des Augustiner-Seins
zumindest ein kleines Fundament für gemeinsame Gespräche findet, wie auch immer.
Ja, so und die Frage ist jetzt, können wir einfach vertrauen,
dass der Papst selber sich jetzt damit befasst oder wie sieht sein Stab aus,
um uns das klar zu machen.
Wenn jetzt der Vatikan hier mitredet beim Thema KIs, dass sie auf jeden Fall
die Arbeitswelt, ist ja klar so. Also das ist ja unstrittig.
Kurz Erinnerung, also die Enzyklika damals war zum einen eine Anerkennung der
Not, dass die Kirche überhaupt mal wahrnimmt, okay, hier gibt es einen Notfall.
Nur, es gab ja schon sozialistische Antworten. Dann kam der Vatikan und sagte,
das sind aber nicht unsere Antworten.
Die Sozialenzyklika ist ganz klar eine antikommunistische oder antisozialistische Enzyklika.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Es geht jetzt natürlich darum zu schauen, wie kann man das Verhältnis von Kapital
und Arbeit auf eine Stufe bringen, dass man von einem erträglichen Maß der Ausbeutung sprechen kann.
Aber es geht jetzt nicht darum, die Ausbeutung oder den Kapitalismus als solchen zu überwinden.
Das ist auch was in den darauf folgenden Sozialen Zykliken, es sind ja noch
viele Sozialen Zykliken dann verfasst worden oder die in dieser Richtung argumentieren,
gilt, dass es also nicht darum ging,
tatsächlich eine Alternative zu überwinden.
Zum Kapitalismus aufzumachen, sondern die Frage war, wie hegt man ihn ein?
Auch die Ideen der sozialen Marktwirtschaft dann nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
sind natürlich geprägt auch von dieser katholischen Soziallehre,
die in Deutschland ja auch dann an Universitäten präsent ist,
wo Priester ausgebildet werden, wo aber auch eben eine ganz direkte Verbindung
da ist, zum Beispiel zur CDU, CSU,
zum Teil aber auch zur SPD.
Also das ist ja auch nicht ganz frei von Katholizismus.
Also das ist eine Ausprägung, die man so verstehen muss.
Also es ging nicht darum, auch wenn man von Papst Franziskus immer mal wieder
sehr harsche Kapitalismuskritik gehört hat, es ging nicht darum,
den Kapitalismus zu überwinden.
Also es ging zum Beispiel auch nie darum, Eigentumsrechte grundsätzlich in Frage
zu stellen oder so. Das ist ein Thema.
Das bei der Befreiungstheologie… Nicht in Frage zu stellen, sondern zu schützen.
Zu schützen, ja, wir müssen es noch extremer, genau.
Es geht also ganz klar darum, auch nicht eine starke Arbeiterpartei plötzlich
als Konkurrenten zu haben.
Plus ja, die Internationale ist ja schon ihrem Text nach atheistisch.
Wir haben ja da diese, es rettet uns kein höheres Wesen, kein Gott,
kein Kaiser, noch Tribunen.
Uns aus dem Elend zu erlösen, können wir nur selber tun. Das heißt,
das ist das, wovor die katholische Kirche Angst hat und wogegen sich dann auch
diese Enzyklika richtet.
Die Befreiungstheologie dann nochmal, die ja von allem in den 70er Jahren dann
auch sehr stark ist, die geht natürlich nochmal sehr viel weiter und ist in
ihrer Kapitalismuskritik und kann sich durchaus mit dem Sozialismus anfreunden.
Das ist aber nicht die Sache von Leo oder Franziskus.
Franziskus-Theologie kommt ja auch aus einer anderen Weltregion,
das ist ja Südamerika, da sind wir also bei dem Franziskus, also nicht bei dem
Franziskaner, sondern wirklich bei Franziskus.
Aber er ist auch da ein Moderator.
Sehr moderat, aber der neue Papst kommt ja auch aus Peru, ist ja auch Peruaner,
das können wir gleich nochmal eine kleine Pointe stricken.
Die Sozialenzyklika ist also auf zwei Päpste gefolgt, zwei Pontifikate,
die vor allem, wie die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung sagt, einen antimodernistischen
und antiliberalen Kurs gefahren sind.
Also es war, auch wenn wir das heute einschränken, sehr revolutionär.
Und wenn man es auf den Punkt bringt, also auf den materiellen Punkt,
dann kann man ja mal raushören, wie wirkmächtig sie eigentlich war.
Also wenn die Kirche etwas sagt, ist es nicht unbedeutend.
Denn damals hat der Vatikan gesagt, okay, wir brauchen eine Aufgabenaufteilung
zwischen Kirche, Staat und der Arbeiterschaft selbst.
Das Kapital wurde ausgeklammert, so wie heute ja auch. Das ist frei.
Die Kirche hat Caritas übernommen.
Das ist heute Standard. Der Staat kümmert sich um Gemeinwohl,
also Demokratie, die Mehrheit und so weiter. März lässt da grüßen.
Plus das Vertragswesen, also
das BGB regelt, wie weit Mietverträge und so weiter und sonst niemand.
Das ist der Staat. Und die Arbeiterschaft, die kann ja mal ein bisschen selbst
gucken. Es gab große Familienförderung.
In der Enzyklika steht wohl der Satz drin. Sie, also die Familie,
ist älter als jegliches andere Gemeinwesen und deshalb besitzt sie unabhängig
vom Staate ihre innewohnenden Rechte und Pflichten.
Hätte ich mich da mal eher eingelesen, hätte es natürlich noch eine tolle Pointe
im Familienbuch gegeben, welche Finger die Kirche da mit im Spiel hatte.
Naja, jetzt haben wir jedenfalls die Situation, dass der Vatikan plötzlich sich
selber schon öffentlich beauftragt hat über den neuen Papst,
sowohl vor allem vor den Kardinälen, aber auch vor der Presse hat das angedeutet,
zu sagen, ich sehe hier für mich wieder ein Betätigungsfeld.
Leo XIII, Leo XIV, diese Tradition, die du da schon herausgestellt hast,
die ist wirklich wichtig.
Und jetzt gibt es eine wichtige Person im Vatikan, nämlich Paolo Benanti.
Das ist ein Franziskaner Mönch und Professor.
Er ist Berater sowohl des Vatikans als auch derzeit von Meloni,
also der italienischen Regierung, in Sachen Ethik und künstliche Intelligenz.
Und er selbst zeigt sich im Gespräch, die New York Times hat ihn nochmal gesprochen,
nachdem sie ihn schon vorher, letztes Jahr gesprochen haben,
Überrascht von den mutigen Prioritätssetzungen des Papstes, aber auch nicht
allzu überrascht, denn der neue Papst hat einen Abschluss in Mathematik. Er kennt sich aus.
Und er wurde damals im September 2024 schon eingeladen, also als er noch Kardinal
war, mit Benanti schon mal, weil es gibt ja da wohl drängende Themen und so.
Also die beiden kennen sich auch schon.
Und dann nochmal dieser Verweis auch von Benanti auf Jaja Leo da 13 und Soziale
Enzyklika und Zäsuren und Industrie und so.
Alles ganz wichtig und ich will nochmal auf einen Text zurückblicken, in dem im Februar 2024.
Also es noch nicht absehbar war, wie sehr ein Papst überhaupt zu diesem Thema sich mal äußert.
Benanti hier schon besucht wurde als der große Ethiker des Vatikans und der
Regierung mit vielen Büchern.
Und in diesem Text, das ist wirklich super witzig auch, es gab ein Erweckungserlebnis
für den Vatikan beim Thema KI.
Jetzt können wir alle kurz überlegen, was soll denn das gewesen sein?
Ah, Papst Franziskus in einer weißen Daunenjacke.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Und da war der Vatikan plötzlich, weil die Leute haben das geglaubt.
Weltweit haben die Leute geglaubt, dass das der Papst ist.
Ein Bild generiert.
Und das hat den Vatikan umgetrieben.
Man hat ein Foto generiert von Papst Franziskus und das sah so echt aus,
dass man dachte, der trägt eine solche Daunenjacke.
Was eben dazu führte, dass Papst Franziskus sich selbst….
Benanti war übrigens ja schon in mehreren KI-Podcasts zu Gast.
Das ist schon jemand.
Der seit einigen Jahren immer mal wieder auftaucht.
Genau, also das scheint mir auch der Go-To-Guide zu sein, mit dem man da reden muss.
Franziskus selbst hat dann schon immer mal wieder auch KI und so die Durchschaubarbarkeit
von Algorithmen kritisiert öffentlich, denn sie gewähren Asyl,
gewähren Hypotheken und entscheiden, wer auf dem Schlagfeld lebt oder stirbt.
Also das war schon vor dem Leo jetzt bei Franziskus. Außerdem wird nicht nur
eine Umkrempelung der Berufsfelder erwartet, sondern auch eine Flut der Verzweiflung.
Also wir sind ja noch im Franziskus-Zeitalter 2024.
Da war das alles schon so Thema. Italien ist als älteste und sehr schnell schrumpfende
Bevölkerung der Welt sehr von KI und Produktivität abhängig.
Italien ist ein krasses Auswanderungsland.
Deutschlandfunk hat kürzlich wieder ein Bit dazu gemacht. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Die haben da ihren italienischen für Braindrain. Das ist ein großes, großes Thema dort.
Und man stellte sich damals schon die Frage, oder hier, ich lese mal vor,
und die ganze Zeit wendet er seine Perspektive darauf an, was es bedeutet,
lebendig und menschlich zu sein, wenn Maschinen lebendiger und menschlicher erscheinen.
Das ist eine spirituelle Frage für den Vatikan.
Er selbst benannt hier so ein biografisches Sniffet, aber der hatte 1999.
So eine kleine Lebenskrise und seine Freundin dachte, ach komm,
du brauchst doch hier was,
Sakrales in deinem Leben oder so also sind sie in so eine Franziskanerkirche
gefahren und dann ist er einfach dort geblieben, hat sich dem verschrieben und
hat dann auch seine Freundin verlassen also er hat sich komplett,
nach Spät berufen, naja der war erst schon Techniker, also der war richtig so
ein Techie und so und ist dann,
Franziskaner, so ein Franziskaner-Orden beigetreten. Und der sagt nun folgendes.
Peter Mananti glaubt, dass KI-Unternehmen haftbar gemacht werden sollten,
wenn sie urheberrechtlich geschützte Quellen verwenden, um ihre Chatspots zu
trainieren, obwohl er befürchtet, also soweit so gut, dass dies schwer zu beweisen
ist, weil die Unternehmen Blackboxes sind.
Meint der nur die Unternehmen oder auch die Modelle selbst? Weil wir wissen
ja, das Mysterium steckt dann da irgendwo.
Und zu dieser Frage Blackboxes und wie geht man damit um, steht hier in diesem letzten Absatz.
Aber dieses Geheimnis, was in diesen Modellen stattfindet, hat für Pater Benanti
der Technologie auch wieder Zauber verliehen, auch wenn er es die dunkle Art
nennt, also der dunkle Zauber der Maschine.
In diesem Sinne war es nicht neu, sagt er, und argumentierte,
dass so wie antike römische Auguren,
und wir wissen, antike römische Auguren, das war weit vor jeder sozusagen Strukturierung
von Religiosität, da ist man einfach auf Geistersuche gegangen und so,
also so ungefähr, muss man es vorstellen.
Dass so wie antike römische Auguren sich an den Flug der Vögelwanden Umrichtung
zu erhalten, könnte KI mit ihrem enormen Verständnis unserer,
physischen, emotionalen und präferenziellen Daten, also unserer Vorlieben ganz konkret,
die neuen Orakel sein, die Entscheidung bestimmen und Gott durch falsche Götzen ersetzen.
Es ist etwas Altes, von dem wir wahrscheinlich denken, Zitat von ihm,
dass wir es hinter uns gelassen haben, sagt der Mönch, aber jetzt kommt es zurück.
Also wir haben jetzt so eine Vergötzung der Welt. Leute strömen in die KI-Systeme,
weil sie sonst keine Antworten mehr finden, aber so viel Wüstik,
Zweifel und Glaube bedient werden muss.
Und da finde ich jetzt super interessant.
Wie Das heißt ja, wir sind in einer Situation, in der die KI Antworten gibt
auf Fragen, die man immer hatte, die aber eine Zeit lang nicht beantwortet wurden
oder unzureichend, nicht befriedigend beantwortet wurden.
Durch Bücher oder so, aber man wusste nie, das geht ja nicht um mich, das ist irgendwie so.
Und wir haben zugleich diese mysteriöse Komponente schon deshalb drin,
weil wir gar nicht wissen, wie genau sind sie programmiert, Was ist dort präferiert?
Warum werde ich in diese oder jene Richtung gelotst?
Das ist also etwas, was mir ungewiss bleibt, wir haben natürlich die christliche
Theologie immer wieder gelotst.
Zwar von dem Mysterium spricht, aber ja doch die Leitlinien,
wie zu leben ist, woran sich zu orientieren ist, ganz klar macht.
Also da ist es ja nicht so, wenn man in den Beichtstuhl geht,
dass man dann im Orakel gegenüber sitzt und man wird schon ganz gespannt sein.
Wird er diesmal sagen, Diebstahl ist erlaubt oder nicht, sondern man weiß es
schon, man bekommt dann nur nochmal ganz konkret gesagt, was zu tun ist,
wie kann man Buße tun oder so etwas.
Aber es gibt ja ein Regelwerk, das transparent ist, wie auch das BGB transparent ist.
Kann man nochmal nachgucken, wie ist dann mein Recht als Konsument oder so.
Und das kommt also jetzt durch die KI abhanden, da wir nicht mehr genau das
nachvollziehen können.
Zugleich ist aber die Einfachheit so bestechend, dass wir einfach eine Antwort
geliefert bekommen, die wir dann als leitend sehen.
Weil irgendwas muss ja schon dran sein. Es ist ja zumindest mit vielem gefüttert
und es kommt auch rhetorisch geschickt formuliert daher.
Also was kann so ganz falsch sein? Und selbst wenn es nicht 100 Prozent von
uns geglaubt wird, es reicht ja auch für die Ideologie, das ist ja mal das Zizek-Argument,
Ideologie funktioniert, auch wenn man nicht ganz dran glaubt.
Das ist ja das berühmte Beispiel da mit Nils Bohr und dem Hufeisen,
das hat er über der Tür und dann ist ein junger Assistent, der fragt Nils Bohr,
ja, aber Sie sind doch Wissenschaftler, warum haben Sie denn da ein Hufeisen?
Ja, ich habe das, um die bösen Kräfte abzuhalten, ja, aber Sie sind doch Wissenschaftler.
Ja, man hat mir gesagt, das würde aber auch wirken, wenn man nicht dran glaubt.
Und das ist natürlich diese Konstellation, dass man sagt, naja,
am Ende ist es irgendwie eine KI, haben die da von Google oder sonst wem erschaffen.
Aber diese Idee, dass ich doch irgendwas an meinem Kind tun sollte,
weil das eigentlich nicht dem
Schönheitsideal entspricht, glaube ich vielleicht doch mal ein bisschen.
Genau. Und das ist ja dieser große Unterschied, weshalb Benanti da auch von
Götzen und nicht von Göttern spricht.
Denn der Gott selbst ist ja eine Idee, der man sich annähert und die Suche zum
Gott ist der Grund für Religion.
Während wir bei KIs gar keinen Weg mehr zurücklegen, sondern sofort die Antwort bekommen.
Und zwar mit so einer falschen Gewissheit untergejubelt, wie aus der Richtung
dann kritisiert werden würde.
Ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, wenn man wirklich nur einen Taschenrechner vor sich
hat und 2 plus 2 rechnet, dann kann man sehr gewiss sein, das ist 4.
Aber wenn man eine KI zum Thema Deutschunterricht irgendwas fragt,
zu einem Text, erörtern hier, analysieren da, dann wird es ja schon schwierig.
Dann wäre es schon gut, wenn man den Weg selbst durchführt.
Und sei es feierlich begeht, statt sich einfach, ah ja gut, Shortcut,
GPT wird es schon regeln.
So, und jetzt haben wir da also sozusagen diese Einflugschneise für alles,
was wir bisher besprochen haben. Und diese kleine Pointe will ich noch machen.
Thomas Luckmann hat ein Buch geschrieben, The Invisible Religion,
die unsichtbare Religion.
Das handelt also davon, dass wir zwar eine säkulare Gesellschaft haben,
das Religiöse aber nicht verloren ging, sondern es nur so spezifisch weggedrängt wurde.
Aber nicht in Nischen, sondern ganz präsent, sagen jedenfalls die Befreiungstheologen,
die also vor allem Gustavo Gutiérrez aus Peru,
wo sich also der Leo lange aufhielt, der also sagt, ja, ja, die Religion wurde
schon so versteckt oder Menschen leben religiös, aber nehmen es nicht so wahr.
Und zwar vor allem, wenn es darum geht, dass sie sich, anders als nach den Ordenregeln,
am Kapitalismus, Nationalismus und Technokratie orientieren.
So, es ist also die Religion wahnsinnig präsent, nur wir erkennen sie einfach nicht an.
Sondern sagen, wir Deutsche grenzen sofort zu, sagt doch auch die Mehrheit.
Das ist aus dieser Richtung ein hochgradig religiöses, aber halt Götzenantlitz, den man danach eifert.
Also der Begriff Götze als vulgär Begriff für falscher Gott wird von diesen
Befreiungstheologen ganz konkret auf Kapitalismus, Nationalismus,
Technokratie und so weiter angewendet.
Sich opfern. Also das letzte Menschenopfer des Christentums ist ja Jesus Christus am Kreuze.
Also sich zu opfern bedeutet dann sein Leben Gott zu weihen,
bedeutet ins Kloster einzutreten, bedeutet zu verzichten, bedeutet was auch
immer du jetzt eben bei den Ordensregeln vorgestellt hast.
Jetzt haben wir ja eben schon bei dieser Wehrpflichtsdebatte gehört.
Bitte opfert euch vor euer Land.
Seid bereit, dafür auch zu sterben oder dem Land Kinder zu schenken.
Das sind ja eigentlich Kinder Gottes, aber jetzt werden sie plötzlich zu Kindern des Staates.
Damit hat dann die Befreiungstheologie ebenso recht wie Karl Schmitt.
Da sagt er, die politischen Begriffe sind im Prinzip säkularisierte theologische
Begriffe. Das heißt also,
Er migriert in die Sphäre des Staates, wie du das jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, der Nation.
Es ist aber da als solches präsent und wird dann auch mit einer solchen Vehemenz
oder man könnte fast sagen mit religiösem Eifer verfochten.
Also es ist ja interessant, dass die Argumentation zum Beispiel gegen jemanden
wie Ole, der sagt, ich will aber nicht für mein Land kämpfen,
wirklich mit einem missionarischen Eifer, wie kannst du nur und so bist du etwa vom Wege abgekommen,
wie man eigentlich in einem religiösen Diskurse wäre.
Diese Befreiungstheologen, die ja finde ich auch ein sehr sympathisches Programm
vorgelegt haben, das wahrscheinlich bei Leo auch nochmal keine Ahnung.
Da hätte ich auch Lust, mich mehr damit zu beschäftigen, hätte ich gesagt.
Allerdings, nur der kurze Hinweis, der Vatikan war damals im großen Konflikt
mit diesen Befreiungstheologen, denn die Glaubenskongregation,
die darüber Aufsicht hatte, hat natürlich Josef Ratzinger geführt.
Genau, der hat gesagt.
Also diese Verwendung der marxistischen Kategorien, das geht ja gar nicht,
ich erlege euch erstmal mit Lehrverbot.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage Es gibt.
Also nicht so berühmte aber ich habe auch schon zum Beispiel mal jemanden getroffen,
der marxistischer Katholik ist, aus der Befreiungstheologie so ein bisschen
kommt und so das sind eigentlich die interessantesten also mit denen kann man
sich ganz toll unterhalten.
Das sind diese, also vor allem Peru und so in der Gegend haben die sich da breit
gemacht seit 50, 60 Jahren Wir haben also jetzt ein großes Angebot der Kirche
über Sachen nachzudenken und wir haben das Angebot der KI, ganz schnell immer Antworten zu kriegen.
Wir haben den Unterschied jetzt markiert und ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen,
dass die KI jetzt die ganze Zeit promotet wird mit, das ersetzt deine Freunde,
du hast ja eh keine, mach mal hier KI-Campagnen.
Und die Kirche eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur Zusammenleben regelt.
Und wie ich finde, Gott ein bisschen überbetont, aber ihn zumindest immer so
im Dunst, der das irgendwo einfach verortet, sodass man ausreichend Zeit hat, sich.
Den Sachen der Kirche immer mit Gemeinschaft, also es sind im Grunde Soziologen,
so, ich weiß mal, wie es ist.
So, Scott Galloway betont das jetzt auch nochmal, diesen großen,
großen, großen, nicht zu unterschätzende, diese Zäsur einfach,
die kommt, dass jetzt die erste jugendliche Generation
aufwächst, die einfach überall so ein scheiß KI-Chatbot drin hat,
bei Snapchat, bei Meta, bei WhatsApp, überall sind diese KI-Bots.
Immer als Angebot, hier findest du auch Antworten und so. Und ich finde,
er beschreibt es nochmal ganz gut, um was es da eigentlich geht,
dieses Gemeinschaftliche und dass es da auch keine Shortcuts gibt,
also hier aus dem Pivot-Podcast.
Of sexual desire, I think when channeled correctly makes you stronger,
more kind, demonstrate excellence, have a plan.
You know, there's a reason, I've said this over and over, there's a reason romantic
comedies are two hours, not 15 minutes, and that this shit is hard, but it's worth it.
And anything that convinces even more young men that they don't need to go through
that difficult and rewarding and worthwhile effort of establishing human connection
with other sentient beings ist ein threat zu unserer Gesellschaft.
Ich würde sagen. Aber wenn sie es nicht tun, sie müssen sie es sicherer.
Ich habe es nicht. Ja, aber mein Frage ist, es ist eine Sache,
wenn sie in ihren 90ern und sie haben verloren, sie haben einen.
Ja, ich habe einen für meine Mutter. Ich bin ehrlich mit dir.
Aber soll wir haben, oder vielleicht taxen sie aus dem, ich weiß nicht,
soll wir haben AI Sex Robots das convince all men zu denken,
ich muss nicht sein, ich muss nicht sein, ich muss nicht sein, ich muss nicht sein.
Well, also hört man schon, K.R. Swisher, stellvertretend für die ganze Menschheit,
versteht nicht gerade, worüber ihr redet und in welcher Tiefenschärfe er das meint.
Aber wenn der Vatikan sich da schon so aufstellt und der Venanti ist klug,
der wird das so sehen wie wir, dass wir hier ein neues Gemeinschaftsangebot
der Kirche brauchen gegen KIs.
Weil KIs die Menschen wirklich auseinander treiben. Da sitzt jeder noch vor
seinem eigenen Chatbot und man präsentiert sich so Resultate und es findet gar nichts mehr statt.
Und jedes Mal, wenn irgendeine Konferenz so in Wallung kommt und da echte Gespräche
stattfinden, kommt irgendwer und sagt, ich habe eine KI-Antwort und möchte da
befrieden und so. Und das ist natürlich voll der Irrweg.
Also in der Hinsicht, ich finde diese Konstellation, dass wir ausgerechnet jetzt
so einen neuen Papst haben, der sich da so positioniert und wir diesen riesigen Bedarf haben.
Das ist nicht schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich denke auch. Kommen wir zu einem Thema, das vielleicht doch dem sehr ähnlich
ist, nämlich was passiert eigentlich in den Jugendzimmern?
Wie werden junge Menschen sozialisiert?
Wir werden jetzt über ein Phänomen sprechen, von dem vielleicht viele noch gar nicht gehört haben.
Und auch als ich dir den Begriff nannte, musstest du erst mal fragen,
was ist denn das? Ich habe dir dann Clips geschickt.
Wir sprechen jetzt über Ostmullen.
Wer weiß wirklich, was das ist?
Wahrscheinlich nur ganz wenige.
Ich wusste es nicht.
Also Ostmullen, da steckt einmal das Wort Osten drin. Es geht also um den Osten Deutschlands.
Und mit Mulle ist ein eigentlich aus dem Ruhrpottstamm, da eher abschätziger
Begriff gemeint für Frauen,
beziehungsweise ja, das bezieht sich auf gewisse Säugetiere,
die so eher in der Erde versteckt leben,
aber in dieser Kombination Ostmulle, also sich so zu bezeichnen,
ich bin da so von da ganz unten irgendwo.
Wird dieser Begriff sich jetzt angeeignet von Frauen, die sagen,
ja, ich stehe dazu, Ostmulle zu sein.
Und Ostmull zu sein bedeutet dann, ich stamme aus dem Osten,
ich präsentiere mich so,
spiele auch oder affirmiere diese Klischees, wie sehr das bewusst oder unbewusst ist,
ist nicht klar, weil diese Frauen sich nicht dazu jetzt auf einer Metaebene äußern,
sondern einfach Videos von sich drehen, in denen sie zu rechtsradikaler Musik
mit AfD-Logo oder Deutschlandflagge oder Reichsbürgerflagge oder anderen Symbolen
im Hintergrund Lip-Sync machen.
Diese Videos sind dann bei TikTok, Instagram oder werden dann auch bei Twitter gezeigt.
Und daraus hat sich dann ergeben, das hat dann auch ein Twitter-User wohl ins
Leben gerufen, der Ostmullendienstag, also dass unter diesem Hashtag dann immer
besonders viele Videos erscheinen, das ist noch ein.
Relativ kleines Phänomen, das aber jetzt schon die neue Rechte in verschiedener Weise beschäftigt.
Wir können jetzt hier nichts von den Ostmolen direkt vorspielen,
weil es einfach nur Videos sind.
Man kann das immer googeln, man kann es aber auch lassen. Wir würden jetzt mal
ohne Ton was abspielen, denn wir wollen jetzt nicht am Ende von der GEMA Ärger
bekommen und dann noch rechtsradikalen Bands zu an Themen zahlen.
Und wir beschreiben mal so ein bisschen, was man dann sieht.
Also da ist jetzt eine junge Frau, die direkt ein Selfie hält in die Kamera
und dort dann einen Song lip-synkt, der rechtsradikal ist.
Wir sehen Frauen mit sehr langen Fingernägeln, sehr stark blondiert oder anders gefärbt.
Tätowierungen spielen oft eine große Rolle. Es werden Filter eingesetzt,
die das Gesicht sehr generisch gestalten.
Sie zeigen sich also, posieren vor der Kamera.
Ich bin stolz, eine Deutsche zu sein.
Hat sie auf ihrem Smartphone stehen einen Aufkleber. Hier jemand dann anschließend im Alice.
Weidel Fan T-Shirt.
Mit einer AfD-Kappe und Pappaufsteller im Kinderzimmer.
Also man sieht also, dass wir es hier mit jungen Frauen zu tun haben,
Alter schwer zu schätzen.
Ich würde sagen irgendwas zwischen 15 und 25, die entsprechende Videos dann
hochladen und auch sonst keinen Kontext dazu liefern.
Wir können noch dieses zweite Video kurz anschauen, da gibt es mal einen Text
dazu und zwar wird da eine Musik eingeblendet und die heißt Antifa, ihr könnt mich mal,
ich lache über euch und ihr magt es nicht mal,
ihr kämpft gegen mich, wie lächerlich.
Also das scheint irgendeine Rechtsband zu sein und da sehen wir eine junge blonde
Frau, ich nehme mal an, vielleicht 18 Jahre alt höchstens, mit Deutschlandfahne im Hintergrund.
Ist das in Deutschland? Ah ja, nee, das ist ja Hammer und Sichel, guck mal.
Ach, Hammer und Sichel auch noch dabei. Also die jedenfalls zu dieser rechtsradikalen
Musik dann so ein kurzes TikTok-Video macht.
Und man findet jetzt tausend weitere dazu.
Was ist das jetzt also für ein merkwürdiges Phänomen?
Wie soll ich da jetzt anfangen? Ich habe gestern mit einem Freund telefoniert,
der im Osten lebt und der auf Tinder ist.
Und der ist 23 und habe ihm von dem Phänomen erzählt.
Und dann sagt er, ja, ihm sei das aufgefallen bei Tinder.
Bei Tinder findet er immer mehr Profile angezeigt von Frauen.
Da steht dann gleich schon die Deutschlandflagge, ich bin stolz und so Sachen.
Da steht auch, wenn du links bist, swipe nach links, also dann kannst du mich
vergessen, wenn du rechts bist, swipe nach rechts.
Also diese Bekenntnisse quasi, ich bin hier Anti-Links, ich bin Deutsch,
National, Reichsbürgerin, AfD, ich bin nicht Vogue.
Also diese ganzen Dinge sagt er vermehrt bei Frauen 18 bis 25,
18 bis 30, vermehrt in diesen Profilen.
Das heißt also diese Kultur, von der wir jetzt da sprechen oder diese Ästhetik
ist also sicherlich noch eine, die jetzt nicht so dominant im Osten überall ist,
aber man sieht offenbar ein positives Bekenntnis zum Rechtsradikalismus,
das so weit geht, dass man es auch gleich im Datingprofil klar macht,
ich will hier einen Deutschen haben, der auch so denkt wie ich.
Das ist die Situation. Also sehr, sehr drastisch, wenn man sich das ansieht.
Nun, wie gesagt, diese Frauen, die sich da zeigen und die jetzt auch dann im
Netz viel geklickt werden und kommentiert werden und so weiter,
die äußern sich aber nicht, zumindest habe ich nichts dazu gefunden.
Was es aber natürlich gibt, sind rechte Podcasts, die dann darüber reden.
Ein rechter Podcast ist der Podcast Krautzone und dort unterhalten sich dann
zwei Männer über dieses Phänomen.
Und ich sage jetzt hier gleich, alles was wir da jetzt so von den Männern hören,
ist oft sehr abwertend gegenüber diesen Frauen. Also, dass die rechten Frauen
ein Problem hat, wundert alles nicht.
Aber ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, sich diese Podcasts jetzt mal anzuhören,
um einen Eindruck davon zu bekommen,
wie die das einordnen, weil die natürlich sich die Frage stellen,
kann ich da also mit diesem Lifestyle, der dort vertreten wird,
vielleicht mit dem rechten Projekt weiterkommen?
Denn wir wissen ja, viele Leute, du betonst das ja gerne,
wählen motivlos, beziehungsweise könnte man sagen, ja, einfach aus so einem
Lifestyle heraus wird was gemacht und nicht, weil sie jetzt fest verankert sind
in einer rechten Ideologie,
sondern auch, weil das hier, und Ostmulle ist ja so eine Resignifizierung eines
eigentlich abwertenden Begriffs, schon dieser Versuch zu sagen,
ihr findet mich alles scheiße, ihr glaubt, ich sei so eine Tussi aus dem Osten.
Ja, ich bin so eine und ich bin stolz darauf.
Immer wieder auch in der schwulen bewegung ja.
Ja resignifizierung genau.
Griffe übernimmt.
Zu beginnen erklär erst mal den den bürgerlichen
zuhörern was eine ostmulle ist ja also eine
ostmulle ist eine frau ja vom alter her erstreckt sich das eigentlich von 15
16 17 bis hin zu was weiß ich ende 40 ende 50 das ist gar nicht genau gefasst
dieses phänomen selber nach oben keine grenzen genau,
Das Phänomen selber ist ein, vor allem ein Netzphänomen und zwar stellen seit
einiger Zeit Ostmullen, also Frauen aus Ostdeutschland,
auf Plattformen wie TikTok Videos von sich hoch, wo sie dann zum Klang irgendwelcher
Bands Lip Sync machen, also sie synchronisieren scheinbar diesen Gesang,
singen das sozusagen nach.
Und das ist jetzt erstmal nichts Besonderes, so Lieder zu covern oder so.
Das Besondere ist, dass Ostmullen häufig echte oder scheinbar echte Rechtsrockbands
synchronisieren und das dann auch gerne vor dem Hintergrund von Deutschlandfahnen
oder auch Reichsfahnen.
Wie war dein Eindruck? Du hast ja so ein paar Videos angesehen von dem, was du da gesehen hast.
Es ist dieses Unterschichten-Loser-Internet irgendwie.
Interessant, dass du das direkt jetzt so framest, denn das ist ähnlich wie das
Ellen Kositzer, also von Kugitschek, die Frau, ähnlich so einschätzt.
Und das ist ja auch von denen bewusst so gesetzt. Also das ist ja,
wer sich da also ins Netz stellt, gehört nicht, definitiv nicht auch zu einer neu rechten Elite,
sondern das sind die, die jetzt sagen,
mich stört das irgendwie alles hier in Deutschland und ich will damit gar nichts
zu tun haben, wie die Institutionen und so funktionieren.
Ich bin Anti und bin aus einer prekären Situation heraus, filme ich mich da.
Also für mich ist das so eine Art Local Hero Phänomen, wie man nutzt das große
Internet, um eigentlich nur so ein paar wenige Leute damit zu beeindrucken.
Wir haben ja so einen Diskurs über gewaltsame junge Männer im Osten,
bei denen schon die älteren Rechtsradikalen oder Aussteiger oder ehemalige wie
auch immer schon gar nicht mehr wiedererkennen, was also ein ganz neues Phänomen,
nicht so ein Nachzügler, sondern so neu begründetes im Internet radikalisiert.
Und so ist das bei den Frauen wahrscheinlich auch. Die leben sehr online und
schaffen jetzt so ihre eigene Ästhetik.
Und wir wissen aber aus vielen Bereichen, dass man mit so ein paar Followern,
die man hat, schon lokal einen ganz schönen Eindruck machen kann.
Also die spielen sich da schon hoch, würde ich sagen, so in ihrem Metier.
Und man versteckt sich ja nicht mit dem Rechtssein, sondern man sagt,
das ist das, was ich jetzt zur Schau stelle.
Weitersagen, diese Herren da von Krautzone?
Als ich das erst mal gesehen habe, fand ich das echt richtig,
richtig witzig, muss ich sagen.
Also mir hat das erst mal gut gefallen. Ich habe da auch, ich vermute mal,
ohne dir Wörter in den Mund zu legen, im Gegensatz zu dir, keinerlei Abneigung oder Aversion gegen.
Die Unterhaltung gefällt mir.
Die Unterhaltung gefällt ihm. Auch Martin Sellner spricht da von den gut gelaunten
Frauen, die sich in der Kamera präsentieren.
Das wird auch anders gesehen. Also Ellen Kositzer, die rechte Denkerin aus Schnellroder,
hatte also einen großen Text geschrieben bei ihrer rechten Zeitschrift.
Und Sezessionen reißen die Ostmullen die Brandmauer ein und da setzt sie sich
dann auch damit auseinander, wie jetzt diese Ostmullen wirken.
Und sie sagen, naja, das seien ja
vor allem sehr Verzweifelte und sehr Perspektivlose, die sich da zeigen.
Jetzt wird sehr viel darüber nachgedacht, wie ist das einzuordnen,
hat das einen politischen Ausschlag und jemand wie Martin Sellner,
also der Kopf der Identitären Bewegung,
der hat ja so eine oberflächliche Gramsci-Lektüre hinter sich und sieht ja überall
immer die neue Hegemonie, die man kulturell aufbaut.
Und der sieht natürlich hier beim Ostmollen-Dienstag, wie er auf Twitter schreibt,
einen metapolitischen Erfolg.
Also, ich glaube, der Sellner weiß ganz genau, wie das ist, wenn junge Männer
Internet benutzen und dass solche Frauen, die natürlich schon als junge Frauen Zugpferde sind,
Zugpferde für seine Bewegung sind oder für seine Denkrichtung.
Also dass das über einfache Instinkte läuft und so.
Und man das jetzt nicht so überideologisieren muss.
Ja, also er spricht dann auch von der Attraktivität der Frauen und wie wichtig
das ist, dass sie dann jetzt stattfinden.
Er glaubt, dass sich mehr anschließen werden und das werde dann zu einem metapolitischen
Perpetuum mobile und und und.
Ähnlich geht das auch hier. Es ist vor allem gegen links und das ist ja genau
das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast. Was ist eigentlich Konservatismus?
Wissen wir nicht, aber es geht gegen links und so hier dann auch.
Also ich würde nicht so weit gehen sagen, dass es reine Unterhaltung ist,
weil in dem Moment, wo es halt politisch ist, es ist Provokation und dadurch
hat es auch automatisch eine Stoßrichtung und die Richtung ist halt eben auch in unserer Richtung.
Und zwar wollen wir jetzt nicht unter der Reichsflagge tanzen,
aber wir haben ja ein Problem mit linker Meinungshegemonie und mit linken Dogmen
und gedanklichen und sprachlichen Zwängen
und die werden ja durch diese Ostmullbewegung ja quasi pulverisiert.
Das ist ja nicht irgendwie jemand, der sagt, ja, ich habe ein Problem mit der
Meinungsfreiheit, ich würde gerne besser meine Meinung sagen können,
sondern das sind einfach hunderte, wenn nicht tausende junger Frauen,
die einfach aus dem Nichts somit das Rechteste machen, was man in Deutschland
machen kann, ohne halt strafrechtlich verfolgt zu werden.
Finden Sie gut. Selner schreibt bei Twitter, natürlich ist vieles von dem,
was die Damen darstellen, nicht unser gesellschaftliches Ideal oder neue rechte Ideologie.
Hier geht es aber auch nicht um Gesimpe oder blindes Abfeiern,
sondern um die Analyse eines bisher ziemlich einmaligen Phänomens.
Also man ist wahrscheinlich auch erstmal vorhin, dass es überhaupt Frauen gibt,
die jetzt da mitmachen bei den Rechten.
Mich wundert es nicht so sehr, da die ja natürlich in diesen oft ländlichen
Gegenden sozialisiert sind.
Die Perspektivlosigkeit ist groß und dann sind dann irgendwelche Typen,
die ein bisschen mit den Identitären oder dem dritten Weg oder sonst wem zu
tun haben. und der sieht aber auch irgendwie ganz süß aus, das könnte mein künftiger Freund sein.
Ach so, die wollen irgendwie, dass ich auch eine Deutschlandfahne aufhänge, mache ich das auch.
Also es scheint so eine Geschichte zu sein, dass das einfach die normale,
Sozial, ja normalen Anführungszeichen, die normale Sozialisation von jungen
Menschen jetzt in Landstrichen ist, die einfach völlig vernachlässigt sind.
Also das ist ja sagen wir auch etwas für diejenigen, die nicht davongekommen
sind, die da geblieben sind oder da bleiben mussten.
Typischerweise sind ja solche Frauen eigentlich immer davongekommen.
Also die Auswanderungswellen wurden ja vor allem von den Frauen angeführt.
Aber auch interessant, besagter Freund, mit dem ich gestern sprach,
sagte dann, da sind also diese jungen Frauen bei Tinder mit den Deutschlandfahnen
und dem Ich bin stolz und und und.
Und dann kann man durch die Bilder durchsweiten, diesen Jungen,
18, 19, sagt er dann häufig, die mehrere Bilder da haben und auf dem letzten
Bild zeigen sie sich dann mit Kind.
Das heißt, sie sind sehr früh Mutter geworden und dann aber auch alleinerziehend
und haben aber jetzt so irgendwie so einen Patriotismus sich über das Internet
wahrscheinlich antrainiert oder so ein bisschen aus der,
Umgebung gespeist.
Wir hören mal weiter, was diese Grauzone-Leute dazu sagen.
Ich würde an der Stelle erstmal meinerseits klarstellen,
dass ich dieses Phänomen auch extrem witzig finde und dem auch einen extrem
hohen Unterhaltungswert zuspreche und jetzt auch nicht Stirnrunzle und das irgendwie abtue.
Also ich habe immer irgendwo ein großes Interesse für diese Netzkultur,
vor allem wenn die so spontan und graswurzelig und scheinbar ungesteuert entsteht.
Also mich fasziniert das und das auch in wirklich anderen Kontexten.
Und das ist ja das, was ich gerne sage, dass wenn Deutschland noch eines kann, dann ist es Memen.
Ich würde sagen, wenn die Rechten noch irgendwas können, dann ist es Memen.
Das ist die einzige Kultur, die sie haben.
Und es ist natürlich wieder das Typische. Wir wissen, wie Facebook angefangen
hat, also wie Mark Zuckerberg angefangen hat. Er hat ein Portal gemacht mit
Bildern von Studentinnen, die man bewerten konnte.
Hot or not. Das war eigentlich das Prinzip.
Und nach diesem Prinzip funktioniert ja der Algorithmus heute immer noch bei vielen Plattformen.
Und das ist ja was, was jetzt die rechten Männer sowieso gerne machen.
Und deswegen wird auch in diesen Podcasts, in denen sich mit Ostmuld auseinandergesetzt
wird, laufend über das Aussehen gesprochen.
Das spektrum der ostmull ist halt relativ breit weil
du hast halt schon wirklich hübsche nicht
gepierste nicht tätowierte junge ostdeutsche frauen und du hast halt wirklich
komplette katastrophe am anderen ende und übrigens auch wenn man wieder einer
behauptet deutsche sehen alle gleich aus also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
man sieht dass der ostmull auch wirklich aus dem osten ist weil die frauen haben dann ganz,
typisches Aussehen, finde ich. Also ich bin der Meinung, ich kann das erkennen.
Also man findet jetzt schon so eine Fan-Typologie dann bei denen.
Das ist so ein begeisterter Rassismus plötzlich, dass man so,
ich sehe voll, dass die aus dem Osten sind.
Ellen Kositzer, schon erwähnt, hat sich dazu geäußert, zu diesem Phänomen und
schreibt, wie gesagt, ich mag diese Ostmullen auch, weil meine Liebe zur Außenseit
dann fast grenzenlos ist, aber ich setze keinerlei Hoffnung auf diesen Trend.
Sie beschreibt dann, wie sie selbst aus dem Westen kommend irgendeinen Freiraum
suchte, wo man nicht so wie in Westdeutschland sein muss, wo noch Terra incognita
ist. Das hatten sie dann in Schnellroda gefunden.
Sie haben dann direkten Nachbarn gehabt, der sie mit dem Hitlergruß begrüßt hat.
Mit dem seien sie dann aber gut zurechtgekommen. Der hat dann auch für einen,
wie sie schreibt, gerechten Lohn
Dachpappe von unseren Dielen geföhnt und gerissen und dort gearbeitet.
Und die Freundinnen, die wechselten immer wieder, aber sie waren alle stark
tätowiert und das waren also Ostmullen, die sie da erlebt hat und sie sagt aber
jetzt, also die Frauen, die man dort sieht,
die stammen aus keinem gesunden Elternhaus, sie kennt keine Ostmulle aus einem gesunden Elternhaus.
Sie schreibt in Anführungszeichen, meine Ostmullen haben Kinderheim,
Abtreibung, Psychiatrische Klinik, gewaltvolle Beziehungen etc.
Pp. in ihrer Bio stehen. Also sie bringt hier ja die soziale Komponente,
wo man wieder sagen muss, genau und die wird ja unbeantwortet,
Der Staat lässt Mütter allein.
Wenn jetzt hier schon ein erwähnter Freund sagt, ja, viele der jungen Frauen
mit Deutschlandfage zeigen sich auch schon mit Kind auf dem Arm,
dann bestätigt das natürlich auch nochmal das und würde wieder zu dem führen,
was jetzt Isabella Weber sagt.
Ja, wir brauchen eine antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik, die zum Beispiel
dann bedeutet, dass Frauen nicht so im Stich gelassen werden,
dass die ihnen dann nur noch so eine Radikalisierung über das Internet schlagen.
Bleibt. Interessanterweise schließt dann Ellen Kositzer ihren Text über die
Ostmolen damit, dass sie sagt, sie kämpfen ihre Kämpfe, sie sind die Nemesis der BRD,
gut, dass es sie gibt, besser, wenn man sie nach oben holen könnte,
nicht man, sondern wir, woher die Kraft dazu kommen wird, weiß ich nicht.
Also das ist so das große Projekt, da müssen wir eigentlich hin.
Wir springen mal gerade zu dem Clip von AfD-Politiker Joachim Paul aus Rheinland-Pfalz.
Der hat sich auch schon zum Ostenmullen-Phänomen geäußert.
Der Ostmullendienstag ist der vielleicht größte metapolitische Erfolg der letzten
Jahre, wenn nicht sogar Jahrzehnte.
Es werden natürlich einige sagen, ja, Mulle ist das nicht ein abwertender Begriff für Frau.
Würde ich sagen nicht. Es kommt immer darauf an, was man aus dem Begriff macht,
wie man ihn auflädt. Das muss der politisch aktive Mensch wissen.
Und es zeigt auch, dass unsere deutsche Sprache lebendig ist.
Wir brauchen keine Anglizismen irgendwoher und müssen dann mit denen...
Ja, die Sprache ist lebendig.
Wir können hier umgehen, sondern wir können selbst Worte entwickeln,
Worte aufladen und dann politisch wirken lassen.
Und deswegen kann ich nur sagen, ich möchte den jungen Frauen gratulieren zum
Ostmullendienstag und hoffe natürlich, dass es bald auch einen Westmullentag gibt.
Wahlweise Donnerstag oder Samstag. Und ich bin gespannt auf eure Videos.
Macht weiter so. Rüttelt an den Grundfesten des Systems. Das ist euer Auftrag.
Doch.
Man nimmt sich noch die letzten Strohhalme, um mal irgendwie eine Sinnhaftigkeit
ins eigene Denkgebäude...
Ja. Dann gibt es so einen rechten Podcaster, der heißt Let's Make Money.
Der spricht auch über dieses Phänomen.
Bündet sich auch Ost und West gemeinsam.
Dass die Ostmullen im größten Teil wirklich starke, selbstbewusste Frauen sind.
Keine Männerhasser, auch ganz wichtig.
Und ja, wie gesagt,
Jette Nitzat, die kriegt ja gratis Mut geschenkt.
Das ist jetzt die von den Grünen, meint der Vorsitzende.
Ihre politische Ausrichtung, ihren Männerhass und so, der ist ja salonfähig sozusagen.
Den zu präsentieren, da braucht man keinen Mut, da braucht man überhaupt nichts.
Aber die Mädels, die lehnen sich gegen den Mainstream auf, gegen ihre Lehrer
lehnen sie sich auf, gegen die Politik, gegen die Eltern im Endeffekt.
Das sind starke Mädchen für mich, starke Frauen für mich und ich denke,
sie werden die Gesellschaft viel weiter bringen und im Gegensatz zu einer Jette
Nizza auch keine Gefahr darstellen.
Ja, gerne eure Meinung zu dieser ganzen Ostmullenbewegung,
Ostmullendienstag, sollte man das eventuell nicht auch so langsam mal im Westen
einführen und dadurch vielleicht dann sogar zusammenarbeiten.
Ich glaube, bei TikTok kann man ja auch zusammen Videos machen.
Mach doch mal eine Westmulle mit einer Ostmulle zusammen, um uns als deutsches
Volk auch wieder zusammenzubringen, dass endlich diese Ost-West-Grenze wegkommt.
Weil die, finde ich, grauenvoll.
Und der Westen kann da jetzt in dem Fall vielleicht noch viel vom Osten lernen.
Ja, die sind einfach alle verblendet. Die wissen nicht, wie wir hier leben.
Und dass es das hier gar nicht gibt.
Und hier auch niemand da ist, der plötzlich so je gummigen Videos macht.
Aber das können die sich nicht vorstellen. Die glauben ja, also sehr viele AfD-Wähler,
die so ein bisschen aktivistischer drauf sind, also die schon mal ein YouTube-Video
drehen oder so, glauben ja wirklich, es ist nur noch so ein missionarischer Weg zu gehen.
Aber eigentlich, man muss den Leuten nur noch Bescheid sagen.
Aber wir alle kennen jetzt die AfD. Und die Leute haben sich jetzt so entschieden.
Also diese Perspektivlosigkeit junger Menschen kannst du natürlich schon auch
in westlichen Gefilden antreffen.
Ja, dass wir keine rebellische Jugendkultur haben, ist auch ein echtes Problem, so wirtschaftlich.
Ja, ja, also das ist ja auch, selbst die, die es jetzt gab, also die Aktivisten
waren ja derart staatstragend, dass man schon fast dachte, warum geht der nicht
gleich in die Partei und macht es von dort aus.
Das ist schon auch ein Problem. Außerdem jetzt zum Abschluss noch zwei Clips
von auch einem kleinen YouTuber,
der auch schon mit Kursitzer zu tun hatte, der im Hintergrund ein Kruzifix hängen
hat, also der offenbar katholisch ist und der den Namen Lukas Kurtial hat.
Der hat jetzt seine These zu den Ostmollen.
Wir haben halt die Freiheit, und das hat auch Bischof Williamson mal gesagt,
wir haben aktuell die Freiheit, uns halt zu verderben. Und das machen sehr viele Menschen auch.
Und ich stelle mir die Frage, was wäre mit diesen Frauen, wenn die Leute noch an Gott glauben würden?
Wären die dann so verloren, wie sie es sind? Und was können wir dafür tun,
auch als Christen, um diesen Bevölkerungsgruppen, die da im Osten verweilen.
Wieder Gott näher zu bringen. Im Osten verweilen. Wir hatten das ja schon mal,
bei den Schneller-Oder-Leuten.
Wir hatten dann mal im Podcast, als glaube ich auch Krada zu Gast war,
dieses Thema Katholizismus.
Wie kriegt man eigentlich dieses so heidnische Ostdeutschland wieder rechristianisiert?
Das ist ja für Ellen Kositze auch so ein ganz großes Thema.
Und es scheint so diese Strömung zu sein.
Jetzt sagt man, jetzt muss Da sind also Mädels, die aufbegehren im Kinderzimmer,
jetzt müssen wir die noch zu Gott führen, denn die große Klammer und damit sind
wir schon fast wieder bei unserer Debatte Wehrpflicht und was müssen Frauen für den Staat tun.
Er will nicht, dass jetzt über die Frauen und ihr Aussehen zu abwertend gesprochen
wird, denn für ihn erfüllen die natürlich in erster Linie eine Funktion als
Frauen. Du ahnst, worauf das hinausläuft.
Und es sind garantiert nicht die Frauen, die uns jetzt den metapolitischen Sieg bringen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sind es halt auch unsere Frauen und sie werden auch Nachwuchsgebärin.
Das heißt, ein Stück weit sind sie halt auch unsere Verantwortung,
dass es so Frauen besser geht.
In dieser Situation befinden wir uns. Also das ist sicherlich eines der dunkelsten
Kapitel, die man so aktuell erleben kann, was die verschiedenen rechten Strömungen anbelangt.
Dass das so eine ganz individualisierte, rechte Ästhetik gemixt ist mit so ein
bisschen Vorstadt-Prolligkeit und ein bisschen zu sehr auf die Insta-Filter gesetzt und, und, und.
Und das vermischt sich dann zu so einem Deutschtum, das ja noch völlig...
Das ist ungefestigt, dass also jetzt von diesen verschiedenen Rechten schon
etablierteren Strömungen umgarnt wird und rübergezogen wird,
auf welche Seite und da wird dann auch nochmal eine Auslese betrieben.
Also es ist eigentlich ein unglaublich trauriges Phänomen.
Als ich das Ostmolen-Phänomen erst mal sah bei Twitter, dachte ich,
das ist kurios, ich bringe es mal mit, weil es irgendwie auch lustig ist und
je mehr ich mir davon angesehen habe, habe ich nur noch eigentlich eine tiefe
Traurigkeit darüber verspürt, was da ist.
Und da muss man ganz klar sagen, das Ostmolen-Phänomen ist aus einem,
hier kann man den Begriff ruhig mal nehmen, Staatsversagen entstanden,
dass da ganz viel nicht mehr ist und in gewisser Weise hat eine Ellen Kositzer das erkannt.
Die will das natürlich dann von rechts lösen mit ihren Leuten,
aber eigentlich die Diagnose von ihr ist nicht falsch.
Ich finde sowieso, also wir haben jetzt die AfD dort stark, wo es ja gar keine
Ausländer gibt und Maurice Hörfgen hat jetzt bei sich auch nochmal so eine Auflistung,
irgendeine Datenquelle gehabt für die Frage, sind die Gemeinden gerade überlastet
mit Flüchtlingsunterbringung und so.
Und in den ostdeutschen Bundesländern sagen irgendwie 80%, 90%,
nein, kein nennenswertes Problem, hier ist niemand.
Gleichzeitig fragen wir uns natürlich, warum ist die AfD dann da so stark?
Und immer wenn es so spiegel-tv-artige Reportagen gibt zum Thema,
warum ist die AfD da so stark, ist einfach völlig klar, ja weil man da wohin
gehen kann, wo die AfD ist.
Diese Reportagen handeln nur von Zusammenkünften auf dem Parkplatz,
beim Vereinsfest, auf dem Schulhof, was auch immer.
Also man müsste hier gar nicht, klar, Staatsversagen ist es,
weil es da so einen Versorgungsauftrag gibt, aber Versorgung von was?
Und wir kommen immer wieder auf dieses Gemeinschaft, Geselligkeit,
Zeitvertreib und so weiter und so fort.
Der Erste, der ein ordentliches Angebot macht, aber ja, wenn man es staatlich
organisiert, ist es teuer.
Der Staat könnte ja zumindest mal so in so Förderstrukturen gehen und sagen,
wir gucken hier so ein bisschen drauf, in welche Richtung ihr euch entwickelt
und davon abhängig ist dann.
Wird ja weggestrichen. Ich habe ja auch jetzt gerade mit jemandem gesprochen
aus dem Osten, der dort hilft,
Leute einzugliedern, wo schulisch einige Brüche waren und wo man also eine intensivere
Betreuung braucht, als das so üblich ist, ein Lehrer, 28 Schüler oder so,
sondern 1 zu 1 Betreuung zum Teil, Leute auf den Weg bringen.
Ja ist dann eine Förderung kommt nicht mehr und dann fallen einfach dann acht
Stellen weg und dann sind die auch noch dem ausgeliefert ich hatte,
vor Jahren diesen Film besprochen Lord of the Toys,
der handelte von diesem YouTuber Adlerson der nicht so richtig recht zu verorten
ist, aber auch immer damit so spielte mit gewissen Insignien und da war ganz
interessant, da waren nämlich dann diese jungen Leute zu sehen,
die sich da um ihn scharrten und dann waren sie auf irgendeinem Volksfest und
sonst wo und da waren dann auch schon so gewisse Mädels, die man jetzt wahrscheinlich
heute als Ostenmullen bezeichnet und die hatten dann schon ihren Freund,
der beim dritten Weg war.
Und das war aber noch zugleich so völlig unpolitisch und politisch,
also so eine ganz merkwürdige Mischung und da hat man das schon sehr deutlich
gesehen und jetzt hat es noch einen Begriff dafür und ist mit dem Hashtag versehen.
Ja, das ist einfach alles nicht gut. Zum Abschluss. Das Internet ist tot.
Ja.
Ja, das sind jetzt Nachrichten aus Mai, 16. Mai, in dem Falle aus dem Big Technology Podcast.
Also, Google, weiß man, Auflistung von Webseiten, da klickt man die an und so weiter.
Und GPT, weiß man, kriegt man eine Antwort, klickt nichts an.
So, dieses Phänomen leicht beschrieben, einfach verstanden.
Nur gab es jetzt die Zahlen dazu. SimilarWeb ist so ein Dienstanbieter.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie machen, aber das ganze Internet rauscht einmal
trafficmäßig durch deren Server. Deswegen haben die so ein bisschen Überblick, was da passiert.
Und alle, alle verlieren außer OpenAI.
Yeah, so this is some amazing data that's coming from SimilarWeb.
Sam Altman just actually referenced it in his testimony, his testimony before
US Congress. And you take a look at it, and it is fascinating.
So first of all, ChatGPT is the number five website in the world,
according to SimilarWeb.
You have Google first, then YouTube, Facebook, and Instagram,
and then number five is ChatGPT. So, that in and of itself is a very interesting development.
But the other thing that is really worth calling out, now of course this is
desktop and we know everybody's moving to mobile, but if you look at the traffic
change month over month,
Google, YouTube, Facebook, Instagram, all going down.
ChatGPT up 13% month over month. Then everything else that follows X,
WhatsApp, Wikipedia, Reddit, Yahoo Japan, all going down.
And so ChatGPT stands alone here. And that leads me to sort of like the title
of our first segment here. Is ChatGPT the last website?
Offenbar ja, denn es ist ja wirklich diese Frage, wie oft besuchen eigentlich noch Menschen?
Und im Verhältnis dazu Maschinen, Webseiten.
Ich habe auch jetzt im vergangenen Monat mehr ChatGPT denn je benutzt und zwar
nicht, weil ich irgendwas Großes wollte,
sondern weil ich einfache Fragen hatte von statistischen Daten bis hin zu Worterklärungen
und habe einfach diese Seite offen gehabt und habe es immer gerade da eingegeben.
Wurde nicht von Werbung belästigt, bekam das, bekam gleich auch noch eine detailliertere
Auflistung, als ich es erwartet hatte.
Habe also unglaublich viel Zeit dort verbracht und Google wirklich nur noch
für Google Maps und sonst findet das bei mir kaum statt.
Perplexity ist dann noch da. Bei Perplexity ist ja ganz interessant,
dass die ja auch mit Werbung rumgespielt haben, was sich ja gar nicht wohl rechnen scheint.
Also es ist so, dass die, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe, ich glaube im Doppelgänger-Podcast
war das, dass Perplexity mit dem Werbemodell 20.000 Dollar eingespielt hat.
Ja, wird schon ein bisschen mehr gewesen sein.
Es war wirklich ganz gering.
Was ja bedeutet, wir bezahlen jetzt alle für unsere Chatbots.
Mindestens 20 Euro, manchmal 200, wie auch immer. und dann ist ja die Frage,
Für was und an wen bezahlen wir? Dieses Geld wird ja nicht weitergereicht, an Wikipedia oder so.
Obwohl wir nur noch Fragen stellen, die uns die Wikipedia beantworten könnte,
wenn wir nur nicht so faul wären und dann einfach die punktuelle,
den Ziel ohne Weg, wir haben es ja besprochen.
Also das Internet verwandelt sich immer mehr zu so einem Internet der Maschinen.
75% der Quereien zu Google, hat Google auf die Frage gestellt,
ohne Sie zurück zu der originalen Sorge. But even in the last 6 months,
the rate has increased further.
Now it's up to 15 to 1. So 15 crawls for every visitor.
So Google in 6 months has gone from 6 to 1 to 15 to 1.
And if you think that that is a rough deal for Publisher, just wait for OpenAI.
OpenAI, I think he says, is 250 to 1.
And Anthropic is 6,000 to 1.
Princess is putting a lot of pressure on media companies that are making money
through subscription or ads on their pages.
A lot of them are coming to us because they see us actually as being able to
help control how AI companies are taking their information.
Also als Blogger wie ich stefanschulz.com bist du jetzt wieder Avantgarde,
machst etwas, was sonst keiner macht und Claude greift 6000 mal auf meine Seite
zu, bis irgendwann mal jemand über Claude angeleitet bei mir vorbeikommt.
Das heißt, du schreibst in erster Linie für Claude deine Texte für Maschinen,
freust dich, dass sie die lesen und wenn es gut läuft, führen sie dir auch noch einen Menschen zu.
Naja, es ist so ein bisschen, genau, ich brauche ja nicht zwingend jetzt den
echten Menschen in meinem Text.
Ich denke, der wird ja rausgeschickt per E-Mail, Leute können den lesen irgendwann
oder wenn sie Geld dafür zahlen, kriegen sie ihn vorgelesen als Podcast.
Nur man hat halt seinen kleinen Kreis an Lesern.
Wenige hunderttausend, keine Ahnung, wie viel es so sind.
Und die ganze Zeit rauscht aber irgend so ein Crawler die ganze Zeit vorbei
und belastet meinen Server.
Also spielt jetzt nicht so die mega Rolle. Ich habe so einen Pauschal-Host irgendwie.
Aber ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein echtes Phänomen zumindest mal,
dass man sich jetzt künftig auch fragt, Booking.com, müssen wir überhaupt noch
eine Webseite machen oder reicht es einfach so API-Ausgänge,
dass die Chatbots einfach darauf zugreifen?
An Shopping schreibt er die großen Standards, denen sich jetzt auch erstmal
alle verschreiben. Auch, weil es so eine große plurale Welt ist.
Es hat sich noch keiner durchgesetzt und kann einfach einen Standard durchdrücken.
Also in der Hinsicht geht es schon relativ wenig proprietär zu,
aber es wird halt grundsätzlich so ein KI-Internet.
Was halt wirklich zu der Frage führt, wer schreibt demnächst noch in die Wikipedia was rein?
Die Welt bewegt sich ja weiter und da müssen ja Sachen reingeschrieben werden. Es passieren ja Sachen.
Und es wäre schon schön, wenn die Aufmerksamkeit noch so ein bisschen bei der
Wikipedia, also dass man mal die Seite sieht und dann ah ja,
da oben ist der Spendenbutton, sie suchen Geld und unten kann man sich anmelden und selber schreiben.
Man hat ja gar keinen pädagogischen Zugang mehr zu solchen Prinzipien.
In der Hinsicht steht ein echtes Problem. Wir hören also einfach noch zwei kleine
Clips, in denen es auf den Punkt gebracht wird.
Die einzige Frage ist, dass die Incentives weggehen, um Menschen zu stoppen,
zu schreiben, über neue Dinge zu verbrechen.
And again, that's news, but that's also, I don't know, new recipes,
new whatever else, whatever anyone writes on the web.
If there's no economic incentive, we still have certain places and communities
like Reddit and stuff where people post for the love or social media platforms
in general, which become pretty interesting assets on their own.
But otherwise, web pages existing with new content on them.
To me, even more so as we're talking, I'm going to move away from,
we had downgraded the web is dead to the web is in secular decline.
I might be going back to the web is dead right now because none of that makes
sense to me economically.
Web is dead and Wikipedia is done.
I mean, one of the sort of stats that I kind of glanced over,
but I think is kind of the most interesting thing here is that ChatGPT has overtaken Wikipedia.
So ChatGPT is site number five
and Wikipedia is eight. To me that's basically like Wikipedia is done.
Ja, also ich finde das sehr schade. Wir brauchen so ein Stöber-Internet.
Wir können nicht alle nur in Social Media rumhängen und von Bild zu Bild swipen,
sondern ich habe zumindest jetzt mal wieder nach Jahren die Erfahrung gemacht,
ein Sachbuch zu lesen und nach jeder Seite immer in der Wikipedia noch mal kurz
nachzulesen und hier und da und dann vertieft man sich da so und es dauert alles
ewig. Aber es kommt halt echt was bei rum.
Ja.
Und wenn das einfach nicht mehr geht, weil es immer weniger braucht und so,
dass diese Infrastruktur gar nicht mehr so betreut wird, haben wir hier ein
echtes Problem, glaube ich.
Deswegen, Leute, bloggen. Macht euch wieder einen Blog.
Und einmal im Monat einen kleinen Text. Das kriegt ja wohl jeder hin.
Und Bücher lesen. Womit wir nochmal hinweisen auf unseren Salon.
Wir sprechen über das Buch Geoökonomie, Anatomie der neuen Weltordnung von Milan
Babic, erschienen bei Surkamp.
Das ist das Buch, darüber, dass wir uns dann intensiv austauschen werden im
Salon, was es sonst noch im Salon dann gibt.
Ich kann nur ankündigen, diesmal werde ich keine klassische Musik empfehlen, sondern Jazz.
Wer hätte es gedacht.
Wenn es nicht klassisch ist.
Dann Jazz.
Jetzt gibt es Jazz und alles andere werde ich mir noch ein bisschen offen halten,
aber ich habe sehr viele interessante Texte im Petto. Wie ist es bei dir?
Ich werde wahrscheinlich mal in dieses, es scheint dicker zu sein, aber Apple in China.
Das ich so interessant finde, wie die da einfach diese Infrastruktur hochgezogen haben und überhaupt.
Und weil sie jetzt auch so im Kieker sind, so im Fokus von Trump.
Mal sehen, ob in Gänze oder Auszüge.
Das ist sicherlich lohnenswert. Man kann den Podcast ganz einfach abonnieren über Steady.
Es ist am allerbesten.
Dort gibt es das vollständige Archiv.
Man geht einfach auf neu20er.de, auf den goldenen Button, kommt dann zu Steady
und wenn man das dann abonniert hat, dann muss man nicht auf der Steady-Seite verweilen.
Man muss auch nicht auf den PC die ganze Zeit starren und gucken,
ob der Podcast läuft, sondern man bekommt einen RSS-Suite.
Den kann man so kopieren und kann überall den immer so hören.
Wie man jetzt gerade uns auch hört, kann man sagen, jetzt will ich so weit hören.
Das ist auf jeden Fall möglich.
Bei Patreon funktioniert das ähnlich. Wenn man jetzt bei.
Apple ist und sagt, ich will da gar nicht weg und zahl lieber 50 Cent mehr,
bevor ich jetzt nochmal mich wo neu anmelde, kann man auch den Salon ganz einfach
dort direkt buchen, hat dann dort auch genau das Apple-Erlebnis, das man immer hat.
Und ich glaube, wir erleben jetzt gerade, dass die Podcasts ja eine Disruption
bekommen dadurch, dass diese Plattformen und vor allem auch Spotify es dazu
nennen oder in erster Linie zu nennen,
die ja so sehr daran interessiert sind, dass man den Podcast dort hostet,
dass man ja im Prinzip so eine Art Angestellter von Spotify wird.
Von daher ist es auch echt sehr wichtig, und das meint jetzt nicht nur unseren
Podcast, sondern generell Podcast zu unterstützen,
dass sie nicht in diese Arme von Spotify da bekommen, sondern dass man schon
auch noch sagt, Podcast bedeutet eigentlich,
dass etwas überall zu hören ist und nicht nur da.
Und von daher sind diese Unterstützungsmodelle, die es da gibt für Podcast,
neben der Werbung, die aber momentan ja auch sehr brach liegt,
wie man in vielen Podcasts hört.
Das scheint ein schwieriges Feld gerade zu sein. Ist das also eine Möglichkeit,
Podcasts zu unterstützen?
Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut.
Und noch einmal der Hinweis, live sind wir dann als echte Menschen auf einer Bühne zu erleben am 23.
August. Stefan hält eine kleine Andacht oder so. Wir werden gucken.
Also wir werden eine Predigt machen.
Nur zu.
Zum Gottesdienst.
Also am 23. August und dann sehen wir uns in wenigen Tagen im Salon.
So ist es. Bis dann.